I don't think we watched this before.
I think we only watched the briefings.
I don't think this is the same as...
No, it didn't, right?
Alaska.
That's where snakes don't belong.
That was an audio, by the way, guys.
Let me know.
It's always confusing for me because the El Gato says
something different than what my mixer says.
It's good?
The nuclear weapons disposal facility on Shadow Moses Island
in Alaska's Fox Archipelago was attacked and captured by
next generation special forces being led by members of
Foxhound.
Look at that guy.
They are demanding that the government turn over the remains
of Big Boss.
And they say that if their demands are not met within 24
hours, audio good?
They'll launch a nuclear weapon.
who's that oh it doesn't matter who he is Roy Campbell says
you don't matter I'm in charge of this here mission also I
just realized he has the Fox town logo on his first you're
to rescue DARPA chief Donald why does he have the Fox town
logo on his jacket secondly you're to investigate whether or
not the terrorists have the ability to make a nuclear strike
and stop them if they do Naomi Hunter I wonder what Hunter
is in Germany by sub it's his old jacket yeah I know he was
Fox Town you'd think though that like you wouldn't want to
wear something that the terrorists are wearing like are
associating themselves with you know what I mean you'd think
that you'd want to be like hmm I'm not with them
Wow!
Oh my god, he's speed.
After the SDV gets as close as it can.
Yeah.
Dispose of it.
Oh, get rid of it.
That's so wasteful.
High tech special forces unit Foxhound.
Your former unit.
Sorry, I know it probably feels like we just like jumped
right into it.
So they're still around.
This is just playing the intro, you know?
There are six members of Foxhound involved in this terrorist
activity.
A little, a little refresher, right?
abilities the sushi the beautiful and deadly sharpshooter
decoy octopus master of disguise thanks sushi for the 20
good and revolver ocelot shaman specialist and interrogation
and a you pronounce it wrong colonel and finally giant and
shaman foxhound squad leader liquid snake liquid snake
Giant and shaman.
Big Pompey, welcome to Membush.
Thank you!
Mint is in the bandana.
Sheesh.
Oh, whoa!
There...
Were those always there?
I don't think so, right?
Maybe you should have abandoned it, Snake!
Maybe you should have gotten rid of it!
This is why we're messed up in the mission.
Because we're messed up in the head from all the clunks.
We have a concussion!
He covers the whole island.
I'll instruct you by codec after you reach your target.
Anyone going with me?
As always, this is a one-man sneaking mission.
Oh, yeah.
O-S-P.
Yes.
This is a top-secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
Whoa.
Drop my controller.
I'm so clumsy.
Wow.
Welcome back, welcome back,
welcome back.
I'm so glad Found You has stumbled upon you during a
difficult time in my life and your MGS playthroughs really
help take my mind on the things.
I'm glad that I could do a little bit to help with whatever
you were going through.
Bell's a hurry.
And hopefully you enjoy these playthroughs.
Also, talk strength is a here with a pink.
This got moved to Friday.
I told my manager I could not come into the office.
No!
What do you mean?
Don't.
No!
Oh my gosh, please.
Don't skip work because of...
There's a VOD, you know?
I'm Jago's.
Thank you so much for that 10 gifted.
Remy, thank you for the 5.
Johnny, thank you for the 5.
This is getting out of hand.
Now there's two.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Last time we left off with Merrill getting a little
pew-pewed.
She's kind of on the ground.
She's kind of bleeding out.
We kind of got to go get a PSG to save her.
but I I'm gonna turn down the music just a little bit I plan
on not saving her I'm sorry we are going to be doing the
Otacon ending so I think when I play when I replay the game
though I'll do the Meryl ending but for this one
specifically there's something that I want to see with the
Otacon ending so we'll be doing that of course Pirate Boat
thank you for the five gifted and anime thank you for the
vibe gifted ducky thank you for the vibe gifted thank you
guys the canon ending the best ending so sorry so sorry to
maryl tomorrow but um and i'm sorry again that i had to move
this um there was some stuff that came up uh some things
that i there was just it was a couple things um alvin thank
you for the vibe good to thank you um but uh i didn't want
to like cancel it obviously and i was like well i don't have
it what i was planning on doing on friday got moved and so i
was like okay i'll just shift a couple things around baby um
brick oh my gosh thank you for that thank you for the 50th
thank you so much oh maryl maryl you see you heard nothing
maryl you heard nothing Oh, shoot.
Okay, it has to be this one.
Right, it has to be this one.
Kia, welcome to membership.
Oh, boy, thank you for the gift.
Did it just give?
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Meryl, you're bleeding.
Stop hearing stuff.
Yeah, she's into...
She's in shock, you know?
Maybe sepsis.
I don't know.
Productivity.
Oh, good luck with work!
Yimayu!
Thank you for the final gift and thank you!
Meryl can become a Membu too.
Right before...
You know what?
It's perfect though if she joins Membusha because...
Actually, I am gonna move the Notifs because...
We'll move them like kind of over here.
So it's a little...
A little less invasive on the game.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Oh geez.
Okay.
Guys, give me a second to, uh...
To...
Oh, what is this?
Oh, there's a mission log.
I was just pressing yes.
To stop the terrorists' nuclear attack, Snake must
deactivate the detonation code or destroy Metal Gear itself.
Snake and Meryl head for the communications tower.
The communications tower.
The only way to the underground maintenance base.
Foxhound members, sniper wolf fires at them.
and maryl is badly wounded it is a trap to lure out snake
snake must get up here whoa wait that's maryl in the back
what i've never seen that before oh my god wait that's so
awesome sorry oh my gosh what that's so awesome what oh my
god um looks like are too so that's so cool oh my gosh even
when hurt she's hot so true Merrill is dying let's go this
is the last time we'll see Merrill actually alive this is
the last time we'll see Merrill alive snake must get a PSG 1
to beat wolf and save save Merrill Oh my gosh, it looks so
good.
Okay, I have a question.
When I'm excited about some things like this, do I sound
genuine?
Sometimes when I'm talking specifically to Matara, she'll
tell me something and I'll be like, Oh my gosh, that's cool.
And she's like, that's cool.
She kind of makes fun of me and she's like, you don't sound
like you mean it at all.
And I'm like, I do!
I'm like...
I'm...
But I'm actually excited.
You sound like a freak affectionate.
You know what?
You are a freak, Raymec.
You are a freak.
How about that?
Anyway.
I am excited.
I think... I get very excited, especially seeing new Yoji
Shinkawa art.
got the um the uh the novel version of peace walker and it
has so much art in it that i've never oh my god i was
freaking oh my gosh this is one beautiful picture of strange
love like looking up at um i don't know it's kind of hard to
tell if it's zeke or if it's like um the peace walker i
think it's the peace walker but you sound like a nerd so i
believe it stop liking that Stop liking, I can see, stop
liking that super chat.
You're too much of a nerd not to be genuine about your
excitement.
But yeah, there's this, like, gorgeous, gorgeous picture of
her, like, looking up.
And I was like, I just need these blown up and, like, on a,
like, framed.
Oh, my gosh, I want them so bad.
Thank you for the summertime.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's get going, baby.
Okay, this is a good little area to remember how to do
stuff, right?
Okay, so this is to fight.
B is to attack.
This is to crouch.
For those coming in, and maybe didn't watch part one, this
is my first time, well, I guess now, this is my second time
ever playing on a GameCube.
So I'm still... What is why?
Is it nothing?
Oh, no, that's the action button.
That's the action button.
If you were Ezekai to the MGS verse, who would you want to
be reborn as?
Oh, maybe Sunny.
I feel like she has the least amount of trauma.
Also, it would be so cute to just make them eggs every
morning.
And I can see...
I can see all the good snake Otacon goodness, right?
Mei Ling?
Practice putting away your gun.
We're good.
I think I got this.
I say, right now.
I say, okay, so we have to go back to the armory.
To all...
We have to go all the way back to the armory.
You know, it might be good to just...
Well, probably...
Maybe... Wait, teleport?
oh wait oh no we have to go through the nuke building we're
in the nuke building so if we go to the armory and then take
this then maybe we can go back hmm there's a psg on this
floor in the remake okay for what I understand that psg is a
what's the word is a uh tranquilizer version and yeah psg1t
and honestly the trank stuff having like doing fights with
the trank feels like it's you know like even though it
doesn't matter it doesn't truly matter like you know how is
how am i supposed to do sniper wolf scene if i use the trank
psg1 you know You are true VTuber and true Patriot Mint
Boss.
Thanks, Ronin!
I don't know.
You enjoy all the killing.
Only in this game.
Because it makes sense, right?
It's not in the spirit of the original work.
Exactly.
So I feel like I have to go all the way back.
Even though I don't want to.
I don't.
want to, but I feel like I have to.
We're just gonna hide over here while we wait.
Oh, it's open.
That was fast.
And up to one.
They die from trank overdose.
Maybe.
Oh my gosh, this area is scary.
This area is so scary.
Recently I have been feeling so sick.
And I was fine earlier.
Well, I was sick earlier and then I felt fine.
And now I'm starting to feel sick again.
Oh, no.
Okay, I think I'll be okay though.
Maybe it's just nerves.
Maybe it's just me being a little, like, little baby.
Go!
Ooh!
Nice for you!
Does he turn around?
Okay, this is our only chance.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
He doesn't see me, right?
Okay.
This guy's gonna turn?
He doesn't come down, though.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, sheesh, so we almost started out real crazy.
Wait, okay.
So, just a box!
Just a box!
I can't see where everybody is.
Where are you guys anyway?
I can't see it all.
Okay, I'm just gonna go.
I don't know if we can make it into the...
Why are your footsteps so loud, Snake?
There we go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Motion.
I think, um, I think I'm doomed.
Um, just a box!
Just a box!
Just a box to the heliport!
To the heliport, please!
No!
I didn't, oh gosh.
Um,
uh, oh, I can't use- you guys can't use weapons here either!
Um, you guys can't use weapons here!
box bags thank you get out of here oh shoot uh that's why
they have their little masks on this is messed up come on
stick wait why did that happen to you oh go crawl crawl
crawl crawl here okay okay something over wait oh um am i
dead no way you can't do this be me me me here and I use the
box.
Will it work?
I wonder.
To the heliport, please!
Okay.
Wow.
That was so... Great start, everybody.
Great start.
That's okay.
That's so unfair that they can use weapons here.
No way.
That is so unfair.
I feel... I feel...
Like, that they should also just, you know, that is so
unfair.
These guys' manomachines don't care if uranium leaks from
shooting the nukes.
They just want to see the world burn.
They're gas masks, I can guarantee you.
I picked up the same gas mask that they are wearing, and it
is not any better.
It is not any better than, you know, I probably could, like,
knock this guy out, but whatever.
Okay.
Let me get down to this.
Oh, oh, right here.
Right here.
Snake.
There you go.
Right there.
Okay.
It is not any better than what I'm using.
So these guys should be down just as much as I am.
Ugh.
Maybe the mask doesn't fit right.
What are you saying?
I'll have a small face or a big face.
Okay, you know what?
I'm just gonna leave.
I'm not even gonna...
Take this special way.
We're just gonna go the long way.
We're gonna...
Let's go.
Go through the door.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Is there anything over here?
Oh!
Do I need any ration?
Yes.
Nice.
Do I need also mind detectors here again?
Can't ever remember.
Oh, wow.
Let's just...
Wait, there's actually people?
Wait, there's people, people?
Oh!
Oh my god, there's a person!
Since when?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
No no sir.
You seriously didn't see anything.
Where are you?
Oh, are you coming around this way?
Just your imagination, dummy.
Can I hit him through here?
That'd be crazy.
You can't see me through the...
There we go.
Huh.
Wow, the cameras are kind of crazy out here!
Um, hello?
He didn't even notice my footsteps.
What?
Uh, uh, this guy is totally new at the job.
Uh, how do I get around here?
Okay, its range is kind of insane.
You know what, maybe I should...
Why am I making life harder for myself?
Oh, who saw me?
Oh, oh, someone saw me.
Oh, oh, there's people here!
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Uh, warning shots!
Warning, warning shots at you!
I can't see anything.
Where the hell are you?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Uh, let's run.
Oh, that's a person.
Ouch!
I tried attacking you, and I don't know what happened.
Um, let me in!
Let me in!
Why is everything so bad today?
Um, ouch.
Hello?
Oh!
I keep pressing the wrong...
Leave me alone!
Oh, this is a fight.
Oh, come on, man.
Yeah, CQC.
Something, something.
Basics of CQC.
Oh!
I thought I would be safe over here.
I thought there was nobody.
I didn't.
I should have just stuck right here.
Oh, this sucks, you guys.
Oh, my God.
This sucks.
Ah, what a terrible area.
I thought there were only just cameras out here.
I have to worry about people now, too.
This is the worst.
shoot.
Don't make me go through this again.
Please, God.
And I can't even hit.
I can't even aim.
Oh, ah!
Come investigate you!
Oh.
This needs to be a backup unit.
That's ridiculous.
Why would there need to be a backup unit?
Why would there need to be a... Oh, God.
Oh, God.
Why isn't it aiming?
Hello, gun.
Oh, there it is.
Because I need to press a button.
Sir, just go down.
Oh my gosh.
Why am I going this way?
Should I just go back?
I think I should just...
I hit him, right?
Maybe it's too far.
Don't kick him.
It does?
he just fell asleep twice like a big old bozo the other way
looks easier now it actually does oh uh there we go okay
come here go back to sleep and we're gonna go back inside oh
shit yep okay what
a waste of my time what a waste of my time i almost to just
get the look at he's like stomping down he's just as mad as
i he's like what if they were not supposed to be guys there
this is this what the heck did they why did they add more
security to the i'm just so angry i could just where's their
men i i swear those guys they shouldn't even realize that he
hasn't reported those so quickly i just can't with them
sometimes they want to be actually want to be 180 IQ it's
just not fair that's literally me I can't shoot for me oh
wait I can't shoot at all I can't shoot at all oh god maybe
the book would help you there's
the camera here hey boss I got to go I promise to watch the
mod later thank you good luck with whatever you're doing or
have fun gl hf good luck have fun isn't there a truck here
there is it's just that i got spotted so quickly before that
i was like you know what i'm not gonna bother but oh here
comes this guy oh you did not see me no um absolutely
not excuse me
That was insane.
Time to crawl, crawl, crawl, crawl.
Crawl, crawl, crawl, crawl.
Box, box.
Oh, I was like, what do you mean, no use?
Don't tell me that.
It's so scary when they say that.
Okay, the camera is right there.
I can probably go in here.
Oh.
We don't see the other guy.
Okay.
Sure, sure, sure, sure.
Yep, yep, yep.
Okay, I think I see them meeting up.
They're doing their kissing.
I think I need to go.
Slow and steady.
I don't know where the other guy is.
That's why I'm trying to be so cautious.
I want to get caught.
Okay.
Wait.
No, that's the guy up there.
Where?
Okay, so he takes a really long time to get around here.
There he is.
Okay.
Surveillance camera.
Oh, yes.
Here they are.
They're meeting up.
Nope.
Get up.
Snake.
Snake, please.
God.
Okay.
All right.
We're all good.
Notice me.
I'm just a little far away.
I'm just a precious, innocent little box.
I just want to go to the heliport.
Is this all there is to load?
Mm-hmm.
To the heliport, huh?
Yeah.
Take me there!
Oh my gosh!
I'm just a little box!
You know what?
I feel like we haven't heard that line very much this time.
I feel like usually when I play this I always hear Huh?
Just a box But this time I haven't heard it like at all Okay
I have some magazines here You know what I am going to set
one right there And I'm going to crawl under Because I think
this guy Oh See?
Let him get distracted by that And we're going to take this
guy
We're going to Oh We're going to get you in the legs.
And he's going to fall asleep for real.
He was sleeping.
Yeah, but he'll wake up.
Now he'll fall asleep, actually.
Now he'll, like, pass out.
You got it, boxes.
There we go.
Another friend is distracted.
So we can...
I can't tell what is the camera.
Wait, what is the camera?
I can't... Is the camera just fixed?
Okay, you know what?
Uh, in...
In we go!
Snake!
Snake, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Snake, please!
Why is it so difficult?
Oh my goodness.
Snake!
Oh yeah, I was accidentally teabagging him.
that was not the intent where was it he's really grateful
probably do you think there's anything over here at all?
I think I check every time but who knows something might
appear
can I shoot from here oh she scooped back a little oh I
could.
I could shoot from here.
Oh, but then they'll be like, where are you?
Respond, yeah.
What?
This is like class A, like micromanaging.
The fact that he has to like send a little status report
every two seconds is insane.
Your manager must be so annoying.
Just always nothing here.
Nothing here.
Like, I think I would go insane if someone kept reporting
that to me.
Every two seconds.
Nothing here.
I'm a little fish.
I'm a little fish in the sea.
I'm a little drowning fish.
I'm going to get out of the water.
The RTO is just lonely.
I get that.
He'd be a little less lonely if there was something here,
though.
Nothing here.
I love the way they say it in MGS2 Nothing here
Okay Sounds very close Where are you?
You are the true VTuber Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Oh, there he is.
If I get him, though.
I think the footsteps I'm hearing are the guy upstairs.
Right?
Okay, he's doing his thing, going around.
If I get him, though, he's gonna...
They're gonna do a status report, but I feel like I have to
get him.
There's nothing here.
There's no...
Okay, yeah.
Where is he?
What?
That way!
No way.
Um, can you just... Oh, um, uh...
Wait, hold on!
Hold on!
I'm just gonna go back and... Oh, shoot.
Uh, I didn't even see you.
Go away.
Yeah, go away.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Um... How the heck did you see?
Oh my god, Snake, just go back to your hole.
Just go back to the hole, Snake!
Where's the hole?
There it is.
Crawl, crawl.
Crawl on in.
No pursuit!
mean you're not gonna crawl after me are you that would be
ridiculous oh no can
you see me
mmm oh my gosh you and your perfect vision why don't they
ever hire guys that need glasses huh Billy welcome the
membership thank you
Um...
Yeah, I'll hug the walls next time.
You know, the CQC jump kick really sells me on the idea that
this is Otakon's retelling of the Shadow Bros system.
They hired Otakon.
Yeah, but that guy's like, he, you know, he's a nerd.
They really just said nothing here.
Oh!
We're calling you to a team.
We're a team.
I'm
a...
Oh!
Where are they going?
Where do they... Oh, I don't think there's a door in there.
I don't think there's another...
Where do they go to?
Hmm, where...
Have you ever watched animated parodies of Metal Gear games
like Metal Gear Awesome or... I did watch Crab Battle
before, yeah.
I think I watched Metal Gear Awesome as a kid.
Mint is cute today also, but not as cute as Snake.
No one's as cute.
is snake.
But thanks for the super chat.
They hired a whole Otaku convention, exactly.
Nothing here.
Yeah, nothing here.
Oh my gosh.
This guy sucks so much.
Oh, whoops.
It's because I'm crawling.
It's still taking me a second to get used to which one is
what is what is crawl and what is an odd.
and all that fun stuff, you know.
No, I don't want to go in there.
I'm hugging the walls.
Where's our friend who comes over here?
Is he going to come over here?
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know his patrol route.
Lucky Nag, welcome to membership, thank you!
Oh.
He thought he saw me.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, did he just say...
He didn't say just a box or anything, right?
There he is.
Okay, he's reporting.
Nothing here.
One thing I really want to learn to get better at is, like,
getting the...
Shooting the...
What's it called?
You know, the...
Uh, the...
The remote.
Babe.
Okay.
Trust your instincts as a soldier.
Yeah, the radio!
What did I call it?
I don't know what I called it.
Uh, B1?
No, B2.
It was B2.
Yeah, the radios.
Wait, can I actually go in here?
Ah, 6.
Did I hear something?
Oh, it was...
I heard the music.
Yeah, get in the radio.
Oh, that B2.
I could never get down shooting the radio in any game.
It's really, I mean, it's like the tiniest target, right?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that guy was right there.
I think every time I start, he's always right there.
Okay, PSG is somewhere.
Somewhere in here.
Alright, let's just let these guys kind of do...
Oh!
Rendezvous!
Just gotta go for it.
Oh my god, the trap is still open.
This side.
Uh, C4.
Nikita.
Does he come around here?
Oh my god.
Ah!
No!
I didn't!
I didn't beat you!
No?
No, I'm just a box!
I'm...
Ah!
This is so messed up.
This is so...
I can't believe you could turn on the safety on this thing.
I guess maybe if you're trying to hold up someone and you,
uh...
You don't want to...
You don't want to kill them for real?
Okay, let's see.
How do I get out of this predicament?
Hmm...
Okay, I'm on rations.
I'm slowly standing up.
And fire!
Fire!
Whoever is...
Oh, I'm not firing at anyone!
Oh my god.
Um...
I'm...
Oh!
Kill you!
Hey!
Oh my gosh.
You don't think they'll see me right here, right?
I hate!
I hurt you!
Why do you have to be...
Oh my god, where did you come from?
Oh, I'm so far away from you.
Yeah, yeah.
Stop!
Stop it!
Leave me alone!
Okay, let's retry that.
Let's... Maybe there's a ration in here.
I can run.
Oh!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh!
so close to using that other ashen my i panicked and like my
and i like did a little 360 with my with the stick okay
let's see there's some stuff in here probably right yeah
there's still some stuff in here oh get everything but it
anything in there here probably can unequip this nice okay
Let's just take a little bit of stuff.
All according to plan, of course, as always.
It was obviously my intention to just get more stuff.
Duh.
Nothing under here.
Meryl, you stingy.
Just as planned.
Nasty.
More books.
I'll take it.
Is there anything...
Oh, wait.
I'll take it.
I can't take it.
Too many of it.
And I don't think...
Was there...
Hmm.
What?
I think there's stuff up here.
Climb.
Oh.
I can't climb it anymore.
It won't let me go into the vents.
I can go into these vents, though.
Okay.
Who would have...
thunk that it would take it would be this difficult oh yeah
i knew it that would be this difficult just to get the dang
psg well difficult for me all right one thing i love though
about this game is when you are down and then you press to
stand back up it doesn't put you just into the crouch it
actually stands you up because that would get me so many
games where i would be like lying down and I'll be trying to
stand up and then I stood up like this you know oh yeah save
good plan wait um with a yes start and a button okay
Campbell stay out of her range and shoot at her with a
sniper rifle yeah but where can I find a sniper rifle I
can't ask Merrill what about Dr. Emmerich he's been on the
base for a while he might know I wonder if he tells me that
there's one, that there's the...
The what's it called one?
Otagon.
Have you ever seen a sniper rifle anywhere on this base?
A sniper rifle?
Merrill's been shot by an extremely good sniper.
Sniper.
A high quality sniper rifle is the only way I can fight
back.
I wonder if he tells me about the Tranquil.
I saw one in the armory in the second floor basement of the
tank hangar.
The second floor basement of the tank hangar.
I have to go all the way back there.
It's literally me.
Yeah.
What's wrong with you, Otacon?
Oh, nothing.
He sounds so...
So shy.
So like...
Nothing.
You know...
Don't worry about him.
This...
He wouldn't...
He wouldn't get it, you know.
There's nothing.
You need to make snap decisions.
In war, the difference between living and dying is counted
in milliseconds.
True.
I made good ones.
I made good ones, Master.
Like turning around.
You cannot win without a sniper rifle.
You cannot save the girl either.
Find a sniper rifle.
It is the only way to save Meryl.
Only way.
Mealing.
I could have used your advice, you know?
You called Snake?
I did.
Let's save since we're here.
We're gonna save.
Yes.
Whatever you say, Nastasha.
Yeah.
All right.
B.
There's a Chinese proverb.
The mind cannot be in two places at once.
Make sure you're not thinking of something else during the
mission, okay?
I'm thinking of you, baby girl.
Sorry.
Okay.
The codex are so, the audio is so low.
Okay, back to B2.
I don't even know where the PSG is.
I was just going...
I was going the...
I don't even know if I was going the right way.
I don't even know.
Wait.
Oh, those guys are still knocked out.
No way.
Wait a second.
Yeah, I'm gonna trank them.
I have to make sure I do this correctly, though.
You know?
Okay.
Oh.
Never mind.
Well, they can't take the elevator because it's occupied.
I wish I could shoot from the box, man.
Oh, nice to be able to shoot from the box.
They won't look in here, right?
I just gotta wait it out a little bit.
Too OP?
Probably, yeah.
Look at this guy.
What are you doing over there in the corner?
Oh, yeah.
Go look around.
Do your job.
There's a maniac on the loose.
He's absolutely wild.
Oh, there he goes.
Stay sharp, everybody.
Okay, they have a reset it.
Very good.
Very nice.
Okay.
This guy's gonna come.
He's gonna be like, ooh, ah.
The reason I keep going to the right is because, um, well, I
guess my left.
The left, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the, You know where I'm going.
The reason I keep going that way is because I'm most
familiar with that guy's pattern.
That guy's his route, so it's a little easier for me.
The radar?
Right.
My.
Like, snakes?
Snakes left.
Yeah.
Who's right?
Who's on first base?
okay can i go now
i'm so scared i don't want to get caught again come on guys
don't even worry about me i'm just a box just a little box i
don't know where the psg lives
please run away
i keep thinking this is a hole in the ground scares me so
much Where am I?
Smoking.
A little left.
Is he coming down?
Where does he go?
Where do these two guys?
These guys gang up.
That's why I got caught.
Okay, this guy goes down and he comes this way.
Yeah.
And then he goes up.
He stops there.
Turned around?
Turned around.
Then he goes up.
You.
Is this it?
Duh, this is the hand grenades.
Dang it.
Every second you wait, Meryl gets close to death.
Good.
Are they camping it up there?
It's not that one up there, is it?
It can't be that one.
The one that the guy is literally standing in front of?
It can't be that one, right?
How do I get past this guy?
I can't see it.
Just a box.
I think he's right in front of it.
I think it's that one.
Just trank him.
I'm scared.
Hold on.
Okay.
Once the bottom guy goes to the top.
We're gonna run right past him when he turned around.
I think he looks here.
Yeah, he looks down here.
And he goes up.
And...
Don't notice me.
Please, God.
Okay.
We're just gonna have to blast through him and then go up.
We're gonna...
We're gonna blast through him!
and then go up
no I was trying to wait start oh maybe I pressed start B on
accident hold on I'm busy please I'm I'm busy right now I'm
busy oh my god please I'm trying to just run
oh press press the button
how are you hitting me if I can't You get him, you get him,
you bitch!
Oh, the elevator's here.
Um, oh, it doesn't work.
Oh, I'm...
I'm...
Oh, I think they noticed me.
Do you think?
Oh, we have no more rush!
It's over!
Now, why does a thing have to be there?
You son of a...
Bitch!
You son of a bitch!
Snake?
Are you okay?
Snake!
I'm not okay.
I'm actually molding.
Oh my god.
Why do I have to have...
Why do I have to...
Why?
Why did I have to be like...
Oh wait.
I was gonna say, why do I have to be like...
I have to be why do I have to be so like um like oh I don't
want the tranquilizer I want the legit thing I want the real
deal okay can I get around okay
okay okay okay this side wait oh wait wait I
They're not going to notice me.
Okay, just kill me.
Just kill me.
No, I won't let you kill me.
Where's the hole?
I'll kill myself!
I knew the guy was going to turn around.
I knew the guy was going to turn around, so I was going to
have to be like, oh, shoot.
Okay, when I go in there, once I make my move, you're free.
to go past the guard.
Okay.
Now turn around.
Are they gonna come in here or...
You know what?
I'm just gonna wait it out and see.
I'm just gonna wait it out.
I'm under attack.
Stay alert.
I'm just gonna wait it out.
Are they gonna come in here?
Oh.
past me I can't get the trank PSG one because it's not it's
not a canon to the game me right now I hate past me you know
what past me sucks past me has bad ideas I I it's
going down I'm too afraid to move because the door is gonna
open okay
just let all these guys go away go away okay okay now I know
this guy stays here but I just wanted less guys around
okay is the door still open I didn't hear it shut you know
what whatever oh there it is oh oh I can't tell I can't tell
I think it reopens again
if I have to go backwards I have to go backwards
No, please Please I'm just a worm I'm just a worm I'm just a
worm I'm just a worm I'm just a little guy I'm just a little
wormy guy Oh, why does the door have to open?
Why does the door have to open?
I made it there so...
It was so clean too.
Okay, he's gonna turn around.
Okay, is it open or not?
I can't tell at all!
Okay, it's open.
How am I supposed to...
I'm under attack!
Stay alert!
How am I supposed to get through?
The red line means it's open?
I'm guessing?
You can see in the mini-map if it's open.
I couldn't tell before, though.
It's closed.
Are you okay?
Are you sure?
Red line is closed.
Yes!
Craydon!
got a sniper rifle you can use that again sniper wolf hurry
up and save mary i'm trying i don't want to save her anymore
she doesn't deserve it she doesn't deserve my my lava after
everything i've been through colonel
oh i see it i see what you guys mean though okay that guy
all right Once he turns around, pass this.
Here.
Oh, here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
This guy is gonna come up.
Oh, nope.
Press the button.
Shaa!
Shot!
Oh!
Metal Gear Gaming.
Okay.
Give me a break.
Just give me one second and a B1.
Holy moly.
Okay.
So now...
Do you think there's that ration back there again?
No wonder.
Gonna be kind of awesome.
If it respawned.
Bashamin!
Hello!
No.
Imagine if you fell into that hole.
What do you take me as a rookie?
I could not see that first one, though.
Okay, how do I want to do this?
Let's see.
I'm going to go to the Kusalan concert tomorrow, but I've
never gone to a concert by myself before.
It's not a concert.
concert.
It's like...
It's so, so casual.
Like, just wear whatever you want.
It's just people playing anime music.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
So...
Don't feel like you have to dress up or dress up.
Actually, put on your best suit.
awesome put on your best suit yeah okay um trying to think
yeah probably going back to the well if i go back to the
truck okay we'll have to knock that guy out i have to shoot
his little toes that's okay we can shoot his toes we'll
shoot his toes you're producing an idol group made up of MGS
characters name the unit and the center cannot be snake
center can be cause I think he'd be a great center cause or
oscillot oscillot could be a great center because he's got
that like appeal of like and I mean this in the most loving
way of a weirdo you know
sometimes people like idols who like are who have like a
weird personality you know what i mean
like not your conventional idol like oh i'm so happy la la
la who is that up there
trying to see where this guy is like who is that in over
there is that outside like me A little corny?
No, I think I'm...
I don't think like me.
Where did...
Oh, there he is.
Okay, he's walking up.
Here.
Exactly.
This guy is not...
No.
I'm not having you come all the way down here.
To investigate my box.
We are not doing that.
Welcome to membership, you guys.
Thank you so much!
Like, okay, sorry.
I was, like, half, just half, like, being able to talk.
So, like, for example, part of, like, um, for example, part
of, like, Atchan from AKB, she was, like, the center for AKB
for a super duper long time.
And, like, oh my gosh, why?
Why is my O2 go down so fast?
But part of her appeal was just, like, how uninterested she
was people are like yeah we kind of like that she's wait
wait a second um am I gonna run into this guy
okay oh I was so scared for a second
sorry I gotta get your gotta get your ankles let's get you a
couple times where's that coming from come here Mosquitoes
in Alaska?
That's wild.
I know.
I know, man.
Must be hard.
Oh, I forgot about his...
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, can I...
They already did the radio.
Oh, I...
Where is his radio?
Oh, shoot.
But I don't know where to shoot.
Just imagine freeze
Just imagining How do you hold it?
I held him up
It's him Everyone stay on guard No way I can't This is so
funny No way Who's that?
It's the enemy Oh, um...
There's no way he should have down.
Do you think if I go back, I'll be fine?
Why did he kick the guard?
I don't know!
La la la la la la la Okay, okay.
this guy i have the most short amount of time to run over to
the truck but i also have to make sure i am not seen going
to the truck which is i can't tell this guy doesn't like
walk around this way like the guy over there by the truck
that will see me shoot guy chaff you think um that might
work That might work.
I do have some stun grenades, but I think that'll make too
much of a scene.
Maybe.
I'll make too much of a scene, right?
Yeah, there's...
Well, the camera is what the chaff grenade would be for.
Throw a magazine to lure him away.
He'll come back, though, right?
Hmm.
Throw a magazine.
You mean this magazine, not the...
Let's lure him.
Ooh, we're throwing really far.
All the way!
Can I get between his legs?
There!
Oh, that did not go far, you guys.
You guys, that didn't go very far.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
Now, I wonder if I can get his...
oh oh i frozen i've got him um if i hold this uh now wait
i'm frozen i can't do anything uh hmm uh uh i literally
can't move i can't get out if i unequip it unfreezes him Oh,
shoot.
Okay, I'm gonna get you in the foot.
Sorry, man.
Ah, get up.
I can't!
I am in!
I am in the thing!
Okay, sorry, guy.
Freeze.
How are you still standing?
Uh...
Stop aiming and crawl.
Is he still going to be frozen?
Is he still going to be...
Okay.
Sorry, guy.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, actually, where's your radio?
What's that?
Nothing?
It's nothing.
What?
What do you mean?
Um...
Uh-oh.
uh um there doesn't need to be a backup unit uh oh oh just
just a couple guys are down just a couple guys are down we
have a man down increased to max i
just want to get in here please the a wall man I even got
his his little radio it was the other radio they're so fast
with the radios maybe because he died on the camera but I
had to kill the other guy well maybe I could have no I think
even if I knocked him out it still would have been bad maybe
hmm hmm
yeah guard team remain there I think this resets their
positions right okay so if i come out come out quickly stand
oh no they just took their bodies okay can anybody take me
to the nuke building uh-oh wait a second did i kill oh oh oh
i was gonna say wait is there nobody to take me to the nuke
building no it's gonna walk up and see me is this all there
is to load No one's gonna...
Nuclear warhead storage, huh?
Mm-hmm.
That's right, sir.
Nuclear warhead storage.
I was so nervous.
I was so worried for a second.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe it's taken me an hour to get
this dang PSG one.
Holy cow.
Okay.
All right, so this is our guy.
We have another guy who walks around.
wherever he might be he's gonna come around there he is yes
and I can't do use anything here I got to be like all skill
okay so once he goes go please snake snake why aren't you
leaving the truck snake Oh, I can't jump out in the box.
Okay, never mind.
I think that kind of ruined my plan a little bit.
I'm sorry.
I did not mean to screen like that.
Okay.
Our friend should be walking up here.
Just a box for real.
Just a box.
Real.
Real, real, real.
All right, we're just going to go down this path.
Okay, there he is.
There he is.
Nice, nice, nice.
All right, let's go save Mera!
Okay, now where's our friend up here?
Nice.
I wonder what that is over there.
Okay, that's there.
He's coming back.
Oh, no, that's the guy downstairs.
Oh, wait.
How can I see what the guy upstairs?
is doing?
Oh, I can't.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Just hopping upstairs.
Yeah.
Okay.
Turn around.
Is he turn around?
Yahoo!
Get the PSG.
Get the other one.
for completion oh wait i went to wait isn't it in here
actually is it the trank in here is it is it this one uh gas
mask actually don't know oh wait it might be one of the ones
that uh
wait are all these oh i can't go in there all the cameras
are still down that's kind of awesome grenades full oh M9
full.
M9 full.
Oh, it's a psychomantus area.
Oh, my bad.
For some reason, I thought it was in here.
Anything in here?
The lady magazine is worth it.
Probably.
I keep pressing the action button for...
Oh, oh, oh.
I keep pressing the action button for trying to look.
in first person.
I think I wasted enough time.
I think we can just kind of go to Meryl.
When I was playing the Master Collection, I thought of you
and I used your box method.
It's actually very effective.
It is.
The box is awesome.
The box is life.
You know?
I only remember this area MGS4?
Really?
Okay, I was gonna say I think Metal Gear Solid is the one
that I remembered the most of.
Actually, when I do think about it, I think, um...
Like, the point between getting caught by um, by Ocelot
like, you know, in the getting tortured by Ocelot and and
going down the elevator to Vulcan Raven I'm like I know I
fight the Hinde but I just I think I've erased that whole
spot out of my brain like I cannot remember ever what goes
on in between there like I know I have to go up the
communications tower but I'm like how do I get there and
then I have to fight the guys in the elevator but I'm like
when do I do that like it's just i think it's maybe i don't
want to say the most like memorable spot but it's like kind
of unmemorable you know in a way i think it's torture tower
elevator right okay now we're gonna be the p box see doggies
love us oh that's the psg train that's so fun um doggies
where's the exit oh sorry did i hit you oh oh my god little
doggy nice okay let's go fight sniper wolf uh yeah i'm a p
box right now uh oh oh my god oh my god please i'm
still p box okay oh oh thank you it actually i think it's
fine because i think we're mostly oh oh what's going on uh
oh i think it's time you guys they just throw you right in
there they're like um are you ready are you ready to fight
sniper wolf okay i have not used the psg in this game yet
before so let's see how this goes aim in first person view
fire with a Zoom in with B, out with X.
Time to take your pills.
Wait.
Uh, gas map.
Oh, no.
Wait, why am I over there?
Why am I in third person all of a sudden?
Who am I?
Who's observing me?
Who are you?
Huh?
Wait, huh?
Oh.
Oh, okay, okay.
Um, can I lay down with this?
Or, um, no.
Rouch.
Lay.
Turn.
Equip.
Where's the...
I never can get the best angle for this, you know?
I can never figure it out.
Can I just do it in first person?
Actually?
Oh.
Hey, girly.
Uh, B and fire!
Oh, ow.
Oh, my meds.
I need my meds.
Oh, I don't even need to lay down?
Wait.
I don't even need to lay down.
It's kind of OP, right?
You're gonna look this way.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I was so close.
I was...
Oh, my God.
Yep.
There she goes.
Okay.
Ouchie.
Hi.
Where are you?
Madam?
Hold on.
I can't see anything.
Let's go this way.
Do I need to be crouching at all?
I shot her in the cleavage?
Exactly all according to plan.
Can I just be...
I literally don't even have to be...
Oh my gosh.
This is insane.
I don't have to be sitting.
Is it probably better...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It might be better...
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Maybe better...
Like...
Yes, your hands tremble less.
That's what I... that's the word better like stability
stability is the word that I was thinking of.
Oh my god You guys how do you even stand me?
Good angle for you.
Hello, madam.
Oh, I must take my meds I must take my meds ma'am Got you
Got you.
Oh, and you got me I did a little...
Where are you?
Oh, uh...
Wait, actually, where are you?
I'm throwing our offer game, you know?
Okay.
Now I zoom in and I take my meds.
I know... I don't know why I cycle through the whole thing
every time.
Oh!
Oh, she's gonna...
Oh, never mind.
Oh.
So sensitive.
Got your cleavage!
I got your cleavage!
So sensitive!
Oh, kind of shaky.
What did he say?
There's no cameras here yet.
If I remember correctly.
The heartbeat?
Thought I heard like a little heart... Oh, yeah, there's
like kind of like a really slow heartbeat like sound.
Oh, oh, goodness.
Oh, goodness.
There is a camera there.
I knew it.
Hmm.
I want that, though.
I can get it.
Oh, snake.
Look this way.
I can get it.
Run!
It was worth.
Okay.
Okay, let's go.
La la la.
Picking up the stuff.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
This game is way more generous on health items.
But you know what I haven't picked up?
I haven't picked very many chaff grenades.
They have not picked so many chaff grenades.
No, no, no, not yet.
But...
Look at the rods.
There we go.
Oh, Kodak calls before progress.
You're so right.
I should have done it.
I'm so sorry.
Robin, it's me.
Starfire!
You do not wish to hurt me, Robin.
Woo!
Whoa!
It's hard to miss when you're this close.
That's yeah.
It's kind of weird that you're using your sniper on me right
here.
Something I would do.
That wasn't slow.
Whoa!
The triple kick!
You're a fool to come back here.
Stupid man.
Sorry.
A lady sniper, huh?
Don't you know that the majority of the world's great
assassins are women?
Yeah!
Do you want to die now?
Or after your female friend?
Which will it be?
Oh my god.
I'll die after I kill you.
Is that right?
Well, at least you could spirit.
You okay, Robin?
Yeah!
Sometimes she even falls in love with them.
I am sniper wolf.
And I always kill what I aim.
Snake's eyes here are...
They're like...
His eyes are like bulging out of his head.
Oh!
I've left my mark on you.
Oh my gosh.
I won't forget it.
Wow.
I kill you you're all I'll think about oh la la what's your
haircut oh oh yeah that was nothing little baby boy yeah I'm
like twice your size oh never mind it was everything take
him away what do you mean why did you act all tough Yes, I
will take it alive.
Leave it to me.
I want no more accidents like that DARPA chief.
Like that DARPA chief.
He's my target.
Mine alone.
It is Robin, I thought it was a bit.
No!
I was like, hi, Hannah!
On her mind, rent-free, for real, for real.
Yeah.
Bro was lagging.
can you hear me solid snake oh brother do you know who I am
I always knew that one day I would meet you I like that we
can just kind of see the man who stole the light from my
life because of you forget it your body is strapped down
Uh-huh.
Uh, isolate.
I'm the man from whom you stole everything good.
And now, after the sacrifice of our brothers, after thirty
long years, finally, the two of us meet.
The brother of light and the brother of dark.
Let me add this.
We will need his genetic information too.
yes yes i want a sample while he's still alive we needed to
correct the genome soldiers mutations then we'll be able to
cure them what's wrong with that we still have to get our
hands on big boss's they're only 179 a i kill have they
given in to our demands yet not yet they won't give in
they're all hypocrites every one of them is that your
And also, I'm not going to submit immediately in case you
guys are wondering as well.
About their precious new nuclear weapon.
Boss, it looks like our friend is awake.
Who are you talking to before then?
Were you not talking to me?
Like, did you think I was asleep talking to me like that?
Whoa, why are we so red?
there definitely is a resemblance don't you think a little
brother little brother
oh my god whoa whoa whoa or should I say big brother I'm not
sure anyway it doesn't matter you would like us to be the
little brother surviving sons of big boss What?
Who's calling?
It's me.
Then what?
I'm the only British person here.
There's a ninja on the loose.
All right, Raven.
I'll be right there.
Moshi Moshi.
They're not responding to our demands.
We'll launch the first one in 10 hours as planned.
Oh my god.
No!
Looks like you read them wrong.
You mean just...
Don't point that thing at me, Ocelot.
Something's funny.
Normally, the Americans are the first ones to the
negotiating table.
They must think they've got something up their sleeves.
So it's come down to it, has it?
We're gonna launch that nuke and write it all the way into
history.
Write it all... Oh, remember the alibi, baby.
I've got to take care of some launch preparations.
You're in charge here, Ocelot.
What about you?
Want to stay for the show?
I'm not interested.
Yeah.
Take your meds.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
It's time to feed the family.
Nice cinematography here.
So, you prefer your wolves to my show, hmm?
Hmm?
Ocelot, don't screw up like you did with the chief.
Yes, I know.
That was an accident.
I didn't think a pencil pusher like him would be so tough.
Well, his mental defenses were reinforced by hypnotherapy.
Gosh, they love hypnotherapy.
Where can I get me some of that hypnotherapy?
I mean, actually, just regular therapy.
man whoever he is he's some kind of lunatic 12 guys bastard
took my hand how could you've gotten in here perhaps there's
a spy among us oh my gosh oh no mantis is dead we've also
got to find out what killed baker and octopus we're
short-handed so make this little torture show of yours as
short No, no, no.
Decoy Octopus is still alive.
We haven't fought him yet.
This is an interrogation.
Oh my god, his nipples were long.
See you later, brother.
Brother?
Oh no.
He's still alive.
Decoy Octopus.
We haven't seen him yet.
She's so awesome.
I get, you know what, Otakon, I get it.
Oh!
Oh, sorry.
Your woman is still in this world.
That was really close.
To come here.
Meryl.
He's like...
God, I wish that were...
What are you laughing at?
What?
What is all of this implying?
What
did...
later handsome oh he wanted a he wanted a kiss he was like a
little kiss on the cheek she doesn't think about anything
else sometimes she even falls in love with them before she
kills them Wow finally just the two of us this bed is too
big for just me us a lot how are you feeling not bad caught
a nice nap on this revolving bed of yours too bad I was
sleeping alone yeah glad to hear that this is some bed all
right I'm about to show you some of its nicer features where
are my things where are my things oh don't worry they're all
there in the floating oh it's actually just a normal box
that's so funny it's not like floating like in the original.
Washington was taking quite a chance sending you here.
Someone must have a lot of faith in your skill, hmm?
Carrier boy!
Huh?
So, Metal Gear is armed with a new type of nuclear warhead,
huh?
Huh?
Snake's that cat name.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
By the way, you got an optical disc from President Baker,
didn't you?
what if I did oh my god can you show like at least a little
bit of his pants disc there's no other data what do you mean
there's no copy if not that's fine I love the kind of woman
that will actually just kill me so true is Merrill okay yeah
she's not dead yet thanks to wolf swim but it's up to you if
you wanted stay that way uh-huh you were holding one card
key where are the other two what's the trick behind that key
what's the trick behind the key that weasel of a president
said there's some kind of trick using the key yeah you want
hypnotherapy to stare into the suspicious app that appeared
on my phone what does that mean oh no he's you're going to
play a game solid He's not a revolver.
I will find out what kind of man you really are.
When the pain becomes too great to bear, he can't revolve.
Just give up and your suffering will end.
But if you do, the girl's life is mine.
Okay.
They nerfed him.
Press the resist button repeatedly to regain your strength.
Wait, what's the resist button?
When you've had enough, Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Ocelot, what's the...
When your life reaches zero, the game is over.
Should have saved.
There are no continues, my friend.
Oh gosh, I should have saved.
Don't even think about using auto fire, but I'll know.
Oh, he's looking at me!
It's been a long time since you saved your game.
Yeah?
So what?
If your body can't survive the torture, it'll be game over.
He even knows.
You really want to travel down that long?
Wait, he knows!
Come on, I won't tell.
Why don't you just give up?
I'm going to run a high voltage electric current through
your body.
If it's just for a short time, it won't kill you.
Wait, what is the resist button?
Oh gosh.
Did you know that it was the French who first thought of
using electrical shocks?
Of course it was the French.
Hey, French films are all right.
But I don't care about that crap.
You're a tough guy, Snake.
some bad news for you you're no p.o.w i'm surprised he
didn't talk about french fries you're a hostage there's no
geneva convention no one is coming to save you starting to
feel a little scared no oh you should be yes okay let's get
started what is the resiski wait oh no no no no no no
oh uh we're getting straight
like that so fast shall we go again that was so fast okay
nice had enough yet he's not like screaming the whole time
like it's so easy it's so fast oh don't say that even if
it's true you're a strong man I know just like my father
right you're the boss's brother all right your brother he's
an amazing man who else could shoot down to f-16s with a
chopper oh my god the eyebrow look there's a far terrible
project was not a total failure One man who could make my
dream into a reality.
What is that project?
Oh.
Take me home, Robin.
Oh, I like how at the start of every, like, changing angle
or, like, the cutscenes, like, their hair all, like, kind of
resets.
It's so funny.
Johnny!
Where?
Ah!
Looks like I got a roommate.
He don't look so good.
Decoy octopus.
Oh my god!
That's disgusting!
Oh my god, that- wait, that is actually disgusting.
The DARPA chief.
Oh, gross!
What a stench!
You couldn't tell when you first came in?
That is some severe...
Ooh.
Lord.
Ding.
Snake, are you okay?
I've been better.
House Meryl.
They got her.
Oh.
Damn.
Okay.
I know.
Snake, the government has decided not to give in to their
demands.
We're trying to buy some more time.
Come on, Colonel.
Why don't you stop playing dumb?
I'm sorry about Merrill, but I want the lies to end now.
What are you talking about?
Metal Gear was designed to launch a new type of nuclear
warhead, wasn't it?
Oh, no.
You knew it all along, didn't you?
No.
Why did you try to hide it?
Colonel!
I'm sorry.
Can't tell the grunts, huh?
You've changed a lot.
Metal Gear, secret advanced nuclear weapons research.
Does the White House know about this?
Of course it does.
Of course they did.
do as far as i know as of yesterday the president had not
been briefed about the rex lies need to know basis is that
the idea these are sensitive times even sub-critical nuclear
tests are causing quite a stir plausible deniability huh yes
and tomorrow the president and his russian counterpart are
scheduled to sign the start three accord i get it that's the
reason for the deadline that's right snake and that's why we
can't let this attack go public we still haven't even
ratified start to or dealt with the issue of TMDs this is
ridiculous I don't care about the president's reputation I
don't care convenient I don't care just stop them to serve
your interests because we're relying on you in that case I
like this picture cuz snake looks so mad I told you I don't
know the details.
I don't believe you.
Yeah, I don't believe you either, Colonel.
If the situation is so serious, why don't you give in to
their demands?
Let them have big bosses remains.
Yeah, who cares?
You see, or is there some reason that you can't do that?
Something you haven't told me about.
The president has adopted a firm public stance vis-a-vis
bioethics.
We don't want the existence of the Genome Army to go public.
You're just all covering your butts.
for your mistake yeah the hell with you i'm sorry the corpse
of the darpa chief is lying right here next to me poor man
but it's strange he looks and smells like he's been dead for
days all his blood's been drained out too drained maybe to
slow down decomposition i have no idea but the chief only
died a few hours ago right right but he's already started to
decompose something in his blood that they wanted i doubt it
just the nano machines in the transmitter did the chief tell
them his detonation code i'm afraid so yeah it looks like
they've got both codes and are nearly ready to launch oh my
gosh we gotta stop that launch is there any way to prevent
it it seems there's some type of emergency override device
that can cancel out the detonation code it's a counter
measure that arms tech installed secretly you have to unlock
it with three special card keys we only have one and where
are those keys you only have the one one of them yeah i
don't know where the other two are besides i'm locked up
here we've got no choice forget about the keys your top
priority now is to destroy metal gear itself i'm sorry to
have to lay it all in your lap but you're all i've got bust
out of there and get to the communications Well, I'm busting
alright.
Merrill, right?
Yeah.
I'll save her.
Thanks.
I won't.
Do that.
I won't do that.
Huh?
Oh, god.
Oh, damn.
I caught a cold.
That witch.
She took my clothes.
Hey.
Shut up in there, will you?
Shut up in there, will ya?
Hey.
Um.
I don't think I can call Otacon.
I don't know what I'm about to call that.
Hey.
are you still okay are you okay thanks to the stealth
camouflage that is yeah i could have used that why don't you
just why don't you just hide in a locker and i use the
stealth camera i'm locked up here in this cell what cell
there's a big torture machine nearby yeah okay i know it
it's close i'll be there right away thanks thanks now let's
save also
I feel so scared for you.
It must be horrible.
I'm so scared, Mealing.
I've been through a lot worse.
Believe me.
He's so cool.
It's a good thing the Kodak has connected directly to your
inner ear.
You can contact us anytime.
Yeah.
It's always nice to hear that you're all right.
Oh.
Why don't you contact the Colonel?
If anyone can think of a way out, it's him.
Boo, contact the Colonel.
Okay, let's see.
Okay.
When do I get my ketchup?
I want for you, baby girl!
I wonder actually if I call him.
A raid?
Pokol raid?
Thank you for the raid!
Oh!
Serial number and date of birth.
But you're not any old soldier, Snake.
I'm not.
I'm a gamer.
I don't want you to tell them anything.
Oh, yeah.
Fortunately, you're strong enough to...
resist yeah I won't tell them anything master the
guard is only human he has to sleep and go to the bathroom
like the rest of us that'll be your chance that's so true
that's so true hey there Johnny thanks for the gift and Look
at him, looking at me.
Looking at him, looking at me.
Ew!
Cover your nose when you do that.
This guy has no hygiene.
Oh, my God.
Go wash your hands, Johnny.
Ah, sure.
He's checking me out, I don't know.
Shut up in there, will you?
Oh.
What just opened?
Shut up in there, will you?
I won't.
Let me...
Shut up in there, will you?
Oh, what's that?
Snake, it's showtime.
Ah!
Ossalot wants you.
Oh, I know he does.
Yeah, there's snot all in that mask.
Can you imagine?
Tascaru sneezed Johnny 11 years just good.
Okay, I'll tell you once more.
I want to do the catch-up, so that's why I'm going to keep
resistant wait oh no i have to give up though don't i when
you've had enough press the surrender button to submit when
your life reaches zero the game is over i have to surrender
don't i there are no continues my friend i know i've fought
wars in afghanistan ketchup means escape yeah exactly
eritrea and chad chad among the mujahideen gorillas i was
known and feared as I was trained by the Russian groom.
Okay, I don't need your biography, you also lie.
I'm not like one of those KGB slugs.
Shalashaska.
To me, this isn't torture.
It's a sport.
It's a fetish.
You're all just a bunch of sadists.
Yeah, he is.
Don't confuse me with those uniformed fools.
Shalashaska.
Look at his nipples are kind of long, though, right?
Shall we begin?
Okay, I have to submit though, don't I?
Do we want to go through one more time?
What should I do?
Oh my gosh, it's so easy.
How did you like that?
Submit.
You can go through two sessions.
No, guys, you're really gonna want to see the Otacon ending,
I promise.
Okay.
There's three sessions to it.
I just kind of want to like...
I kind of want to just like...
Hang out with Johnny one more time.
You're a strong man.
I am.
Well, that's enough for now, I think.
For now.
I feel like a loser submitting, even though it's...
You know?
I feel like a loser if I submit...
Did you save?
I did save, yep.
20th century Russia has had its share of problems, but at
least they had an ideology.
Russia today has nothing.
Yon, I'm sleepy.
They're struggling between freedom and order, and with that
struggle, a new spirit of nationalism has been born.
The boss has a close friend high up in the Russian
government.
He's currently the head of Spetsnaz.
Spetsnaz.
He's agreed to purchase this new nuclear weapons system.
was just a down payment oh this is uh you're in this for the
money oh no i don't need money oh no i want russia to be
reborn to lead a brave oh no snake if only you knew what
he's what what ocelot is in it for if only you knew now
olga's dad yeah yeah yeah colonel grilukovitch watch he
loves to watch me be dragged away
He loves to watch me get dragged away.
I'm back.
I'm back, my girlfriend.
What if I hide under here?
I think he, like, kind of...
He's like, yeah, I get...
Oh.
Who's calling me?
You okay, Snake?
I'm good.
Nothing new to report.
Snake.
Oh, my God.
Raffle Chief!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Oh, I guess I should have...
I increased the level of pain.
To the Raiders.
Hi, I'm Mint Phantom.
I'm a ghost maid.
Say something to take my mind off the pain.
Ooh.
What can I say?
I love Metal Gear Solid.
Anything.
Too much.
I... I'm not a very good talker.
Please.
Tell me about yourself.
Myself.
That's a tough one.
Any family?
That's not a happy topic for me.
I don't have any family.
No, wait.
There was a man who...
Who said he was my father.
Where is he?
Dead.
By my own hand.
Big Boss.
What?
Big Boss?
There was no way you could know.
It happened in Zanzibar land six years ago.
Only Snake and I know the real truth of what happened there.
So, is it true?
Was Big Boss really your father?
That's what he said.
That's all I know.
And you were able to kill him.
Knowing that?
How?
It's what we wanted.
Me.
And him.
That's patricide.
Yeah.
After Zanzibar.
That's the trauma of my life.
Just like Mantis said.
Aw, Snake.
Is that why you left Foxhound?
Let's just say that I needed to be alone for a while.
And Alaska was the perfect place.
And you're 50 dogs.
Snake.
Yeah, I'm troubled too, Naomi.
I didn't have a real family either.
We all have our problems, Naomi.
brother who put me through school.
We weren't even blood related and he was much older than me.
Thank you, Mindy, for fixing the soundtrack.
I got you.
He's dead.
I'm sorry.
His name was Frank Hunter.
Is there a woman in your life?
I'm sorry, Frankie after you've been through as many wars as
me, it's hard to trust anyone.
Friends.
Roy Campbell.
You're still calling me friends.
Is that it?
Sorry, I love that part because Campbell's actually so cute
there.
Jager big boss is most trusted lieutenant and the only
member of Foxhound ever to receive the code name Fox gray
Fox I learned a lot from him but didn't you try to kill each
other it's true we did in Zanzibar land but it was nothing
personal we were just professionals on opposite sides that's
all and you still hard to believe war is no reason to end a
friendship that's insane i first met him on the battlefield
he was being held a prisoner of outer heaven but he didn't
look like a prisoner to me he was always so cool and precise
he's so cool i was still green and he showed me the ropes
you knew him well yeah we had like two lines together in the
first game sort of an unwritten rule the next time i saw him
on the battlefield.
We were enemies.
We were fighting bare-handed in a minefield.
Yeah, it was so awesome.
I punched him.
I know it sounds strange to most people, but we were just
two soldiers doing our jobs.
It's like a sport.
Thought there was an actual BGM.
No, it's just me.
Just violence, murdering each other.
Yeah.
It's just me.
I think so, too.
So if you were friends, then how do you explain the ninja's
behavior?
I don't know.
I thought it was in-game BGM.
I don't even know how to sing the song.
Naomi, why did you get into genetic research anyway?
Yeah, why did you?
I never knew who my parents were.
Or even what they looked like.
This is the truth.
I guess I got into genetics because I wanted to figure out
why I am the way I am.
This is the truth.
So you studied about DNA.
I thought if I could thoroughly understand DNA, I could get
back my identity.
I thought that by analyzing a person's genetic
information...
made the cutscene better oh i'll keep going blank spots in
that person's memory memory is stored in dna we're not sure
but we know that a person's genetic fate is determined just
by the sequence of the four bases in their dna so what about
my fate you know my dna sequence don't you your fate i'm i'm
sorry i have no idea of course not you're a scientist not a
fortune teller
See, part of me is also like, I want to see these...
Oh!
My stomach!
IBS?
IBS real?
Go Johnny!
Go, Johnny!
You okay in there?
If only we had the mic, the direction, oh.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Oh my god, why does he walk like Sasquatch?
Otakon, please!
Hey, I'm here.
Oh my god.
It's me.
It's Otakon.
Wow.
They even captured you.
Oh, I thought he was saying wow.
Oh my god.
Stop being a high school bully again.
Don't be mean to him.
Oh my god.
you ask a guy a favor let me go oh my god what was oh oh my
god the the the the moans excuse oh geez it's like an
animal's cage what a smell yeah because of him it's not me
it's the DARPA chief
If you don't hurry up and get me out of here, I'll be laying
next to him.
King Cube Snake has anger issues.
It's true.
He's such a high school bully to poor Otacon.
That's... That's a ration.
So what are you doing here then?
I... I thought you might be hungry.
If you need more food, I can bring some more later.
level six card it'll get you out of that torture room nice
take this to I gotta submit though sorry what's this it's a
handkerchief huh I got it from sniper wolf why why I don't
know why but she's nice to me sounds like Stockholm syndrome
the mate I was taking care of the dogs here after the
terrorists took over they were planning to shoot all the
dogs but sniper wolf stopped them she even let me feed them
when I asked then she fed me when I asked she likes dogs she
must be a good person she likes dogs just like me wake up
you idiot she's the one who shot Merrill well that's all I
can do they're planning to launch a nuke I've got to stop
them don't hurt my girlfriend then have to get past the
communications tower first you have to get me out of here oh
my god snake come on i'm trying my best that guard's got the
key you'll have to take him out give me a break i'm no
soldier i can't take anybody out why is he acting like a
zombie in a cage i'll be killed get out of here oticon he's
coming back oh geez he's coming back that's what i just said
see you later bye Sasquatch.
Oh, it's because he's got the bad leg.
I forgot.
I forgot that his leg is all messed up.
Oh, it actually tells me to use it.
Handkerchief.
Sniper wolf's handkerchief.
Smells faintly of her.
Yeah.
Oh, we got our card.
That's better.
Johnny.
You washed your hands.
Johnny, you washed your hands, right?
You washed your hands, right?
Shut up in there, will ya?
Sniffer.
Actually, I actually really gotta go to the bathroom.
Hey.
What?
Let me out!
Hey!
He fell asleep.
They're giving me every opportunity to use this ketchup.
They're like, hey, you want to use it?
Oh, oh.
Shoot.
That coma doesn't knock me out.
It doesn't even work.
I'm so sleepy.
Maybe if I walk a little.
Yeah, walk around.
Walk it off, buddy.
Walk it off.
The funny part, too, is like, it looks like Johnny.
Like, I can see Johnny with those eyes, you know?
Like, that looks like Johnny to me.
Come here, come here.
Come here, Johnny.
Yeah, yeah.
Look at me.
I don't know.
It just looks like him.
Bless you!
Shut up in there, will ya?
I won't.
I won't be silenced.
You can't stop me.
What are you going to do?
Come in here.
Oh.
Shut up in there, will you?
All right, guys.
Snake, it's showtime.
It's time to submit.
It's time to submit like the little baby that I am.
Remember to give up.
I know it's really hard not to sometimes.
But also, I wanted to see the cutscenes too, so.
Seeing the...
I'll tell you one thing.
The Ocelot one was fine.
Press the resist button repeatedly to regain your strength.
When you've had enough, press the surrender button to
submit.
Submit to you, Ocelot.
When your life reaches zero, the game is over.
There are no continues, my friend.
Patrez, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Okay, let's get started.
So submissive and torturable.
Okay, so it's start and A.
Go submit!
Mission to the Ten Gifted!
What do you mean submit?
Oh, Meryl?
Um, don't look.
Meryl?
Meryl, shield your eyes.
Forever.
Had enough?
So you're human after all.
It does feel wrong, doesn't it?
It does feel wrong.
The torture will stop as I promised.
But I'll take the woman in return.
fun with her before i kill her what do you mean by that did
he just head pat me i hope you can still look at yourself in
the mirror my friend no
no oh
wait they're taking me away do i still get to use the
catch-up then
Man, you can't do that.
The future will be changed.
You created a time paradox.
It's okay.
That's why this is not the canon game, right?
Bless you.
Here it comes.
Oh, not again.
Oh, that sounds like you relieved yourself, Mr. That didn't
sound like...
There he goes.
That's me.
That's gonna be me in a few minutes.
Um...
Oh!
I pulled an Otacon.
That's better.
Okay, oh wait.
No, no, no.
Lay down.
Lay down, Snake.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm dead.
What the hell?
My stuff?
My stuff.
Yippee!
Call?
What should I call?
Call Campbell?
To get to the underground base where Metal Gear is.
Yes.
You'll have to climb the communications tower on the north
side of the cave.
Okay.
Um.
Monster Miller.
I'm alive.
I'm good.
Now that you've got your stuff back, You should take a good
look through it.
If you're slow equipping an item in battle, it could mean
death Right, I go.
I know I know what's in I know what's in there Merrily you
good
So you figured out what I had in mind huh he doesn't know I
can't believe it actually worked Adakan you genius you know,
Anastasia, do you know anything about the bomb that's in my
inventory or?
Snake Hurry up to the communications tower.
I guess not.
Unless she doesn't know anything.
You called, Snake?
Yeah.
She's gonna save.
Bomb!
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
I have to go to the bathroom so bad, but I'm waiting to...
Good luck, Snake.
Thank you!
Um, okay.
Start A button to exit.
And, um...
Where is that?
Not the book.
Is it...
Is it in... wait.
Is it in here?
No.
Where is it?
Remindy.
Palky.
Huh?
Wait!
Oh, there's no bomb if you surrender?
Really?
That's funny.
Hold on, I wanna, um...
I wanna shoot him.
Not dead.
He's got a whole life to live.
But you know, I wanna make sure he's, like, actually knocked
out.
Oh, I guess he's not gonna wake up.
Okay.
Really?
There's no bomb if you...
Huh.
Good to know, I guess.
Pew, pew!
Wait!
I'll take it.
Why does this always happen to me?
Oh, man.
Okay.
Johnny without Merrill's kind of a sad future.
Nah, he'll be fine.
He'll be fine.
He'll find someone else who will love his...
Who will love him for how he...
Yeah, I don't think it's a good idea to go in there.
I think it's, like, really gross.
Who just... who just sneezed?
Oh, me?
I sneezed?
That's so cute.
Bless you, me.
It was me, sorry.
It's not gonna see me, right?
Oh, what's this?
Oh, that's an elevator?
Oh, yes, this is where we're at.
See, remember, like, this part is kind of, like, a blur to
me.
So, oh, we're back in here.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
So now, wait, Colonel, where do I go again?
I'm so sorry.
Cushami, tascaru.
Action!
Snake, Naomi wants to talk to you.
Um, why?
How do you feel, Snake?
I feel fine.
To tell you the truth, I think I'm catching a call.
I think I'm catching a call.
I'm monitoring you via the nanomachines.
You're so cute.
Your body temperature is elevated and your lymph nodes are
slightly swollen.
But don't worry.
It appears to be just a mild rhino virus.
I guess I got it from that soldier.
I've increased your nutrition and elevated your blood sugar
level.
You can't cure it.
Sorry, Snake.
The nanomachines don't carry antibiotics.
Maybe you could find some garlic.
It contains natural antibiotics, you know.
I'm a garlic girl.
Ugh, brown garlic.
Give me a break.
Your dad would have said delicious.
There must be some cold medicine somewhere on the base.
That would make you feel better.
If not, you'll just have to wait until your body's natural
defenses take over.
I'm sorry.
The nanomachines?
The nanomachines can't cure a common cold.
But with what we know about nanomachines...
I'm sorry, they had...
I'm sorry.
Huh?
They cannot cure a common cold?
And yet, and yet, early nanomachines, son.
I actually, I'm going to go to the bathroom real quick.
I'm going to go potty.
And, you know, don't clip that.
I'm going to go to the bathroom.
I'm going to go to the little ghosty girl room.
So, I will be right back.
Actually, I'm going to rewrite this.
Bathroom break.
And I will be right back.
I will be right back.
BRB.
La la la la la.
I hope.
I hope that everyone has been good.
I hope that people haven't been sending wasteful donos.
But she forgot to wash her hands.
I never forget.
Ever, ever, ever, ever.
ever forget.
Give me one second, though.
Um.
Hmm.
Okay.
Now we're good.
Okie dokie.
I sent you a pizza.
Thanks!
I was just thinking how I was trying to get hungry.
Alrighty.
Uh, Colonel, where's the communication tower?
Colonel, where's the tower?
I don't remember.
Where do I go?
There must be some cold medicine somewhere on the base.
That would make you feel better.
Yeah, it would, but like...
You'll just have to wait until your body's natural defenses
take over.
Sorry, guys.
Thank you.
So sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay, okay.
forever bathroom break I'm Johnny what would you consider
wasteful oh wow you know just a spamming spamming ones you
know yeah you should you could buy a gunball with that so
calm
my health is good My rations are full.
I'm a healthy guy.
How do I get to the communication?
Where do I go?
One, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one, one.
Oh, bless you.
Wait, do you think they have some in here?
Any cold medicine?
It's the medical room.
It has to be...
Is Johnny gone?
Watch, it's probably like...
In the...
Oh.
It's probably in the locker that I couldn't get into.
It's probably in here.
Um...
Oh, shoot.
One dollar.
Oh, ew!
Oh my god, that's nasty!
Snake!
I think there's probably one in here but I can't get to it.
What should I do?
Seems pretty economic to me.
It's going to a good cause.
Is it?
He's cold.
If you're cold, he's cold.
Let him in.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
There's something else here, right?
No.
This is the medical room, and they don't have anything?
Medical room, my butt.
Oh, bless you.
He's so cute.
The little sneezes.
You have such a bad constitution, Snake, if you got sick
that quickly.
You ran into him one time.
Rations aren't garlic?
I don't know, actually.
Okay.
Oh, in the vent!
Oh, so true, so true.
The vent over here?
There's Russians.
There might be medicine down here.
I feel...
I feel like I had some medicine.
I feel like I at least saw some medicine.
Something.
Johnny was carrying sneeze, die.
Okay.
There's medicine in Psycho Mantis's area.
You have to go there anyway.
Oh, oh, you know what?
You're so right.
Because you're right, you're right, you're right.
Because that's how we were going to the communications tower
and that's when we get stopped.
Yes, it's all coming back to me.
Yes, sneaky, sneaky snake.
Oh,
I have to go all the way back to the third building.
Oh.
This game is the first game to ever start my MGS brain ride
as a kid.
Never did play the OG game until years later.
Even though this is so vastly different from the original
game, it is still a lot of fun.
It is still a great game to get your start on.
I believe.
Oh, that scared me.
That scared me more than anything.
Nothing to report.
What?
It's no one, actually.
See ya.
Actually, how did he see me?
he see me how did he see me I'm actually you don't even know
why I'm stream sniping that guy is actually one 80 IQ okay
now we got to go through this nonsense again.
Oh, oh, I passed it.
Just fake a British accent and pretend you're liquid.
The smartest thing would have been to bleach my hair?
And...
Oh.
Robot?
Was that a robot?
Um, it would have been to bleach my hair and pretend to
actually be liquid.
you know kind of like using the Rykov mask I think I should
join the team I think I could have given them way better
advice this poor guy's ankles okay let's see now this is the
tricky part because as soon as we take him down they're
going to be like huh something something something someone's
here uh where's your status report laddy dody do you know so
we got to figure out yeah freeze him again what but if i
freeze him i gotta be fast gotta be so fast i'm scared
because there's the other guy that he does walk around i
guess then because otherwise he wouldn't have i don't know
his path at all the guy here let's check Let's check.
Let's see where he comes from.
Let's see.
Because there's a guy.
The guy saw me over there, you know?
I kind of want him to shake me down, or I kind of want to
shake him down and take his, uh, dog tags.
But I don't want to waste time.
Okay, hear the other walking.
Does it, does anyone ever show up?
He's sleeping.
Like, there was someone that came and caught me.
How, though?
I don't understand where did they...
Where did they come from?
I hope Snake doesn't sneeze.
He wouldn't.
He's better now.
Right, Snake?
Yeah.
He's better now.
Probably the guy upstairs heard you.
Oh, you think he came, like, running down?
Mmm, maybe.
Okay, so I freeze him, I come out, I knock him out, and then
I get in the box.
Or I get in the truck.
In the box.
Okay, here we go.
Freeze.
Freeze?
Uh, freeze.
Hmm.
Freeze.
I don't want to...
Okay.
Maybe this is not working.
So, uh...
He's so shivery.
You cold, buddy.
You just go inside.
There's no one here anyway.
Nothing here.
I can do the report for you.
Freeze.
Free.
Freeze!
Snake, if you were a mere 149, then a weird doll.
How small do you think I am?
Okay.
I think he's falling asleep.
I think so too.
But then how did we get it to work before?
Hmm.
Weird.
Okay, hold on.
You know what?
I'm gonna, okay.
This might not work.
This might not work, but...
If we die, whatever.
At least we tried.
Did he wake up from that noise?
Uh.
Why didn't that work?
It exploded.
It went off.
Why didn't it work?
Yeah, it didn't stun him at all.
Oh my gosh.
Aren't you 152 centimeter?
Yeah.
Duh.
They nerfed the stun grenade in this game.
Get closer for the freeze.
Okay, let's try it.
Oh.
Wait, hold on.
Closer.
Freeze.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Um, okay.
Uh.
Then I, uh, I, uh, equip and crawl out and stand up and
equip gonna get you buddy sorry taking you out oh sorry I
forgot to okay good night and run clean
clean clean clean won't anybody take me to the nuke building
please I'm just a small box who wants to go to the nuke
building won't anyone take me there yeah just a lot just a
hunk of junk that's what it is yeah there is a camera but
it's easy to avoid luckily for that one toha welcome the
membership thank you simple and clean if you will when you
walk away you don't hear me say this might be a mistake but
please oh baby don't go simple and clean as always oh my
gosh i don't know if my voice is ever gonna recover you guys
it's so bad i wonder if my throat is ever going to recover i
think if i keep screaming it definitely won't but you know
If I keep yelling all the time, it won't for sure, but you
know.
Oh my god.
Give it time and take it easy.
It will help a lot.
Yeah, I've been, like, drinking a lot of, like, throat,
like, teas for your throat.
Actually, I have a different tea, a throat tea.
I just remember.
Okay, I'll start drinking that, too.
And, uh, just kind of, like, having cough drops and stuff.
daily but I fear I feel I actually have a genuine fear
because like I can't hit high notes like I did before I'm
scared maybe a vocal coach could help as well maybe yeah I
was thinking I've been trying to like I was thinking or
rather I was doing like some light vocal exercises but I
don't want to like do so much and then make it worse on
accident you know so So I'm kind of like, what do I do?
He's going to look over?
It was risky, but I took the risk.
Do some hypnotherapy for your throat.
Yeah.
Lead singer of a band...
Wait, I went to the wrong one again.
He broke a blood vessel and sink...
Wait, I can't tell if you're being serious or not.
Throw it in now, things better than ever.
What does that mean?
Wait, wait, is that real?
Oh, I do have the level 6 card!
You're so right!
Wait, where was...
What was in...
What was...
Was there any level 6 down there?
I can't remember.
Let's try it, though.
Is it pretty flabby?
No, it's just, like...
Raspier than usual.
Like, if I...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
If I sing high, like sometimes I just can't hit the note.
All of these I can go into.
Yeah, four.
That one I can go into.
This one.
This is two.
It's this one.
Uh, I can't read.
Six!
Body armor!
I was good too.
Four.
Yeah.
Gosh, taking out the cameras and them staying out.
No one wants to come back here.
Of course they just keep the cameras dead.
Last time I had a bad cough, it took like two months to
recover.
Oof.
It was only...
It wasn't a bad cough.
It was just that I lost my...
I had lost my voice from getting sick.
It just hasn't recovered since.
Well, we can't see Otacon.
I mean, well, obviously, but we can't even see that area.
Sometimes it just takes time.
I'll be patient then.
I will be patient.
The commander is waiting for you, Mr. Foxhound.
Gosh, everything...
Meal, ready to eat.
Um.
Everything is, like, so, uh...
So quick to respawn.
It's kind of awesome.
Is there anything else in here?
My eardrums are rumbling.
Oh, what's on there?
Nothing.
What if it was...
Can you imagine?
What if it was, like, Newgrounds?
Like, Psycho Mantis.
What are you...
What are you doing?
Okay.
Doge, mate.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh.
Hello, dog.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Oh, this is the tranquilizer.
We don't need any of this.
Oh.
Up here.
Yes, yes.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, pup.
Excuse me, little...
Oh, wait.
Uh, it's this one, right?
Oh, I have all...
I'm full?
Okay.
Is there a dog in here?
Sound Rouge.
Welcome to membership.
Niels.
Thank you for the 20th and...
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh
my god, Meryl's blood.
Snake, you're still sick?
Wait,
what?
My trauma is happening.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
My trauma.
still help I want to help you quiet down save your strength
I was a fool I wanted to be a soldier Merrill oh war is
meaningless Merrill nothing comes out of war you got a
husband out of war please save yourself go on living and do
Don't give up on people.
Oh.
Don't forget me.
This doesn't happen if you save her, right?
Snake, about Merrill.
Colonel.
I'm sorry, Colonel.
I'm sorry.
Listen to me.
Oh, it does still happen.
I wasn't able to protect her.
No, I don't think so.
Snake, it's okay.
You did what you could.
Now let it rest.
Colonel.
She joined up of her own free will.
I'm sure she was prepared for this.
No, you're wrong.
Meryl thought she had to become a soldier.
Thought it was the only way.
She said she thought it would bring her closer to her dead
father.
She said that.
She wasn't ready for real combat.
I shouldn't have pushed her so hard.
No.
It's all my fault.
That's not like you, Snake.
Oh, Master.
What is it?
Master Miller?
Ha ha ha!
Master Miller Jump scare!
master snake you can have regrets if you want to it's only
natural but you can't keep attacking yourself for things
that happened in the past nothing good will come from that
he's right don't kick yourself it doesn't suit a legend like
you and besides that for all we know merrill's okay right
okay snake forget about merrill stop liquid that's what
merrill would want to you're right Snake.
Merrill.
She's pretty special to you, huh?
Well, yeah, special.
Master is such a good guy.
There aren't many tomboyes like her.
Tomboy?
That's not what I meant.
She's the Colonel's niece and a combat buddy.
Oh my god, combat buddy!
Come on.
This is like a police interrogation.
No, I just...
I guess it's in the jeans.
The jeans.
What do you mean?
What are you talking about, Colonel?
Tomboy love?
No, I just remembered about it.
Naomi's grandfather I think Naomi said he rose as high as
assistant secretary in the FBI during Edgar Hoover's time is
that right yes yes he was Japanese and he became a special
undercover investigator to nab the mafia when was that oh
master Miller clock in her lies oh where oh yeah go go
master go I thought that you didn't have any family oh I
researched it after I became an adult my grandfather was
already dead by the time i learned about him i never even
had the chance to meet him don't she's making it all sob
story good luck watch your back snake master miller is like
sniffing her out i love that
deep throat just imagine snake david hater trying to do a
british accent to infiltrate I'm telling you though.
Oh, bless you.
He sneezes so much more in this area.
It's kind of weird.
Okay, Martin, thank you!
Wait, oh, my doughnos are kind of weird.
There we go.
The problem with you being on the team is the second snake
flirted with you.
You'd scream, hang up with Kodak, and never call again.
Bless you.
Don't say that.
Ah!
Oh yeah, bubba.
I'm gonna try and shoot this one down.
There we go.
Oh wait, my rations are full anyway.
There's only this one?
Okay.
Nice.
Chew.
I can't wait for the call.
I can't wait for the call where he's just like, That girl is
weird!
That girl is not normal!
That girl...
That girl is...
Telling lies!
Where's a little rat?
I'm gonna take down a little rat.
Oh, there is one!
There's one!
There we go!
Oh!
Oh, I gotta, I gotta put in the other disc.
Hold out, you guys.
Yippee!
Time to change the disc, everyone.
Take it out.
And let me put it in here.
Let me grab the other one.
Okay.
My, the first disc, unfortunately, has some, like, damage.
It's kind of, like, cracked a little.
Okay.
Disc.
Wait, for some reason...
Wait.
I always thought that disc...
disc too.
Wait, Otacon is supposed to tell you to change the discs,
isn't he?
I thought it was after um, I could have sworn it was after
after sniper wolf.
Hmm.
Oh, it's just an MGS4.
Wow.
Wait, hold on.
I am going to call people though.
Let's see where we're at.
nuclear warhead is almost here the new nuclear and get to
metal gears underground maintenance base i'm getting the
overland route is blocked by a glacier climb the
communications tower so you can go over it got it the
communications towers consist of tower a and tower b hey do
i even need chaff grenades here to get to tower b you'll
have to use the outside walkway remember snake dark places
are dangerous places you can't see where your enemies are
coming from after sniper they loaded part one with more cut
scenes ah see see see because i was like you fight you kill
sniper wolf and then you change it right or no response what
what where are you where are you master miller snake it's
dark inside the communication towers you should use your
night vision or thermal goggles if you want thermal goggles
there's a pair on the same floor as my lab be careful there
are always a lot of soldiers guarding the communication
towers the walkway is directly between the communication
towers head for there don't tell me to use thermal goggles
not you too ought to not you too let's just save just in
case you know I'm the worse though at calling Nostasha all
the time.
Gather ye rosebuds while ye may.
Old time is still a flying.
And this same flower that smiles today, tomorrow will be
dying.
Snake, laughter is the best medicine.
You should be happy you've got enough free time to play a
game.
Enjoy yourself, okay?
Thanks for anything.
Thanks.
When you're in a dark place, you should use night vision or
thermal goggles.
Is it really that dark in?
Oh, okay.
Is it really that dark in here?
Or am I...
I feel like I'm being...
Like...
I feel like I'm being like gaslit.
I can see perfectly fine.
Is it that dark?
Ooh.
The
night vision goggles did not pick that up.
So...
Thanks a whole lot.
lot thanks a whole lot um oh my god
oh this is this part just go snake just go just run snake
just run just run snake just go snake oh whoa oh shoot um
Oh, uh, it's kind of, oh, come on, it's a- Oh my god, oucha!
Oh, turn, turn this way.
Yeah, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Uh, uh, look up, snake!
There we go.
Go!
I enjoy all the killing!
Killing, killing, killing, killing, killing, killing.
Killing, killing, killing, killing.
Ah!
Oh, oh, um, oh my god, they come from behind me too.
Launch!
Oh my god, he can't throw it because they keep shooting at
me.
Thank you!
Oh, it did go off.
Oh, oh my god.
No, I'm trying to auto-aim at no one.
Oh my god.
Hey, do.
Uh-oh.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
gosh please right in the crotch yeah oh my god just run
snake geez just go just run oh my gosh oh my gosh you were
so obnoxious how do you have such good aim oh my god i'm
gonna oh my gosh
what okay nice just kill go go go go
oh did i make it
Oh my god, it didn't work.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm actually stuck!
Oh my god, please.
Wait.
Me do.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
There's a ladder?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Thank you guys.
gain our health a little bit.
Because I remember the other door is stuck, right?
It's frozen shut, so you can't get to it.
What a thrill.
Yeah, so that's why I remember running just past it.
I was like, it's time.
It's time, it's time, it's time.
It's quiet up here.
made it to the roof you must be exhausted snake i am it was
no big deal he's so cool i'm monitoring you closely your
heart rate is elevated and your breathing is shallow what's
the matter snake you out of shape from all that dog mushing
then climb down and proceed north you're out of shape now
automated response
Why do you say it like that?
I know, right?
What are you doing, Master?
Why won't you pick up?
Otacon, I'm up on the roof.
That was a pretty fast climb.
I wanted to go slowly, but someone there forced me to move
faster.
Oh, gosh.
Well, you can relax because there's an elevator in Tower B.
Good.
That walkway will take you to Tower B.
Oh, thank goodness.
Surely there won't be anything like in the elevator or
anything.
We'll just go down.
We'll just...
go all the way down and we'll relax while doing it you know
oh my gosh sorry i'm like it keeps kind of stretching
because my oh so um not last night the night before last um
when i was sleeping my cat he was sleeping next to me and he
started to throw up and like you can hear when a cat is
about to throw up they do like the you know and i like woke
up and i was like no because he was face he was looking
directly at me and if i hadn't woken up he would have just
thrown up all over my face and so i quickly pick him up and
i like try to gently get him off of my bed but i slip i slip
and i um right next to my bed i have a cat tower for him
because he likes to climb it and i slip and i i bash my head
into the corner of the of the cat tower i i'm like i have
like a like I have a bump on my head from where I want where
my I hit and on my nose you can't really see it only if I
zoom in you can see it but I have like I cut my nose and I
um pulled something in my leg and like it was just a huge
mess it was like three in the morning and I'm like I had to
I literally like launched him I felt so bad because he was
like throwing up he's not feeling well and so I like
launched him and I like fell out of bed and like so now I'm
so sore because of it like my neck i was so sorry you
wouldn't think like that because like i don't know maybe i
need to like work my ectoplasm a little bit more oh luckily
you're already dead i know right i know otherwise i would
have been in a big trouble and it was so close it was so
close to like hitting the corner of the cat tower into my
eye it was i was like oh my gosh i'm such a mess it was such
a mess i was such a mess marilyn thanks for the five gifted
Ugh.
Anyway, who else was I calling?
Nistasha.
I wonder how Deep Throat's doing.
I wonder who that guy is.
To coincide with the signing of the START III Accord.
Hmm.
According to the terms of START III, both Russia and the US
are to reduce the number of nuclear warheads in deployment.
You were gonna have an eye patch.
22,000 and 2,500 missiles.
It was my left...
My left eye, so...
I would have been...
No.
Yeah, I would have been Solidus.
It was my left eye.
It's a big concern for him and his supporters.
Did I save?
I don't think I did.
We'll do it just in case again.
What is it, Snake?
Oh.
I know.
Typical politician.
Of course.
Beep, beep.
Beep.
Okay.
what do you mean what do you mean president mint no i said i
would be solidus george sears is the president you guys in
paradise lost milton wrote solitude sometimes is best
society and short retirement urges sweet return sweet return
why you came back sneak you got tired of your short
retirement in alaska huh uh no um i was actually dragged
here mailing let's not get Let's not romanticize my
kidnapping.
Let's not romanticize how this happened.
It's kind of spooky.
Oh, there's the door.
Seems pretty safe.
Is there anything in here that I can...
No.
It's quiet.
Quiet.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Run, Snake, run!
Oh my- Whoa!
Snake!
Dodge, Snake!
No way.
Throw it!
Wait, Snake!
Oh my god.
Wait, Snake, you're gonna fall!
Oh wait, that's not how that works.
He stopped the momentum.
He hit the invisible wall and stopped the momentum!
How did that happen?
Let's go, Snake.
Blew that up with a grenade.
Perfect plan.
Exactly what I would have thought of too.
Where did those move?
missiles come from.
I'm going to take care of some errands, but I'm now ready
for a minute to take on Kojimbo's Wild Ride Part 2.
Time to run from a helicopter.
Oh my gosh!
A hindee!
What's a Russian gunship doing in an area like this?
Liquid.
I'm afraid I can't let you get past here.
You're not going any farther.
Whoa.
it's a long way down if only i had a rope whoa i should be
able to use that rope i got what are you what rope uh yeah
you know it
wait did i get a rope if i stay here i'm finished did i get
one while I was running away from the guards?
Uh.
This isn't where I fight him.
I go...
I...
I go down first, right?
Oh, I did get a rope!
I did get a rope.
I didn't even notice it.
Here we go.
Wee!
Whoa!
That's close.
Time to do this.
Whatever.
However this works.
Uh.
Okay.
Uh, I'm moving.
I'm not moving.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, it's still a cutscene.
Okay, I'm moving.
And I'm going down.
Uh, yes, please.
Thanks, Colonel.
Click the A button to kick away from the wall.
While away from the wall, push down on the control stick to
descend.
Okay, if you kick off the wall while pushing the control
stick left or right, you make a large jump in that
direction.
He's so, he's so quiet.
You can walk slowly across the wall if you press and hold
the B button.
Why would it?
To move a little at a time in a certain direction, push the
control stick while holding the B button.
If you're careful with the timing, you should be able to
dodge the gunfire from behind while you repel down.
Okay.
If anyone can do it, you can, Snake.
That's it.
All right.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm just...
Oh, there's a...
There's a ration.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
I somehow got it.
Oh, I don't know how I'm doing this.
I'm pushing off it.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
Nice.
I think I'm cracked at this.
Oh, was that it?
Wait, I didn't...
That was not me.
That was all snake.
I didn't get hit what?
They were so kind with that part.
For real!
$20 for my 20th super chat.
No way.
Thank you!
What is that?
Who's breathing?
Oh.
Can I...
Oh, maybe I can see for this now.
Uh, how do I use it yet?
A button to set.
Huh?
What's wrong with the alert though?
There are people over here though, aren't there?
Yeah, I see him.
I see him.
Um...
Let's take these guys out.
Crouch.
Take my meds.
Here.
I have to be really fast though.
I have to be like, boom, bam, boom.
Oh gosh.
Did I kill him?
Wait, wait, I can't see them at all.
Oh my gosh.
I can't see them at all.
Wait, they're not, they're not coming down, are they?
Ah!
Oh my gosh, scared me.
You guys could warn me.
Oh.
They won't be able to see me like this, though.
Oh, they can see me like this.
Ow!
Try the Nikita.
I don't want to...
Wait, how many do I have?
of 40?
Well, hold on.
Let's see if the guys are still here.
If they respawned all three of them.
They did.
They did respawn all three of them.
It doesn't feel any easier.
You know?
Until I get them.
Hmm.
I could Nikita them.
If I Nikita one of them, well, I get all three of them.
I wonder.
Wait, okay, how do I use this thing?
A.
Release the fire.
Okay.
Here we go!
They're not gonna shoot it down, are they?
Oh.
Don't shoot it down.
Are they all dead?
What do you mean?
no use this is the perfect time to use a scope what do you
mean no use no the other two guys are still up there you
guys I think it only took out one guy no What?
They're all still standing!
I'm still standing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What?
That's insane.
Oh, dang it.
Where did they go?
Where do they run to?
Oh, uh...
There we go.
I think I got all three of them now.
Easy!
Pshah!
Oh!
Stinger Missile!
Die!
That guy's so dumb.
Why?
You can't get me if you're in a helicopter and I can go
inside.
Idiot.
What a dummy.
What an idiot.
You can't go inside the building in your helicopter.
What a silly goose.
What am I thinking?
I gotta go down the elevator.
Good one, boss.
Thanks.
Gosh, he just doesn't have a brain.
He is the lesser...
He is the lesser clone.
The way to the top is blocked, huh?
well we can worry about that later why don't you go and see
what's happening below I don't I need to go why do I need to
go to the top master Miller what do you have to say no
response huh what are you busy doing snake I'm heading your
way what are you talking about oh yeah well there's
something I've got to ask you well what is it hmm well you
see I'll ask you when I see you.
Bye.
The death flags.
He's gonna confess.
He he.
You have Stinger missiles.
Now you have at least got a chance against the Hind.
Only a chance.
Well, you are not exactly evenly armed.
That Hind is a monster.
You only have a small chance to win.
But at least it's better than no chance.
or a cold-hearted bunch, huh?
To shoot around that hind, you will have to get to a place
with good visibility.
Do not try to fight in that walkway.
No, no, don't worry.
Get up on that roof, where you will have a clean shot at
him.
Yeah, Mr. Miller's in the bathroom.
It's okay.
He's human, you know?
Yeah, it's a good point.
I didn't think that...
I didn't even realize or, like, think about that I didn't
have the Singer Missiles.
So I was like, la la la, la.
Let's go and fight Hindy with my Nikita Missiles.
What is it, Snake?
We're just fighting within the key to myself.
No big D.
And BD.
If I go out there, is he still there?
Or...
Because I kind of want the ration.
The proud man does not eat rotting meat, even when hungry,
nor steal water from another's well when he thirsts.
But on the other hand, you were forced to steal or find
every item you've got.
So I guess I shouldn't say that.
You shouldn't.
It's kind of insensitive.
Thank you for realizing.
that.
What the?
Huh?
That's so weird.
What?
Why wouldn't the elevator be working?
Hmm.
Fushigi.
Dane.
It's kind of sus, not gonna lie it is a little sus right
like oh yeah i should probably be making sure that there's
no cameras tell me each way okay oh damn damn uh i didn't
notice that i i looked i looked at it
Liquid is a silly goose, since Snake is no maverick.
Meanwhile, AutoCAD is slowly becoming a good wingman by
melting Snake's ice man cold heart.
Oh my.
Oh, I would have had a good moment.
I forgot that there's grip in this game.
Good job, Snake.
Stop, you're going to make me want to watch Top Gun again.
Wait, is Otakon here?
Already?
Our little stealth guy.
Don't shoot!
Snake, you can put the gun down.
It's me, don't shoot.
You don't recognize his voice?
It's me, Snake.
Otakon, how'd you get here?
Well, it wasn't as dramatic as your entrance, believe me.
you were watching yeah I was watching watching the whole I
was riding in the back of their truck thanks to the stealth
camouflage whose truck how did you get up here the elevator
of course okay so you're telling me that these guys first
floor of the circular staircase was destroyed are just
chilling in the elevator that's why I took the elevator the
elevator was working yeah that's right yeah that's right
yeah yep just chilling the whole oh you're incredible like a
movie hero or something like a Japanese anime you're wrong
in the movies the hero always saves the girl you mean
Merrill sorry Forget I said anything.
It hurts.
It actually hurts more.
I feel like such a baby that I submitted.
There's something I've really got to ask you.
It's why I followed you up this far.
What's that?
Have you ever loved someone?
Why is the music so creepy?
That's what you came to ask.
No, I mean, I...
I was wondering if even soldiers...
fall in love what are you trying to say do you think love
can bloom even on a battlefield yeah yeah I do I think at
any time any place people can fall in love with each other
but if you love someone you have to be able to protect them
I think so too I have a favor to ask oh oh don't worry it'll
be easy he said the thing I told you before I won't hurt
anyone I don't want you to I'm starting here hungry oh look
at that playful shove the elevator is stopped down there I
want you to get it to move wait what do you mean down there
oh you see you see
that's weird that is weird it was working before but now it
isn't maybe the panel's broken can you fix it can you fix it
it was working before if it's the mechanism leave it to me
Matias!
Welcome to membership, thank you.
I've got to go and swat a noisy fly.
Yeah.
I'll stay here and hold the fort.
Good luck.
You'll definitely do that.
You really look like hell.
Are you okay?
Oh.
Don't worry.
If I do this, it doesn't matter.
Saku, thank you.
Aww.
I just pretend like I'm not here.
And then I'm not scared.
Looks like he's got a mustache.
Strange logic.
I'm counting on you.
That will become a handshake later.
There he goes, mysterious Sasquatch.
Oh, to God.
I love snakes like mocap in this.
Oh, nice!
I mean, not nice.
We're about to go fight a hindee.
It's strange.
It looks like Liquid really wants to have a showdown with
you.
I'm looking at maintenance digitally enhanced satellite
images right now.
He really wants to fight.
It seems he's waiting for you.
Like a vulture circling its prey.
I hope everyone's enjoying the live broadcast.
Are you?
Sorry, Snake.
I wish I could do something to help.
Snake, are you guys enjoying the live broadcast?
Please don't go up on the roof.
I have to.
I can't run from this one.
Sometimes there's like a long pause between the codecs.
Like when they're finishing them.
Master Miller.
What about you?
I'm about to go fight a helicopter, Master Miller.
I really need your advice.
I'm scared.
Okay, actually maybe Nastasha would be the most helpful
here.
You have Stinger missiles.
Now you have at least got a chance against the Hine.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
She said the same thing.
After I beat the hind, we'll get something to eat.
You're going to go after that hind now?
Yep.
After your behind.
It's just circling the tower.
He must be waiting for you.
Well, you won't hear it for much longer.
In the meantime, I'll fix the elevator so you can use it
later.
Hind.
Uh, what about Deep Throat?
I know he's not going to say anything.
The guy's shy.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Liquid is still hovering.
Yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
Mailing.
There we go.
What's up, Snake?
You can buy fire department elevator override keys on eBay?
What?
What does that, what would that do?
What does that do?
Does it just make you able to use the elevator however you
want?
In China, they say, once the fox gets his nose in, he'll
soon find a way to make his body follow.
description of you you can do it snake but you've got to be
flexible adapt to each situation uniquely okay all right I'm
getting very hungry so let's see stinger missiles aim in
first person fire with a align site on target wait what was
it fire with a okay let's go Can you see Otacon down here?
Is he, like, chilling around in here?
I mean, there's nowhere for him to go.
Right?
Like...
He's using Stealth Camel.
Yeah, but I mean, it's not, like, the best.
Thermal goggles?
I don't have thermal.
I only had night vision.
Oh, my eyes.
Ugh.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go!
Oh, I should have used the body armor for the stairs.
That's okay, though.
Ikimashou.
Yeah, I don't even have the thermal goggles.
What the?
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
You jerky!
Okay.
Gosh, okay, this is where I have to start looking out for
the...
For the...
Cameras.
I didn't know what MGS was moved to today.
I'm sorry!
Yeah, like, some of my plans got moved around last minute.
I'm so sorry, I tried to announce it in several places.
I put the waiting room up earlier.
It's okay though.
Honestly, a lot of it was me trying to get the dang PSG so
far.
There we go.
Oh, a little too high.
Hello?
I feel like that should have hit it.
There we go.
Okay.
My last Oshi blasted off into space on a rocket ship.
Whoa, that sounds awesome.
She also used to stream MGS.
Thanks for the stream.
Of course.
You know, I could be your new Oshi if you wanted.
Just saying.
You know, no pressure or anything.
I also play MGS.
And, um...
I have no reason to go to space, so...
I'm just saying.
Oh!
Sneaky, snarky.
I can't ever get this one.
properly.
Hey!
Here we go.
You're my new Osi.
Wow.
Where's your sense of loyalty?
No, just kidding.
You threw away your old Osi that fast?
Where is your sense of loyalty?
I'm just kidding.
Amazing how much easier this part is.
I know, right?
It's actually it feels unfair a little bit.
Oh my gosh!
So goofy.
It's so funny, though.
There we go.
Nice.
We had to move on.
Yeah, I get it.
I do get it.
But if I found someone very similar to my Oshi, even if it
was like a similar voice and everything, I'd be like, I
probably would also be like, okay, you know what?
I get it.
Okay, I'd probably also move on.
Famous.
Nice.
Health is good enough.
I won't grab that ration.
Well, actually, I don't think I could come back here.
So you know what, we will just top off.
Choo!
Oshi or your loyalty to Minto.
Don't make me choose.
Where's the door?
Huh?
Oh, oh, here it is.
Here we go.
I noticed the ladder this time.
I noticed.
Oh.
Okay.
Have I told you lately that you're truly awful?
Really?
Me?
I'm the bad one.
Mm-hmm.
Sorry.
Only unshowered people are my Oshi.
Goodbye forever, Minto.
How do you know I didn't shower today, huh?
When will we get to see a made-Mint live reaction to Ocelot
kissing snake?
I don't know.
Oh, don't forget to save.
Yeah, thank you.
I don't know.
Maybe sooner than you think.
knows what can i do for you snake yeah i really don't want
to have to go through shooting all those guys all those
again though usually it's pretty good about like just
sending me back but you know what if something happens to
the disc who knows he who is firm in will molds the world to
himself don't forget what you're here to do you've got to
seize any opportunities that present themselves but i guess
i don't have to tell you that do i she's so flirty sound You
know Liquid is still hovering around the roof of Tower B.
He's waiting for you.
He's waiting for me.
Snake It's time for you to take him on.
Woohoo
I'll repair the elevator while you're fighting that hind.
It might take some time, so don't hurry.
Okay I'll take my time Oh wait, oh, I should switch to the
body armor Seize the moment.
Bum, bum.
Brother!
So, the snakes finally come out of his home.
Are you ready now?
My brother.
Why are you calling me brother?
Who the hell are you?
He explained it.
I'm you.
I'm your shadow.
I'm a sight...
What?
I'll send you to hell to meet him!
A cat is so...
What?
Standing man emoji.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, so we can see him.
There.
Where's our... stinger?
What is he?
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, he's fast.
Hey!
I don't know if that'll work.
Oh, I guess it did work.
Oh my gosh, it's so fast!
How is it so fast?
Oh.
He's so fast.
Maybe he'll come around this way.
Oh, there he is.
Ouch.
He's taking a lot of hits.
Ah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh my gosh.
Just posting a bullet, it's nice.
Oh!
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
I don't think I got him.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
He doesn't hit me as easily though.
Oh, oh, oh, ouch, ouch.
I don't know if that'll work.
Are you telling me I had a bad shot?
Over here?
Aye!
Oh, oh!
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh.
That's it?
That's all you got?
That's all you've got?
Liquid?
Oh, is he doing the down low thing?
No!
Ow!
Don't, don't, don't, don't.
Like, weird.
You can't tell when he's down low, because...
Oh!
Before, it would, like, do an actual...
Like, the music would get so quiet, you know?
I'm not sure where is he.
So fast.
Ouch!
Oh, yeah, I got, I hit you.
And it was a nice shot, actually.
Gosh, this fight is so much easier.
Oh, my God, you're so loud, please.
It
does get a little bit quieter.
Where the heck is he?
This side?
Yeah.
I lost you.
Where are you?
Wait, where?
Ah, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I keep losing you!
I keep losing you, Liquid!
You come here first!
Um, skill issue perhaps?
Liquid?
Oh my god.
There's the space of junk!
Where the heck are you?
Oh my gosh.
That's so loud.
Maybe he'll come over this.
Woo!
How did I avoid that?
Hey, this!
Almost there.
They did this in the original...
Oh, never mind.
Where did you...
What?
There's the hellfire.
Oh, here it is.
The best part.
Go Snake!
Yeah!
Good
thing we got that body armor on.
Liquid!
See you in hell, liquid.
Yeah!
Absolute cinema.
Explosions in the background.
Yeah!
That's my action here.
Snake, the elevator's working.
You've fixed it?
No, that's the weird thing.
It just moved by itself.
It's headed your way now.
Is that so?
So, Nino.
That explosion before.
What was it?
Oh, I had to take out that helicopter.
Helicopter?
That's incredible, Snake.
You knew I was going up there.
I just want to make sure again.
I cannot hate this ever.
I know it's so awesome.
The entrance to the underground maintenance base is towards
the back of the snowfield ahead.
Find a safe place to hide out for a while.
I'm going underground.
I know, I know.
You don't have to tell me.
And stay out of my way.
Don't try to be a hero or anything.
Call me if you need to.
All right.
Let's brag to Miller.
Oh my god, Master Miller is going to be really proud.
He's going to be like, you took...
Sorry, I was really...
I had some, you know, I had some Taco Bell earlier.
I just, I just couldn't, you know, I just didn't want you to
hear that.
Snake jumping off a missile is canon to me.
Me too.
Where are we?
Also, are we not going to talk about Snake jumping off that
missile like Mario jumped off a bullet bill?
We are going to talk about it.
It was awesome!
Oh, he's probably still busy, you know.
It's okay.
I get it.
Did you see that?
Did you see that, Colonel?
You did it, Snake.
You shot down the hind.
I know.
I was so worried.
Liquid couldn't have survived that I wonder But even so Just
because we've taken out their leader Doesn't mean they're
going to give up They're still going to try to launch that
nuke You're right Dedication is so real Hope you're doing
all today, Mint You do none The underground base is past the
communications tower The elevator is working again, isn't
it?
I'm glad that you love Um Uh Ace combat Probably as much as
I love Metal Gear But be careful Don't waste your whole
paycheck, you know Stay on the ground.
If you stop by a burger place while looking for food, maybe
you'll run into why Miller couldn't help with that Hein D.
Oh, he was taking care of his food chain.
You're so right.
Oh, wait.
I don't know why, but the elevator just started working
again.
If you take it all the way to the bottom of Tower B and go
outside, you'll be in the snowfield.
The snowfield.
The underground maintenance base is in the north of the
snowfield.
I was in the kitchen making a snack.
and I could hear your cheers from my headphones peeking out
from my room.
Sorry.
Sorry that I'm loud.
Sorry that I'm a little loud sometimes.
But you can't blame me, right?
For cheering.
There's nothing else here?
There really isn't...
Whoa.
I thought I saw something.
Oh.
Oh, I was seeing the stuff landing on my camera.
Oh, okay.
Let's go take the elevator.
Here, I'll turn my mic down just a little bit.
Goop.
There we go.
And down we go.
Had to go attend to some burgers on the stove.
That guy.
He's in Burger Town, real.
Why would they give us fam- Oh, maybe if you use the famus
on the...
If you use the famus on the...
What's the word?
Oh my goodness.
The cameras.
No, be louder, please.
I didn't notice that my mic was sounding a little bit weird
recently.
Maybe it's just me?
I don't know.
I'll work around, I'll work on it, I'll see what's going on
with it.
They're all still down, right?
Yeah, they're not moving, Ernie.
I mean, they weren't moving before, but...
Yeah, they're all pointed.
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
I'm actually kind of low, really.
Oh, okay.
Like, I have my compressor on and everything.
It just gets so energetic, you guys, I'm sorry.
I haven't noticed, really.
That's good.
Sounds good.
Make sounds fine.
That is good.
I feel with how much you love these action cutscenes, you
would love the Devil May Cry games.
I believe you.
I do love over-the-top action.
It's so fun.
Okay.
I love my communications tower ASMR.
What's this?
Grenade.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, we'll take those.
And here we use the FAMIS.
We gotta get ready.
Oh, there's a ration right there.
Oh, I never noticed.
Oh, wow.
Push the button.
That's why we have Metal Gear Rising.
So true.
Don't forget food tile.
I don't know.
Huh?
Hmm.
I hope I don't run into anyone in here.
Oh.
Uh.
There we go.
It's working though!
Oh my gosh, this is it.
This is the codec call.
Snake, there's something I forgot to tell you before.
There were five stealth camouflage prototypes in my lab.
Yeah, so?
If you take out the one I'm wearing, that leaves four.
Hey, this isn't first grade math class.
I thought I'd get one for you, so I went back to the lab
and...
And?
The four suits were missing.
also about the elevator that I checked out it's really
strange it was like someone was intentionally holding it
when you were riding on it did the weight limit warning go
off that's another thing that bothered me about it yeah the
warning went off and I know I couldn't be over the limit are
you sure about 135 whoa he's tiny skinny baby 650 pounds it
would take at least five people to The guys who stole my
stealth prototypes are in there with you.
Oh my god!
No way!
Oh my god.
I can't believe they're in here with us.
Oh, oh.
I can also shoot.
Shoot.
Oh my god, that's spin.
Okay.
So true, Snake.
They were chumps.
They were.
Nice.
I hear a...
I hear a camera.
In here?
Maybe.
Oh!
What was that?
What was that over here?
I guess I should collect everything first, though.
Oh,
the PSG tranquilizer version.
The tranquilizer one.
PSG bullets.
Oh, it's this one right here.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe I can get it from here.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
That's right.
That's right, buddy.
Try again, idiot.
Actually, don't.
Let me go.
I just want to live.
I just want to go.
Another one, right?
Oh, we're good.
Too late for it.
Oh, I thought it was cold medicine.
I thought it was cold medicine.
Okay, when the door opens...
Okay, one of my biggest issues...
Not one of my biggest.
it's not the biggest but it's an issue that i really have
with specifically the fight with sniper wolf and the
cutscene afterwards in the original the the sky and
everything looks like this it looks cold it looks dark it
looks like bleak everything and like watching snake walk
into the darkness after the fight is like one of the it's
like one of the coldest things i've ever seen ever it's so
awesome but but this they make it so much brighter but this
looks like how it does in the original What game is that?
The original Metal Gear Solid.
The original, the original.
Um...
Does anyone have to say anything before we continue?
The entrance to the underground maintenance base is
somewhere towards the back of the snowfield north of Tower
B.
Okay.
Thank you.
Otacon, I'm alive, by the way.
Otacon, which direction is the underground base?
It's in the snowfield to the north of Tower B.
Oh, so awesome.
The door is security level 6.
It's so awesome.
Like, I don't know.
It just, like, creates the atmosphere so well.
Especially when Otakon is, like, yelling out to him.
And he's like, what are you fighting for?
It's, oh, it just hits different.
Nostasha, what do you have to say about that?
As long as the strategy of nuclear deterrence continues,
nuclear weapons may be reduced, but they will never be
eliminated.
If you think about it, nuclear reduction does not mean much
without elimination as the ultimate goal.
I used to work in the DIA.
I figured the only way to achieve nuclear elimination was to
work from the inside to convince them of the ineffectiveness
of the deterrence theory.
Victims of nuclear radiation are a sad thing to see.
And I have seen a lot of it.
I have seen more than enough of it.
I was born and raised in Pripyat, Ukraine.
I was ten years old on that day April 26 1986 you don't mean
yes Chernobyl that is the day that changed my life and
thousands of other lives I live just three kilometers north
of there oh my god 600,000 to 700,000 people were evacuated
over 650,000 children suffered the effects of radiation
poisoning What about you?
Between 1986 and 1993, 12,000 children died.
Are these real stats?
My parents, and many others like them who helped in the
cleanup, died a few years later from radiation sickness.
We must rid this world of all nuclear weapons.
It's mostly gone.
It's not as heavy, but it's still there a little bit.
Before they destroy the delicate environment that keeps us
alive, I will not allow allowed this pain and anxiety to
pass on to yet another generation.
I like Nastasha, she's so cool.
Might have been even more.
I'm so sad.
You called Snake?
Yes, okay.
All right, let's go fight another boss.
Snake, in China they say, when walking through a melon
patch, oh, you can't say melon.
Don't adjust your sandals.
That means that when things get really bad, you have to try
to remember what's important.
Keep things in the proper perspective, okay?
I don't think I've ever heard her say that one.
Okay, Gonzalo.
Time for you to leave, Mei Ling.
I can't believe you said that.
To me.
I did save, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I saved.
I saved.
Time for another ridiculous action cutscene.
See, it just doesn't look as good.
It just doesn't look as bleak.
I don't want to be able to see the sky.
I want it to be pure darkness.
Oh my god, that was so loud.
Oh, that was so loud.
Ow, ow!
Jump!
Oh no, Otacon.
Snake, are you okay?
Otacon, were there any other stealth prototypes?
Oh, oh!
There were only five.
Nostasha not returning was one of the big losses.
What are you talking about?
Someone's shooting at me.
It's her!
Wolf.
Sniper Wolf?
Yes, it's her.
It's definitely her.
Otacon, you sound like you're happy.
No, I'm not.
So then what is it?
Snake, please don't kill her.
His glasses.
Please, she's a good person.
You'd know that if you talked to her.
That woman isn't as sweet as you think.
I can see you perfectly for me.
She's so hot.
I told you, I'd never quit the hunt.
Now you're mine.
Otacon, you're...
Wolf!
No, you can't!
Don't get between a wolf and its prey.
You're pretty good if you can hit me in this storm.
You see, women naturally make better soldiers.
Wolf, don't do this.
Emotional damage.
Snake, I'm near.
Can't you sense me near you?
It's a mistake for a sniper to reveal her location.
You think so?
The tension here is so awesome.
What I message from me is a message from Beth.
If I'm close, you will know death is close.
Please, Wolf, Snake!
No!
Quiet!
Don't get in our way.
That's a different sniper.
Now I'll pay you back for Meryl.
You men are so weak.
You can never finish what you start.
I'm weak.
Now I don't necessarily want to cheese this.
I think I will...
I probably will use the sniper if I can find her.
first.
It's like so bright.
Oh, there she I wonder where she is.
Oh my gosh, it's funny.
She also kind of runs like Sasquatch.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
Uh, let's run this way.
Actually, where?
Wait, where is she?
Oh wait.
Yeah, I saw her.
Oh, my Medicine!
Where?
Oh, there, there, there.
Okay.
No!
How did I miss?
She going over here?
No!
She doubled back!
You sneaky!
Where'd she go?
Where's she hiding?
There she is!
Got her?
Back, oh, it's so sensitive, it's so sensitive.
Wait, I don't know where she went.
Uh oh.
Oh, oh, no, there she is.
Oh, oh, I lost her.
Oh no.
Oh no, hello.
Where is she running to?
Oh no.
You can't get me.
Okay, uh.
Run, run, run.
I don't know where she went.
She could...
Before I saw, like, the red of her...
Oh, there, there.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Ah!
She just stayed behind the tree, right?
Oh, shoot.
I'll shoot.
There we go.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Oh, no!
You...
Sniper Wolf.
I'll get you while you're running.
As soon as you come out.
My alert sounds are adorable.
What do you mean?
By the...
Oh, dang.
Come on, Sniper Wolf.
That way.
That was this way.
Come on, Sniper Wolf.
Oh my gosh, my aim.
My aim!
Oh, even with the Pazazamine...
I'm useless.
It's so, so sensitive!
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Even with the Pazamine, like one millimeter off.
So crazy.
Oh.
Got her.
Come on, Wolf!
This is too easy.
This is actually too easy.
That's not me!
That's the Pazazamine!
Your invincibility frames, huh?
Sniper Wolf, your invincibility frames.
Come on out, pretty lady.
easy come on man that's too easy it's so easy actually i
don't remember struggling much with her original fight
either though that
was a lot of blood and this is why this this this exactly is
why i did not grab the tranquilizer that's why this is why i
went back to the armory only for this scene otherwise this
scene would be useless I mean pointless.
She's so awesome.
Snake, stop standing!
Wait, what are you... stop standing in places?
Like, actually!
Oh my god.
Oh, he...
yeah!
Oh!
No scope.
360, no scope.
He flipped.
He did a flip.
Oh, because my headshots did nothing, you know.
Somersault 360 with scope.
I don't remember that.
Welcome to the Twin Snakes.
See if there's anything around here.
I think I can also loot after the scene, though.
Oh, Otacon.
Otacon, don't look.
Otacon will remember that.
No, don't look.
Don't look, Otacon.
But this scene without the best is yet to come in the
background is not...
I've waited for this moment.
But it still makes me so sad.
I am a sniper.
Waiting is my job.
Never moving a muscle.
Concentrating.
Oh my god.
I am lungshot.
You cannot save me.
Please.
Just finish me quick.
I am a curd.
I have always dreamed of a piece.
place like this occurred so that's why you're called wolf I
was born on the battlefield raised on the battlefield
gunfire sirens and screams they were my lullabies hunted
like dogs day after day driven from our ragged shelters That
was my life.
Each morning I'd wake up and find a few more of my family or
friends dead beside me.
I'd stare at the morning sun and pray to make it through the
day.
The governments of the world turned a blind eye to our
misery.
But then, he appeared.
My hero.
Saladin.
He took me away from all that.
Big boss.
You mean big boss?
I became a sniper.
Hidden.
Watching everything through a rifle scope.
Now I could see war not from the inside, but from the
outside as an observer.
I watched the brutality, the stupidity of mankind through
the scope of my rifle.
Nine.
Little Pops.
I joined this group of revolutionaries to take my revenge on
the world.
Oh, even this small guy.
I have shamed myself and my people.
I am no longer the wolf I have.
was born to be in the name of vengeance i sold my body and
my soul now i am nothing more than a dog
wolves are noble animals they're not like dogs so so gentle
the word for wolf is kaglinak and the aliots revere them as
honorable cousins they call mercenaries like us dogs of war
we're all for sale for some price or another it's when
Otakon comes in that makes me really cry solitary you're no
dog you're a wolf no oh oh who are you are you Saladin wolf
wolf you spared Merrill's life even when I'm just an
onlooker I don't like to see or children get hurt rest easy
you'll die as the proud wolf you are you wolf i finally
understand i wasn't waiting to kill people i was waiting for
someone to kill me so fortunate like you you're a hero
please set me three oh no oh no oh no little dummy why why
i loved you
what is it this part's so sad too give it to me she's not
even reaching out to otakon She's just...
She just wants her guide.
She doesn't care about you, Otakon.
She is part of me.
Ah!
It sounded like the willow scream.
Oh my gosh.
These dogs look so goofy.
The tiny dog looks so happy.
Like a kid.
Oh gosh.
Everyone.
is here now okay hero set me free good bye no
snake you said that love could bloom on a battlefield I
mean I didn't but I couldn't save her I didn't say between
you two just said in general.
Oh, the handkerchief.
Returning it to its owner.
I don't need a handkerchief.
Why?
I don't have any more tears to shed.
He cries more.
I'm going to the underground base.
We're out of time.
I know you'll have to protect yourself now don't trust
anyone you too yeah if I can't stop Metal Gear this whole
place will be bombed to hell yeah we might not meet again
don't lose the codec I'll be behind you all the way
I hope I don't lose the codec.
It's in my ear.
A head start on your new life.
This book.
Snake!
What was she fighting for?
What am I fighting for?
What are you fighting for?
If we make it through this, I'll tell you.
Okay
Okay, I'll be searching too
Okay I love it
Okay I love that light so much.
Oh my gosh Oh.
Oh.
Oh, a sniper wolf.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, Otacon.
Wait a second.
Oh, wait a second.
I recognize this place.
Oh, don't stand up, Snake.
Snake.
Snake, don't stand up.
Oh, uh...
Oh, I'm all full.
This death trap.
The VTuber room.
It actually is, though.
I think everyone who plays this...
who's never played it before.
Get her dog tag.
How do I get that?
Oh.
Oh, hello.
What am I fighting for?
Even with the music cinematic change from the PS1, this
scene still hits all...
the emotions it does yeah actually wait i'm stuck i'm stuck
on top of her loot her
oh he's here though i can't loot her i can't pick her up
wait is it b how do i pick them up again no no a oh here we
go oh my god this is so messed up oh my god this is so
messed up oh my god sniper wolf uh i'm gonna put her back
where she below where she Here, let's just...
Okay, hold on.
Just, uh...
Let me match it up.
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, hold on.
Just a little bit more.
Uh...
Okay, hold on, hold on.
I gotta match it up so it doesn't, you know...
Okay, okay, hold on.
I gotta just, uh...
Look for the Hein-D wreckage in first person.
Oh, you can see that.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm gonna get it.
I'm gonna get it, puppy.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
And, uh, wait.
Like that.
Oh, what's that sound?
I think I, I think I, I think I, I think I glitched the
game.
You could still hear the sounds of me pulling her, I think.
Unless this is a different sound.
Thank you!
Just because you're a ghost.
You can't just disrespect the dead like that mint.
Is there no afterlife decency?
No one treated my body with decency.
Actually, I don't know.
It was so long ago.
I don't know what happened to my body.
I don't see the...
Oh, let me try the scope.
Hindee!
I can't see anything now.
Where would it be?
Where would it be at?
It's so windy.
Towards the south.
This isn't where I go.
Hmm.
just in case okay
oh it's more chaffs which I didn't use any which is crazy
more towards the south like down here down here
down this way the paranoia can you blame me let's try going
up um Is that gold medicine?
Oh, it's a bandage.
Nothing here.
To the right side.
Wait, like, is this right?
Which right?
Who's right?
Right side beyond the fence.
Snake is right.
Huh?
Look at this.
Are they gonna see me?
From the mini-map bottom right.
Okay, okay, give me a second.
I'll grab them.
Or I'll go look in a second.
There's the other one.
There we go.
More bandage.
Full on right.
This game is so generous.
Holy cow.
Okay, so this way.
La la la la la la la.
Here?
I can't see you over the dang fence.
Maybe up here?
Oh, wait.
That was down there.
Over here?
Hmm.
I saw it.
Oh!
Huh?
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
There it was!
Colonel, listen to me.
I found a parachute near the wreckage of the Hind.
A parachute?
You don't think the liquid survived?
No way.
He'd be mad to try to escape by parachute.
As soon as he jumped out of the pilot seat, he'd be cut to
ribbons by the rotor blades.
So what's that parachute doing there then?
I have no idea.
He's dog food now.
Either that or a message.
To me.
meaning I'm not dead I suppose no maybe but I think it's
more like I'll string you up no we took care of that guy we
took care of that guy he's not coming back we took care of
Licklin I've never seen that before though that's so
interesting oh stop snake you're embarrassing me there's
this is okay this is the way that we we there's also here i
know this is all just gathering supplies and a lot of it we
wow i was gonna say a lot of it we already have but wow
okay yeah we're like so full and we got box number three
to the snowfield oh my gosh little snowflake on it's so cute
medicine doco I don't think we're sick anymore are we I
guess we're fine now we have a good the nanomachines worked
oh my god the nanomachines mutated oh oops the nanomachines
have mutated into oh my gosh they cure all sorts of diseases
Naomi you wouldn't believe it I think I think it's
incredible how how advanced they've become in such a short
amount of time!
Is that it?
Right there?
Yeah.
Disc 2!
It's rumored that Kojima ended Solid Snake's story at MGS4
because he wanted to focus more on Big Boss's story in later
games.
What's your opinion on this?
I mean...
I think Snake told his whole story, though.
To be honest.
Oh.
The blast furnace!
Oh my gosh, how could I forget about this part?
Oh, uh, uh, uh.
Oh, that was, uh...
Who's there?
No one?
No one.
Hold on.
You don't have a...
Okay.
It's so loud in here.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
Nothing?
Was that sound?
What are you doing?
What are you doing coming all the way over here?
Hold on.
I think I can...
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
They don't do reports in here, I guess.
It's too noisy and stuff.
Huh?
Alright.
I should probably save.
I should probably say, even though I feel like, you know, if
we die, we just start back at the door, but it's fine.
I'll save just in case, you know.
IWSFJ, welcome to membership, thank you!
Who are you, like, with your status report?
Guys, actually, I think also, maybe it doesn't come so
quickly if there's no, like, most of the time I feel like I
take out these guys.
It's in front of a camera.
If you have confidence that what you're doing is part of
your true nature, there should be no hesitation.
I don't know whether your orders are in your true nature or
not, but Snake, believe in yourself.
I'll try for you, Mealing.
The cutscene was kind of awesome, though.
Very Terminator, right?
Are these guys awake again?
Of course he is.
Maybe I can take this other guy out from up here anyway.
If I can see him.
Actually, I don't know if I can see him.
Where is he?
Oh!
Is there another guy?
Am I just here?
Or I'm just...
I'm hearing something.
I think maybe I'm just hearing that thing.
Stung gun.
Grenade.
Hmm.
Oh my god, no!
Oh no, I, I, I, I, oh my god, no!
No!
I, I, I, I...
Oh.
Gosh, darn it.
Get his head.
Oh, dang, I was close.
I want to take out his radio.
Just in case.
I don't think it does anything, but, you know, just in case.
Uh, uh.
I don't want to shoot you in the butt, buddy.
Yeah, there we go.
Uh.
Uh, uh...
Okay, here we go.
And here we...
Don't go.
What a way to go.
Shot in the butt by a V-Tuber.
Pathetic.
Absolutely pathetic.
I could take him out.
Might actually be easier.
Hmm...
Um, hello?
Where is this guy?
Did he sneak past me?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Come on.
I gave you a little bit more.
There we go.
Okay, controller.
Was this...
You know what?
Maybe this part would be easier with the D-pad.
I'm not so sure, though.
Actually, no.
I don't think it will be.
Okay, here we go.
Slow and steady.
My hand is getting sweaty!
Stinger the crane get revenge in.
Okay, I'm gonna wipe my hands.
Okay.
Oopsie.
There we go.
I don't think I got his butt.
Oh man, I didn't get his butt.
Oh, it's fine then.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, it's coming back.
Oh, I have to be just a little rat.
No Terminator thumbs up.
Zero out of ten bad game.
Oh, to be just a little rat who can crawl right under.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
The fake out was real.
Okay.
Wait, let's get him so sweaty.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I remember!
Oh!
Keep going.
Please, please, please.
Okay.
There we go.
There's some...
some things though.
Yay, you did it.
Yay, I did it.
Where'd that...
Where'd that camera go?
Oh, there's one.
Well, we just need to go through there.
So I think we're good.
Actually, I can't see anything.
It's so hard to tell where I'm going.
It's so easy!
No way!
Oh.
What's going on?
What is that?
Oh!
Oh wait, I have her dog tags.
That's so cool.
I didn't know they'd be in my inventory.
Oh, here we go.
Hmm.
Seems a little suspicious to me.
Oh, dang.
Oh, what's this?
Gotta check everything.
Yes, very good, very good.
Okay, here we go.
Ready for Raven?
Yes.
Yes, oh yeah.
Oh wait, we have to fight some more people in here.
here don't we?
Oh no.
I think this is my favorite updated cutscene.
Really?
Wow!
Why did it explode in the middle?
Why did it do that?
Oh, whoa!
Oh my gosh.
Look up.
He's He's doing the pose.
Oh, not anymore.
Why did the hat explode?
Oh wait, I'm fixing my contact.
Okay.
Oh, he's right behind me!
Are they all just running around?
Ow, jump!
Oh.
Ow, jump, jump, jump.
Yeah, I have the body armor.
I'm reloading.
Okay.
No problems here.
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you.
I didn't see who raided, but thank you so much.
Oh,
you hurt Snake.
Hang in there.
I know you can do it.
I'm hanging in there too.
For you, Snake.
You keep hanging in there, Meryl.
You're doing amazing.
Oh my god.
Hey!
Um, delayed much?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, yeah, I got it.
This also has mines in here, though, doesn't it?
Am I just being...
I'm not being paranoid, am I?
I could have sworn there's some mines somewhere around here.
Whoa!
Oh, this...
Now this is the elevator.
to to to
raven you guys um did i tell you guys that i'm playing
through obs so it might be a little delayed sometimes but
actually so far i think it's been pretty good the plot
elevator yes this is my one of my this is like my favorite
part of the game oh my gosh i'm so excited have you ever
tried acid one and two i know i know what kind of games they
are but i have not played them
come here bird come here bird actually i'm not gonna use oh
just kidding snake i've got something to tell you about
naomi hunter what's that yeah what is it is this
conversation secure mm-hmm worry the monitor's off yeah okay
yeah what's up what is it i was in
Don't be rude.
Dr. Hunter's story about her background.
About her grandfather being an assistant secretary to Hoover
in the FBI.
Uh-huh.
And then going undercover to investigate the mafia.
Yeah.
What about it?
Mm-hmm.
It was all a big lie.
What did you say?
It was really bothering me.
Why would she lie about it?
Hmm?
She lied?
She might be a spy.
Ridiculous.
I believed?
She lied?
Even a high school student could see past it.
Didn't Naomi say that her father was Japanese?
Mm-hmm.
At the time when Edgar Hoover was head of the FBI, there
wasn't a single Asian investigator.
Also, in the 50s, the undercover mafia sting operations
hadn't even started.
Oh my God.
They first started in 1960 in Chicago, not New York.
You better check it out.
The chief and the president mysteriously died.
That ninja.
Two men.
Her last name being Hunter?
Are you saying that Naomi might be behind it?
And Cyborg Ninja being Frank Yeager?
Masaka.
I'll call.
In the meantime, be careful.
Thanks, Master Miller.
You're the only one who has my back.
Gosh, Master Miller, you're so cool.
You're really the only one that has my back.
He's asleep.
Wait, what if I get one?
one in the sky.
Burn!
I'm sorry!
Oh, it's getting cold.
I'm chilly, I'm chilly, I'm chilly.
I'm chilly, I'm
chilly.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's save.
Oh, let's call people too.
Okay.
Colonel, where's Naomi?
Me out.
Um, Naomi, I have some questions for you.
Nothing.
Forget it.
Actually, not you.
That's strange.
Just kidding.
Snake, by now those terrorists have finished their launch
operations.
Stop wasting time.
I'm not wasting time.
Metal Gear's base is up ahead.
Snake, it's over 30 below outside.
Yeah.
What's wrong?
I don't want to talk to you.
Forget it.
Thanks.
Snap, pap.
Stop lollygagging around and get to Metal Gear's Sorry.
Sorry.
Sorry, Colonel.
Oh my gosh.
Master Miller, I'm so worried about her.
I want to ask you about Naomi.
Yeah.
I'm looking into the details now, but it doesn't look good.
I like how her mouth went.
Even though nothing came out.
Snake, keep your guard up.
You're the only one I could trust, Master Miller.
You're the only one I could trust.
Oh my gosh.
Very subtle, Snake.
What the hell are all these crows doing around you?
crows you got me there were crows around from before but for
some reason they started to increase in number about the
same time that Foxhound came to the base mmm it's really
weird I wonder what it could mean I don't know I wonder if
we do not drastically reduce the number of stockpiled
nuclear weapons it's going to become easier and easier for
terrorists to get their hands on them Sorry, it's just
really funny that everyone's like talking about Naomi and
she's like, the soul, we need to get rid of some of this
stuff.
Reducing their nuclear stockpiles to a core deterrent force
of less than 500 missiles each.
And declaring that there would be no nuclear counter-strike
in the event of the use of conventional or chemical weapons.
But talks fell through.
It seems that America is unwilling to relinquish its
position as the most powerful country in the world.
The pride.
Pride.
in the how's Naomi huh she's fine I guess what's up if you
want to talk to Naomi why don't you call her yeah I guess so
strange guy strange guy shy guy shy boy strange boy boys are
weird USA USA USA Good luck, Snake.
About to go fight another person.
Oh, wow.
It's a good thing we walked through there.
We would have been crushed.
Like a little ant.
Okay.
What's that?
Oh my god, they're eating here.
Then they're gonna eat me.
Oh my god.
Welcome, Cossack.
What'd you call me?
This is the end of the road for you, right my friends?
Kaka, kaka, yeah!
Me too.
Ravens aren't scavengers like most people think.
They're simply returning to the natural world that which is
no longer needed sometimes they even attack wounded foxes
well i'm a snake you were the one in the m1 tank must have
been a tight fit for a big boy like you i love but that is
no true battle
isn't he freezing no he's a big boy I love that line so
much.
What?
The judgment is decided.
The Ravens say you are a true warrior.
Snake, you're hallucinating.
Yes, you are.
Snake?
I can't move.
What?
The raven has put the mark of death upon you.
Blood from the east flows within your veins.
Ah, your ancestors too were raised on the barren plains of
Mongolia.
Psycho-Mintus.
Inuit and Japanese are cousins to each other.
We share many ancestors, you and I.
There's no crows in Mongolia.
My family tree.
You ready?
Yep.
I am not fond of snakes, but you are family, so I cannot
complain.
But there will be no holding back.
Snakes a Japanese princess.
Wow!
It reminds me of Nonomi from Blue Archive.
I need Vulcan Raven Nonomi art together.
You live in Alaska too.
You know of the world Eskimo Indian Olympics.
Olympics?
With that strength, you must have been training in the stick
pull and four-man carry.
Yes, you are right.
But there is another event that I excelled.
But actually, Snake's mom is Japanese.
It is called the ear pull.
Wow.
It's an event where two opponents pull each other's ears
while enduring the harsh cold.
This is the worst thing ever.
It tests spiritual as well as physical strength.
You want to pull each other's ears?
The form is different, but the spirit is the same.
Rejoice, Snake.
Ours will be a glorious battle.
The thought of Katori for Nonomi because of her hair.
Oh, I see it.
It's just plain killing.
I never thought of it.
Violence isn't a sport.
Well, we will see if there is iron in your words.
Oh, yeah.
I take supplements every day.
Oh, what is going on?
Oh, he's got that iron grip.
Oh.
What?
Oh, my God.
Stop.
Stop, he did not just blow it up with...
No.
Oh, my God.
He just threw a whole container at him.
And Snake stopped it.
Once again, by blowing it up with missiles.
Oh, no, sorry.
The first time was a grenade.
Oh, my God.
Blast radius doesn't exist.
Not for solid snake.
Oh, my God.
That thing is huge.
Snake, how did...
How...
Oh, but if I do it...
If I do it, I get blown up, you know?
Like, if there's cutscenes, buff then it's fine hey get out
of here crow you're gonna get shot at oh oh he's yelling at
him oh oh oh he's yelling at snake draw what is going on
okay i
missed okay so there is a way to like kind of cheese this
where you can just shoot him in the back of the head
constantly oh well i missed Oh, hold on.
I un-equipped my gun, so I'm stupid.
Oh, I missed him.
Let's see.
You know what?
Maybe I won't.
Maybe I'll just do it with the Nikita.
Maybe I will just Nikita.
Where is he, though?
Oh, I think he is.
Phew!
Oh my god.
Ow.
Ouch!
Oh, no, no, no.
Ah!
You jerk.
You have a big gun.
Actually, I don't know where he is.
Actually...
Oh, he's over there.
Somewhere.
There he is.
Did that work?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, he's coming.
I just used the stinger.
I guess that's fair.
But I think you blow it up, right?
Like, there is a way to just, like, Literally shoot him like
this.
Oh, he's running?
He's so fast?
He's so furious?
Oh, he's really fast.
Hey buddy.
What are you- you're wasting your bullets?
Oops.
Pull his ear.
Pull his ear!
Let's try the- we can try the Stinger.
Oh.
He's- he's breathing heavy.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's...
Oh my god, it's...
It's like focusing in on all the crows too.
No way.
That's so funny.
Uh...
Let's just stand right here and, um,
where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Uh-oh, he's gonna see me.
Ah!
I'm gonna use this.
Now I'm gonna switch the body over here.
Oh my god.
Why are you heavy breathing so much Stop, you're scaring me!
I heard that this fight was so much easier.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It was so much easier in this one.
And I mean, all the fights pretty much are.
But...
I want to try and do the cheese.
Wait, oh, maybe I can do it here.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Hold on!
Oh my god, please.
As long as I don't die.
Oh my god.
Maybe I have to get him in the head.
Stop shooting me!
I take a couple hits.
You take a couple hits.
It works out this way.
I take a couple hits.
You take a couple hits.
I'm just a little tankier than him, you guys.
Body armor for the win.
For real.
the boss said it is my existence which is no longer needed
oh our body armor is on but my it's not very sexy will not
remain in this place the fit the blood looks fake my spirit
and my flesh will become one with the ravens maybe because
like in the other with the other people they were wearing
clothes mother earth who bore me but with this he's not it's
just his skin so it doesn't like snake i will be watching
you understand oh
should have worn a shirt
snake take this security card it will open that door oh it's
so funny take the hard to advance in the game why you are a
snake which was not created by nature you and the boss you
are from another world a world that i do not wish to know go
and do battle with him i will be watching from above first
i'll I'll give you a hint.
The man you saw die before your eyes.
Yeah, oh yeah, the diaper chief.
That was not the DARPA chief.
What?
Who was it?
It was Decoy Octopus.
No!
Oh no!
We never got to fight!
Decoy Octopus!
No way.
He was a master of disguise.
Wait, did we get to see him?
He copied his subjects down to the blood.
Stop!
So he drained the chief's blood and took it into himself.
We actually get to see Decoy Octopus?
But he wasn't able to deceive the angel of death.
Thought he was about to take off his pants.
that's awesome we actually get to see him ah that's me i'm
the angel of death but why go to so much trouble why
impersonate the chief
that is the end of my hint you must solve the rest of the
riddle yourself yeah what questions were is he asking me he
was asking He's asking a lot of questions to me, you know,
when I, uh, when I met him.
Voldemort.
How would the fight be with decoys since he only knows how
to disguise himself?
He could disguise himself as the wall.
It's like hide and seek, you know, you have to go find him.
Hebio.
They're eating him!
Oh, God.
Oh, it's really nasty.
Oh, gross.
In the natural world, there is no such thing as boundless
slaughter.
There is always an end to it, but you are different.
He looks a fool.
What are you trying to say?
The path you walk on has no end.
No matter how far you go, or how many corpses, you crawl
over the killing will never end it's a future without hope I
hate how me snake oh laughing octopus my spirit will be
watching you Wow it was it was like a balloon there's
nothing to him it's really a sad how kind of true That ends
up being...
Poor Snake.
Snake has had a hard life.
No bones.
Yeah, Raven wasn't wrong, unfortunately.
Snake, it's me.
The music?
It's about Naomi.
Turn your monitor off.
What about Naomi?
Wait!
Colonel!
Is Naomi there?
No, she's away.
She's taking a short time.
Oh, I wish I could take a short nap on the job.
So what is this about Naomi?
Okay, maybe we'd better let the Colonel hear this too.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, go on, Master.
Well, basically, Dr. Naomi Hunter is not Dr. Naomi Hunter at
all.
What?
I thought her story of her background sounded kind of fishy.
Yeah, so I checked it out.
I believe you.
And?
There is an actual Dr. Naomi Hunter.
Or I should say, there was one.
Skinwalker.
She took her body.
And we know the real Naomi hunter disappeared somewhere in
the middle she buried her in the sand Naomi must have
somehow obtained her identification papers.
Oh my gosh.
So then who is she really?
She must be some kind of spy a spy a spy a spy?
Maybe she's been sent to sabotage this operation.
Are you saying she's with the terrorists?
Oh my god.
I don't want to believe it either But she is working for
Foxhound.
So you think she had a part in the uprising?
She could be working with some different group all together.
How do you know I have a sad group?
it couldn't be Place her under arrest Colonel.
Yeah, she's betrayed us Colonel.
Yeah, she needs to be arrested and interrogated to find out
who she's with Yeah, she's one of their spies and we're in
big trouble.
She what have you what have you told her Colonel?
Oh, nothing Have you let her in on some kind of vital secret
or something?
Uh-oh.
Oh Does this have anything to do with the mysterious deaths
of the DARPA chief and the arms tech president?
I have no idea.
Oh, Colonel, that is the least convincing answer I've ever
heard in my life.
Any further in this mission.
Wait, wait a minute.
Without her, we can't complete this mission.
Had been really ties her out for together perfectly.
Thank you!
Give me some time.
Have a good rest of your night.
Alan, thank you.
Island, sorry.
Thank you.
doing here.
I understand.
Snake, give me some time.
I don't have any time left for you.
Oh, yeah, you tell him, Snake!
You tell him!
Oh my gosh.
Master Miller.
What's that sound?
Be ready?
I got his dog tags!
Vulcan Raven!
Wait, oh, could I have gotten Psycho Mantises two I wonder
oh no that's a shame I didn't get it because I didn't know
it's so chilly in here oh let's
put the body armor back on I
don't see anything else maybe I think maybe we're okay have
you ever listened to all the snake codec calls from smash
bros if not it would be a very fun watch I have seen a good
amount of them I don't remember if I watched like a
compilation of all of them or if I finished that compilation
if I watched one, but I have seen some, yes.
Miller's the only honest guy in this game.
Truly.
I remember you.
I, I remember you.
Check, check your rations.
I do need that, don't I?
Wait a second.
Is that a person and not?
Wait, is there a person here?
I think I saw it turn around.
This room never...
I think there's an actual person in here.
Oh my god, there is.
Oh my god.
You scared me.
There never was a person in here.
Oh, cool.
Oh, oh my god, uh, uh, oh shoot, oh my god, uh, uh, oh
shoot, oh my god, uh, uh, where are you going?
It's him, give me some backup, Robin, no!
Oh my god, oh shoot, um, I thought the cameras were the only
issue here, and suddenly they're adding people,
Oh my god.
I'm also trying to shoot.
Uh, oh, uh, hi.
Uh, ouch.
Oh my god, please.
Snake.
There we go.
Anyway.
You trapped his car.
Oh, that's why he ran into there.
Zum.
Wait.
Where's your...
the zoom zoom my
god what a little baby baby rex oh my gosh you guys part of
my metal gear like order that i did the other day i got a um
a paper craft rex
zoom there's no zoom there's
no zoom
There's no ZUM?
I want to cry right now.
What is that?
Oh, I was like, what is that?
I think I know who that is actually.
I was like, what is that?
That's so funny.
I can see the camera from here though.
ZUM.
I'll just do it myself then.
Lame ass.
Soundtrack.
Worst part of the... Worst part of the game is the
soundtrack, truly.
Wait, is there someone actually down here?
Oh, no, he's above me.
Zom...
Thank you for the zom...
Zom beanies.
Zom...
Oh, hello?
It's obligatory Metal Gear.
I had no idea you like Metal Gear.
I love Metal Gear!
Oh, thanks to the stealth gear.
I got stuff to do.
I'll get you on the reruns.
Love ya.
Thanks, A.V.
Good luck with your stuff.
I overheard them talking.
The music in this version seems very subdued.
Yeah, it is very absent.
Yeah.
There's nobody here.
No guards.
No mechanics.
It's too quiet.
There's some guards.
They said they even input the PAL codes.
What should I do?
Oh my god, no.
All we can do is use the override system that President
Baker told you about.
override.
I've only got one of the three keys and besides that like
Ocelot said there's some trick to using the keys.
Leave it to me.
There's also actually an easier way here too which is kind
of nice.
I'm in the computer room right now I'm trying to access
Baker's private files.
Okay.
Baker's files.
Don't you need a password?
Of course.
But there are ways.
Are you a hacker?
Yep that describes me pretty well are you a hacker i don't
know yet i'll give it a try i'm hacking to the gate
where are the guards you said there's guards literally right
above me i
think wait what up where is it huh
Actually, where is the guard?
I heard someone walking, though.
Are they one above?
Oh, uh-oh.
Is there somebody there?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
Oh, gosh.
I didn't see your stupid ass.
Oh, my God.
Snake, it's me again.
No guards at all.
Yeah, it's so weird.
There was no guards.
guards in this part before i just got past his third
security level he was a pretty careful guy do you think
you'll break in soon i've never met a system i couldn't bust
i couldn't even see where he was coming from man man this oh
uh uh we're both loading at the same time but i'm faster oh
my god no no he's not you
know your stupid shield where's my shield Oh my god.
Okay, now I can run and hide.
Where's my box?
Snow box.
I saw people running up, but they're gonna see me, aren't
they?
Aren't they gonna see me?
They're gonna see me, aren't they?
They're gonna see me!
Do you think I can walk?
Okay.
that in I could have just I should have just stayed here
okay we'll just wait until the caution's over can
I see them in there I don't see them they're just like
probably being like what's going on down there nothing much
don't worry about it why would you need to worry about it
you know middle of a hallway I didn't know where this left
led to yeah oh my god oh my god oh wait hold on oh oh wait
wait wait oh
my god what I tried to be sighted remember what no I shot
your everything I shot your thing this
is so unfair.
It's so unfair.
This is so unfair.
I shot the radio!
I...
No sign of the AWOL man.
No, no, please.
No, God, no!
I shot.
I shot your radio.
Wait, where's my...
body armor.
Oh, there it is.
I always pass it like a bajillion times.
I can't believe I got scammed, for real.
Oh, thanks.
How am I supposed to get out of this, though?
How am I supposed?
They're just gonna all keep coming.
They're all just gonna keep running up here and over here.
Hmm.
Doshio.
Gotta
run out of rations.
I feel like I should just Oh, oh.
Just gonna have to blast on my way, oh, oh.
Blast my way through them, I think.
Snake, I didn't.
You got past security.
My grip is not good enough, I think, for hanging over the
railing.
I think my grip is too small.
So what about the PAL override system that Baker talked
about?
Haven't found it yet.
That's okay.
That's what I need to know.
But Snake, I found something else.
What?
The secret behind the new nuclear weapon.
Huh, what's that?
Just as I thought.
The nuclear warhead is designed to be fired from the railgun
like a projectile.
It doesn't use fuel, so it isn't considered a missile.
That way it can get around all sorts of international
treaties.
Oh my god.
Pretty sneaky.
Sneaky.
But effective.
And that's not even the scariest thing about this weapon.
I can't wait to hear this.
It's a stealth weapon.
Oh, so scary.
It won't show up on radar.
Yeah.
The truth is, they've been working on a stealth missile
since the late 70s.
Why weren't they able to develop one up until now?
Because of the missile's rocket propulsion system.
It would be picked up by enemy satellites.
Because of that?
But unlike a missile, the railgun doesn't burn any
propellant, so it can't be detected by any current ballistic
missile detection system.
Insanity.
An invisible nuclear warhead.
So scary.
Totally impossible to intercept.
Oh my god.
of that it's got a surface piercing warhead designed to
penetrate hardened underground bases we learned how made the
thing yeah did you not think could mean the end of the world
it's the ultimate weapon and from a political point of view
didn't you make this the problem of nuclear reduction and
nuclear inspections Colonel is this true are you listening
I'm listening it would push back the signing of the start 3
treaty if word gets out about this weapon it cause a whole
world of trouble oh yeah yeah it would be nasty the united
states would be denounced by the un it could even bring the
president down oh my god did you know this colonel not the
president i'm sorry you've changed colonel god i'm so
disappointed i'm disappointed in your colonel listen to me
this new nuclear weapon it's never actually been tested only
simulated you mean with vr experiments yeah that's why they
were conducting this Man, they love VR.
They needed to get actual experimental data to back up the
simulation.
VR is the future.
What were the results of the exercise?
It looks like it went better than they hoped for.
But I can't find the data anywhere on this network.
You'd think the data as important as that would be carefully
recorded.
How built the mech?
Didn't build the railgun?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
What?
Do you still have it?
No.
Ocelot took it from me.
Damn.
The terrorists have replaced the dummy warhead with a real
warhead.
Oh my god.
Once they input the detonation codes, they should be ready
to launch.
So, you think they can do it?
Well, the dummy warhead was designed to be identical to the
real thing, so I think so.
Did you find out how to override it yet?
Not yet.
It must be in a separate file.
Right now, I'm looking through all of Baker's personal
files.
We're counting on you.
We're counting.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, shoot.
For real.
Oh, hello?
Oh, it's empty!
Oh, no.
Anyway.
Snake.
Yeah.
That was fast.
I haven't found out about the override system yet, but I
found Baker's ulterior motive.
He's just looking to get rich, isn't he?
That's part of it.
Arms tech is in much worse financial trouble than I thought.
I know they lost their bid to make the next generation.
fighter jet that plus the reduction in SDI spending it looks
like there was even some talk of a hostile takeover oh
everything was riding on this project I guess and it looks
like they were paying a lot of bribe money to the DARPA
chief that guy yeah it's the worst was a big proponent of
the nuclear deterrent chief is the worst so anyway what
about the override just give me a little bit longer
Are there people?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Ah, time to go!
Cutscene!
Cutscene time!
Oh, oh, oh!
Yes!
Go, Snake.
I've entered the PAL codes and disengaged the safety device.
We can launch anytime.
There's still no response from Washington.
It looks like we'll have to show them that we mean business.
Yeah.
Oh.
Dummy.
Should I set it for Cherniton Russia?
No.
There's been a change.
The new target is Lopnor China.
Why, boss?
Oh, he's so beautiful.
Liquid.
I'm sure neither you nor Mr. Golukovic would really like to
see a nuclear bomb dropped on your motherland, right?
But why?
There's nothing there.
Wrong.
It's a nuclear test site.
A nuclear test site.
If we nuke a major population center, the game's over.
But a nuclear explosion at a test site can still be
concealed from the public.
Meanwhile, Washington will be worried about the retaliatory
strike from China.
That'll probably mean top-secret talks between both.
countries leaders top secret of course and in the process
the president will be forced to divulge the existence of a
new and highly destabilizing nuclear weapon to the Chinese
what do you think that will do to the US's reputation or the
president oh my god and with the CTBT that means that China
in India I think you missed a letter there wait I saw what
this Yes, when the other countries hear about the new
weapon, they'll all want to contact us.
Washington won't be very happy when we start selling their
own system to the highest bidders.
Yes, the president will break.
He will give in to our demands.
Big Boss's DNA and one billion dollars.
One billion dollars.
All for money?
No.
will be used to cure our genome soldiers as well does it
care about the money i'm also including the fox die vaccine
in our demands fox die it killed octopus in the arms tech
president so it's true that it affects older people first
mantis might not have been affected because he wore a mask
wolf wasn't infected either perhaps due to those
tranquilizers she always took
Adrenaline levels in the blood they deployed a product still
in development into live combat no surprise it was
unreliable Ridiculous they must have been desperate
Desperate in any case have you heard from your friend
Colonel Sergei Golukovic at Spetsnaz yet He still has doubts
about the ability of Metal Gear by the way this person's
full name and where they're at You know, I gotta give you
some context.
There's nothing to worry about.
The Colonel wants Metal Gear and the new nuclear weapon so
bad he can taste it.
Oh, the Pazazabine saved me from Foxdie?
Oh, maybe.
Russia wants to regain its position as a military
superpower.
They need to reinforce their nuclear arsenal.
They need a nuclear weapon that can't be intercepted.
Metal Gear will allow them to gain first strike capability
over the rest of the world.
Oh, my God.
is in shambles in shambles restore their country's military
power with nuclear weapons that galukovic he's no warrior
he's he's a politician maybe so he's the one who gave us the
hind and most of our other heavy firepower he's got over a
thousand soldiers under his command what just happened if we
joined forces did i just accidentally zoom in quite a
resistance here sorry I almost dropped my controller since
Mantis died the genome soldiers brainwashing has started to
wear off you zoom in I'm worried about the men's morale an
alliance with the Russians would boost that as well hmm what
are you saying oh my god we are not going anywhere we're
going to dig in here what it's going to be a long war we
could still escape we We have the new nuclear power, and
we're going to ally with Belukovic's forces.
Are you going to fight the whole world?
What's wrong with that?
Fighting the whole world?
But I can't move around.
From here, we can launch a nuclear warhead at any target on
this planet.
A nuclear warhead invisible to radar and totally immune to
interception.
I can't move it, though.
And on top of that, this base is full of spare nuclear
warheads.
The other one.
Once we get the DNA and the money, the world will be ours.
But boss, what about your promise to Colonel Kulukovic?
I have no interest in the revival of Mother Russia.
You're not thinking of reviving Big Boss's dream.
Oh, oh, oh.
From today, you can call this place...
Don't say it.
No!
Ow!
Big boss's dream.
Outer?
Heavy?
Boss, you're not worried about the pal being overridden?
If the code is entered again, it will be deactivated.
Oh, that was the most convincing delivery ever.
The DARPA chief and the arms tech president are both dead.
Does Snake know how the override system works?
Boss, he doesn't know how to over- oh my god, his neck?
He didn't have any keys on him.
Good.
Then no one can stop him.
Oh my god.
Boss, he doesn't know how to put in the detonate or the...
What should we do with that woman?
Want me to kill her?
Want me to kill her.
Let her live.
She's Campbell's niece and Snake cares for her.
We'll keep her as our ace in the hole.
Merrill, she's alive.
Merrill.
emoji snake I found Baker's top secret files great job how's
it going there they finished inputting the PAL codes oh my
god so how do we deactivate them okay you see the override
system how to deactivate can also be used to input the
detonation codes you see if you insert the keys when a
warhead is active you deactivate it and if you insert them
when it's inactive it becomes activated and you can only use
the keys once only once huh you need the keys for input
three of them but i only have the one where are the others
hold on a minute you see that's the trick you already have
all three keys what are you talking about the card key is
made of a shape memory alloy oh shape memory alloy it's a
material that changes shape at different temperatures the
key is made out of it this card key yeah the card key
changes shape at different temperatures oh this key is
actually three keys in one clever so clever so so clever can
you see the input terminals in the center of the control
room I do they're very obviously laid out yes I don't think
I need a okay those three laptop terminals are for the
emergency if you're gonna wait out your binoculars at least
zoom in okay thank you there should be a symbol on each
screen mm-hmm each symbol corresponds to a different key you
input the keys in order from left to right the left ones for
the room temperature key see the symbol yes next to that
goes the low temperature key the one on the right is the
high temperature okay okay I got it I got first I changed
the shape of the card, and then I input them in order,
right?
That's right.
All you do is insert the card keys.
After you insert the key into the module, a hard disk reads
the information contained on it.
They're not even talking.
Once you've finished with all three terminals, the code
input process is complete.
But here's the thing.
You can only use the key three times.
It's an emergency system, and it's only meant to be used
once.
In awkward gatherings, I employ solid snake I just say what
they said but ask it in a question.
Who's that?
Oh my god!
Snake!
Oh, oh, oh, he's looking at the bullet.
Oh no, I forgot about this part.
Oh, our card key!
Oh, so clumsy.
The key fell in the drainage ditch.
The key here fell in the drainage ditch.
Ouch!
This is bulletproof glass.
There's no way in.
I'll enjoy watching you die.
This is bulletproof glass.
Snick, you've got to get that key.
Snick!
This is bulletproof glass.
Okay, I'll go get that.
Look at it.
So, the people I'm seeing walking is them, right?
Like...
Oh.
Wait.
Yeah, it's them inside.
That's so funny.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go get us...
Let's go get us a card key.
Could use some more bullets.
Especially since I ran out.
Where are my famus?
25?
Oh.
Oh my god.
No way.
Where were you?
Where?
Where were you the whole time?
Where were you?
Wait, actually?
Let's see.
Maybe we can...
Oh, but if I...
Oh.
I don't know.
If I put him down.
If I make him sleepy.
Or a...
your status report.
It's fine.
Maybe it's fine.
Excuse me.
Are there any other guys?
They're not showing up if there are.
Wait, can I go down here?
What's down here?
There's a lot of...
Wait.
I don't...
This is not used to be here, right?
Right?
This is new, right?
I feel like I hear someone else walking around.
I don't think it's me.
But I don't see anyone else on the radar, so I was just...
This is completely different.
Sorry, I'm going to shoot your butt.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, I came this way.
Okay.
Now at least I know where they're at.
Before, I think what the trouble was, was I was like seeing
them on the radar, but there's so many tiny little stairs
areas in here that I'm like, I didn't know where they were
walking at, you know.
But now we at least know where... Wait, how do I... How do I
get down?
I'm lost.
Wait, I'm lost.
Wait, oh, uh, here, here, here.
Let's grab this.
Nope, just kidding.
Okay.
I'm hearing something.
What the heck am I hearing?
Look at them, they're in there talking with each other.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
If I put on the body armor, does it help?
La la!
How do I find this thing?
We got more bullets?
Wait, got it!
A time bomb!
Wait a second.
Where is that?
Where's the time bomb?
Oh.
Wow.
Uh, uh, please, Snake.
Hmm.
Maybe it's down here.
Oh, Ration?
Nice.
Take it.
Rex's bath water.
If you drink this, you will literally get super power.
I hope these guys aren't awake.
Okay.
Palky!
There we go.
Very nice.
Gotta go all the way back.
You will become the world's most powerful soldier if you
drink this water.
Any VTuber fan would be honored.
Hopefully these guys are still...
Just take you there.
Yeah.
Give you a little extra.
And this guy too.
Yeah.
Oh, you only got two.
There you go.
Now you got three.
Okay.
back here, right?
Yeah, right?
Then I go inside.
Oh, they're gone.
Where could they have gone?
Very good.
Hmm.
Nice.
Do I just, uh...
Okay, so this one, first our little pal key insert call
otakai now that you found the key okay oh yeah i should be
calling people snake re-input the pal codes colonel i'm
scared what if it doesn't work what if you're what if you're
tricking me you've got the card key back good job now hurry
to the control room yes of course master he's the only one i
can trust so it's fine You found the card key, right?
First comes the room temperature key.
Put it into the far left terminal in the control room.
That key is actually an IC card.
Its connector pins and main body are made of a shape memory
alloy.
Ooh.
It's designed so that unless it's been changed to the
correct shape, it won't be recognized by the PAL code input
terminal in the control room, and the detonation code won't
be entered.
So...
I could just...
What if I...
What if I mess it up a little?
What if I just...
Oh, wait.
It's not activated.
Oh, I mean, sorry.
We're deactivating it.
But I think I mentioned this earlier.
But there's actually an easier way to do some of these.
Like, uh...
I think...
I think it's...
Well, you like have to shoot a pipe.
And it will allow you to do the hot and the cold.
Not having to go all the way back.
So...
We'll see.
Beep beep.
Yeah, there's a Lend with a hot and a cold pipe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I don't know.
I might do the quick way because I think it's kind of cool
that it's unique to this game.
Alright.
Rex, you're not getting activated today.
Oh, gas attacked.
Pal code number one confirmed.
Nice.
That takes care of pal code number one.
Now, pal number two.
Freeze the key.
Oh, wait.
Do I get gas attacked when I complete them?
Oh.
Oh, I forget.
Oh, he's still down.
Let's go.
Now I...
Okay.
The issue is, I don't actually know where these pipes are.
I think...
Look at him.
Slumbering baby.
I think they're over on...
this side.
I missed the zoom.
Me too.
This music is kind of creepy.
But it just...
It's not the vibe, you know?
I don't know exactly where these are.
floor right side hang drop catch down like here wait hang
drop from where oh gosh i have to catch going down we might
have a problem wait hold on can i see it where i need to
drop i love that i just walk all over their bodies let's see
is there one that oh
or just take the stairs i'm looking to see like this there
it is okay okay so right okay so you can't access it that's
what i was just checking so you have to hang from here okay
okay wait so to drop down catch i don't know the controls i
don't know the controls actually Okay, hold on.
Uh, shoot.
It's action.
And,
uh, drop.
Nope.
Uh, wait, I don't know what to act.
I don't know the controls.
I did it!
First try, baby!
First try!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Nitrogen.
Ow!
Ouch!
Did that actually hurt me?
Nice.
Oh!
It's already cold!
That was so fast.
Alrighty.
Um...
Uh...
Where is this gonna drop me?
Oh, whoops.
Uh...
And drop...
Oh.
My bad.
We're fine.
Come on, Snake.
Shake it off.
it's actually okay that's so cool oh my gosh how nice i'm
just gonna keep shooting these guys every time i go past
them no use in having them wake up i mean honestly i could
just kill them then they then they'd never be a bother then
they would never wake up
yeah is that just for twin snakes yes it is just for twin
snakes so you will not find that because you can't hang in
in regular Metal Gear Solid number two
you've killed so many why I hold back on these two that's
true they did give me a really hard time they did I am still
annoyed at the fact that they I'm still annoyed at the fact
that they gave me a hard time because i didn't know where
they were yeah pal code number two confirmed y'all waiting
pal code number three mint this saves me like 15 minutes i
know there goes pal code number two it's kind of awesome
next comes pal number three warm the key which is so funny
because like i was so maybe maybe i feel like i'm more okay
with doing this because i was so adamant about the um about
the sniper about the psg that like it and it took so long
for me to get it that i'm like you know what we can save a
couple we can save some minutes because i um i messed i'm i
was so bad at the beginning but it's also funny because i'm
trying to like i'm not trying to remain like faithful to the
original it's just that i feel like the cut scenes work
better when you don't use like a tranquilizer like everybody
everybody in this game dies it's not it's not a happy ending
okay shoot what was it okay you nice hey yo hey yo hey yo
ouch oh uh palkey and it's hot baby oh it's on fire it's
it's hot they die in MGS three, two, a big die from
explosion.
So it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what I do.
Reach, thank you.
Hatty has her own route and occupants drive.
I have!
Also, the Metal Gear saw...
Oh, hold on.
I'll read it, Reach, in a second.
Okay, so what's up?
I've got a good friend in the Pentagon.
Yeah.
He's the one who told me about it.
It looks like the DIA recently developed a new type of
assassination weapon an assassination weapon snake have you
ever heard of something called Fox die no that's what they
mentioned earlier Fox die Fox yeah liquid in the others were
talking about it yeah they the others it's some kind of one
other the target specific people also I don't know all the
details but what are you trying to say yeah what are you
trying it's too similar what is the cause of death didn't
the arms tech president the DARPA chief I mean decoy octopus
die of something that looked like a heart attack yeah well
apparently Fox die kills its victims by simulating a heart
attack no no you're telling me that Naomi was behind it
snake try to remember did Naomi give you some kind of
injection the nanomachines the nanomachines she was in the
best position to have done it but I don't know what her
motive was oh my god does the Colonel know I'm not sure but
he still hasn't questioned Janai Fox died Janai Colonel
what's new with the Naomi situation I just placed Naomi on
the air take her butt to jail she was sending coded messages
toward the Alaskan base I didn't want to believe it but she
must be working with the terrorists oh my god I'm afraid so
oh my god she's being interrogated now she's working with
them interrogation well I'd like to avoid the rough stuff
but we don't even have any sodium pentathol here that's the
true stuff right find out anything so it's true isn't it
Naomi Fox alive I can't believe it that means the Fox die
vaccine must be around somewhere is that all you think about
but snake you might be infected too you know all I can do is
leave it up to the Colonel I mean I mean I mean I don't know
I mean I think it's pretty important to think about that's
the last one hurry to the control room I'm on my way I'm on
my way master master I'm doing it so Naomi is a spy just
like I thought Campbell is hiding something too yes but
that's okay Fox die is a virus a biological weapon there
must be a vaccine we can worry about getting that later
snake but right now you've got to focus on re-inputting
Yeah, there's gotta be a...
There's gotta be a vaccine.
You're up soon.
Important to note, this was originally an elevator scene for
backtracking, but because of skipping in Twin Snakes, they
put it here.
Oh, yeah!
Yes, yes!
I love going in the elevator and getting all the exposition
and everything.
So fun.
Hey, auto-climb.
Naomi's an enemy spy?
I can't believe it.
You don't even know her, Otakon.
I believe her, but...
Snake, leave it to Colonel Kami.
You don't know her.
You've got to concentrate on re-inputting that detonation
code.
Yeah.
You're right.
We gotta stop Metal Gear Rex from launching, for sure.
What is it, Snake?
Good luck, Snake.
Thank you.
Sorry, I didn't mean to...
You know what?
We don't need to say it.
We're fine.
All right.
Let's go.
oh okay good I was like wait a second it's it's it's purple
but no it's red we're good let's go stop Metal Gear from
launching let's go oh hello snake can you hear me it's Naomi
how'd you get this number Naomi what the hell what the hell
on a different codec Naomi is what the colonel says true yes
but not everything I said was a lie who are you who are you
I don't know anything my parents face is my name the name
and idea I have now I just bought but the reason why I study
genetics that was true because you want to know yourself
right I want to know where I came from my age my race
anything Naomi Naomi I was found in Rhodesia sometime in the
80s, a dirty little orphan.
Rhodesia, what's now known as Zimbabwe?
But you were found by who?
You were found by who?
And there were lots of Indian laborers around.
That's probably where I got my skin color from.
But I'm not even sure about that.
Naomi, you're too worried about the past.
Yeah.
Isn't it enough to understand who you are now?
Understand who I am now.
Why should I?
no one else tries to understand me i was alone for so long
until i met my big brother and him him your big brother yes
frank yeager what he was a young soldier when he picked me
up near the yank what is this music i was half dead from
starvation yeager means a hunter oh my god oh my god
revelation frank my brother and my only family no no gray
fox gray fox survive that held together Frank and I he
protected me he is everything to me oh my god the only proof
I have of my existence of my existence as an individual and
he brought you back to America no I was in Mozambique when
he came he is he no save endurance MGS Maybe.
You brought us to this land of freedom, this America.
Big boss.
But then he and my brother went back to continue the war.
And that's when it happened.
When we killed him.
You killed my benefactor and sent my brother home a cripple.
I vowed revenge and joined Foxhound.
Oh my god.
I knew it was my best chance to meet you.
And I prayed for the day that I would.
so were your prayers answered yeah how do you feel now huh
yes i waited two long years to kill me is that all you cared
about i mean two years is long but it's like not that long
two years you were all i thought about for two long years
rent-free for real twisted obsession do you still hate me
did they read up naomi's lines they read up to everybody's
lines about you what about liquid in the others I'll have my
revenge on them too yeah Naomi you didn't kill that doctor
too did you the one that used gray fox for his genome
experiments yeah but they got rid of Naomi's accent that was
my brother afterward I covered it up now you're so obsessed
with me Naomi so that ninja I mean gray fox he's come here
to kill me I don't think so I think he just he loves you he
loves you snake I wasn't sure before but now I think I
understand a final battle with you that's all he lives for
soldiers are so weird they're all just like I need to have I
need to fight one more time tell me something about Fox die
Fox die is a type of retro virus that targets and kills only
specific people yeah first it infects the macrophages and
the What's that?
Fox die contains smart enzymes.
Created through protein engineering.
The program to respond to specific genetic patterns in
cells.
I don't, I mean I know that the...
Those enzymes recognized the target's DNA.
Original recordings were bad.
But I don't think they sucked.
They have soul.
It's a type of cytokine.
Do you know Jaeger means hunter?
A peptide which causes cells to die.
That's a spoiler.
The TNF epsilon is carried along the bloodstream to the the
heart where they attach one more fight will fix me i can fix
him and then they cause a heart attack yeah the heart cells
suffer a shock and undergo an extreme apoptosis apoptosis
then the victim dies scary apoptosis you mean the heart
cells commit suicide this naomi does this what you must have
programmed that thing to kill me too right you did
Naomi!
I don't blame you for wanting me dead.
Why can't you ever give us a clear answer, Naomi?
I'm not the one who made the decision to use Fox Die.
Huh?
You weren't.
No.
You were injected with Fox Die as a part of this operation.
I just wanted to let you know that...
No.
That's not the whole truth.
Huh?
why are you such a pathological liar snake hey what are you
doing no live snake you must live Naomi snake I can't allow
Naomi to make any more unauthorized transmissions what
Naomi's been removed from this operation what happened to
Naomi what did she mean when she said that Fox die was a
part of this operation Colonel let me talk to her I won't
Twist after twist after twist.
You double crossed me.
Snake, there's no time for that.
Right now.
Your job is to stop Metal Gear.
You'll die when you die.
Naomi.
That's her alright.
Oh my gosh.
What do you mean there's no time?
When I've been injected with like a poison essentially.
Oh my gosh.
The camera angle sometimes get me a little motion sick.
Naomi yapped a little too much.
Here we go.
Final pal-key.
Nice and steamy.
In it.
Insert, we go.
Yeah, there's no time to talk about my double crossing.
Yeah, he's just like, just get your job done before you die.
Which is also so sad.
Snake just being like, I have one friend.
It's the colonel.
It's like...
I think you're just a tool to everybody.
You know, if you rearrange Rat Patrol, what's that mean?
Oh, here we go.
Here it is.
What?
Oh my god!
No!
Why?
Welcome to Bembush and thank you I deactivated oh here it is
who's calling master please thank you snake now the
detonation code is completed master Miller nothing can stop
metal gear now no master what's going on master please you
found the key and even activated the warhead for us too I
really must express my gratitude sorry to have involved you
in that silly shape memory alloy business what are you
talking about we weren't able to learn the DARPA chief's
code even with Mantis psychic powers he couldn't read his
mind then Ocelot accidentally killed him during the
interrogation in other words we weren't able to launch the
nuclear device we were all getting a little worried without
the threat of a nuclear strike we're getting a little
worried would never be met why did I launch that nuke
without the like a fiddle we had to find some other way
that's when i decided you might prove oh my god we're just a
pawn in everyone's game well for starters i had decoy
octopus disguise himself as the darpa chief oh my god we
thought we'd get the info from you but there was fox die
yeah you mean you had this plan from the beginning just to
get me to input the detonation code you didn't think you
made it this far by yourself you're telling me he didn't
actually regrow that arm in any case the launch preparations
are complete once the world glimpses the power of this
weapon master I trusted you to surrender the Fox I trusted
you master there ace in the those day Miller Senpai the
Pentagon's plan was already successful in the torture room
you're the only one who master baited you I can't believe he
did that are you anyway I'll tell you everything you want to
know if you come to where I am that is there the little jump
scare of very close by very close by snake that's not master
Miller what Campbell you're too late master Miller's right
now he's been dead for at least three days master Miller
because my codec link with master was Oh my god.
But Mei Ling said his transmission signal was coming from
inside the base.
Why didn't you check the sooner?
So who is it?
Snake, you've been talking to...
Brother?
Me, dear brother.
Yeah!
Liquid.
How the...
You've served your purpose.
Crazy how everyone betrays snakes in these games.
Glad I never did.
Dramatic stare off.
No!
Oh my god, no!
Uh,
uh, call...
Um... Colonel!
Snake.
Gas.
Do something.
Snake.
Call Emmerich.
Gas.
Do something.
Snake.
Call.
Emmerich.
Snake.
Do something.
Snake, that's bulletproof glass.
You can't break it with an ordinary weapon.
Can't you open the security lock here?
I hope we get the little liquid jump scare as he runs by.
The...
Um...
Very close.
But that's why he didn't pick up when we were fighting the
Hindee!
Gas.
All you can do is wait for Dr. Emmerich to open the door.
Stay alive, Snake.
Fox alive.
If only a snake would throw up here.
Oh no, wait, never mind.
He would throw up in his mask.
That'd be awful, actually.
Um, Arkan?
Uh, Arkan?
Uh, Arkan.
Wait, Arkan.
Arkan, this is bad.
Arkan.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is actually bad.
This is bad!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god!
Come on, hurry up already.
Hang on.
Uh.
I know the gas map doesn't do anything anymore, but Otakon!
Um, Otakon, please!
Oh, thank God.
I hacked into security.
Thank you.
Took you long enough.
God.
I need to use a ration!
Okay, here we go.
I love this part.
Please, please, please, please.
Also, we're in for a really...
We're in for a treat of a cutscene coming up.
Okay, please, please.
Doom, doom, doom, doom, doom.
It sucked.
Snake, did you like my sunglasses?
Oh, you point a weapon at your own brother?
why did you disguise yourself as master so I could
manipulate you more easily you performed quite well I must
say I must say although the boys at the Pentagon are
probably saying the same thing what the hell are you talking
about following orders blindly with no questions asked
you've lost your warriors pride and become nothing more than
a pawn snake what stopping the We managed to avoid choking.
A diversion.
The Pentagon only needed you to come into contact with us.
That's what killed the Arms Tech President and Decoy
Octopus.
They wanted to kill them on purpose.
That's right.
You were sent here to kill us.
So they could retrieve Metal Gear undamaged along with
bodies of the Genome Soldiers.
From the beginning, the Pentagon was just using you.
as a vector to spread Fox Dye.
No!
Fox Dye.
It can't be.
Are you telling me Naomi was working with the Pentagon?
Oh no, no.
They thought she was.
But it seems that Dr. Naomi Hunter couldn't be controlled so
easily.
Oh, thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
We've got a spy working in the Pentagon.
Oh, I'm so sorry, Corey.
Fox Dye's program just before the operation.
But no one knows how or why.
I wonder maybe they arrested her so they could find out the
answer to that No doubt but I had no idea she was motivated
by such petty revenge We still don't know what changes she
made to Fox dies program Oh, well doesn't matter.
I've already added the Fox die vaccine to my list of White
House demands Guffle thinks are the five there's a vaccine
There must be right Yeah.
The only one who really knows.
Yeah.
It might prove to be unnecessary.
Unnecessary.
Oh, yes!
Here it is!
Yeah.
Why is that?
You were successful in coming into contact with all of us.
Right.
So we must have all been exposed to the virus.
You're just young.
It's true that the Arms Tech President and Decoy Octopus
were killed by Fox Die.
But Ocelot, myself, and you, the carrier, were apparently
unaffected.
Why?
Why is it so extra?
In any case, if it doesn't kill you, then I'm not worried
either.
After all, our genetic code is identical.
It's so awesome.
So it's true.
You and I are...
Clones.
Oh, he's breakdancing now?
Yes, twins.
Twins!
But we're not ordinary twins.
We're twins linked by cursed genes.
Les enfants terribles!
Hold on.
I got some twin snake gummies.
I'm gonna eat one.
I got all the flawed, recessive genes.
Everything was done so that you would be the greatest of his
children.
the only reason I exist is so they could create you so
you're saying I'm the dominant one right right I'm just the
leftovers of what they used to make you can you understand
what it's like to know that you're garbage since the day you
were born freaking out but I'm the one father chose so
that's why you're so obsessed with big boss some warped kind
of love huh love it's hate his choosing me knowingly two
sides of the same coin for this i want revenge you don't
even understand this you who could kill your own real father
you store my chance for revenge now i'll finish the work
that father
You had two tries, like when...
You're just like Naomi.
Well, I'm not like you.
Unlike you, I'm proud of the destiny that is encoded into my
very genes.
He's going full monkeys.
Oh, oh!
You missed your last chance!
You'll regret that forever!
Uh-oh.
Snake, come, kneel down to this historic weapon.
No!
Consider it an honor, a gift from your brother.
From your brother!
Now, you shall bear witness to the demon weapon that will
drag the world into the 21st century!
Oh, Rex!
Huge.
Oh my god.
Oh love.
The demonic weapon.
Wait!
Oh my gosh, I should have killed those guys.
They're gonna get crushed.
Are they still die in their sleep?
The music's kind of awesome though.
Kick it's Batman!
I'm gonna kick it!
but some kind of metal gear revenge in so it's moving but
how do i stop it it's huge oh my god it's so big after
zanzibar take one action wipe
his ass i'll wipe his butt
oh he's so Oh my god.
Now roar.
Oh my god, it's so cool to see.
Oh!
Punch it!
Ow!
Roll some nectar!
He's so cute.
Huh?
Alright.
Anyway...
God help us.
Metal Gear is moving.
No!
You help me!
It's all riding on you now.
You'll have to ask Dr. Emmerich, the guy who made it.
Gotta take out the... First the Radom, right?
Snake, Rex's armor is impregnable.
You can't do any damage with the weapons you've got.
Rex uses the latest advances in combat.
Can you speak up Otacon?
I can't hear you over the music.
Huh?
The music.
Rex's pilot seat operates exactly like a VR system.
We got the chorus back, finally.
He's got multiple sensors connected to a high-tech interface
used for the controls.
It's completely self-enclosed and shut off from the outside
environment.
He's not using his naked eyes.
Naked eyes.
So if you could somehow destroy the sensors.
Do you see that round plate on Rex's left arm?
Yes.
Yeah.
The Ray Dome.
If you can destroy that thing, it won't be able to use its
electronic equipment.
It's so funny, because when I was putting together...
Try to hit that Ray Dome with a Stinger missile.
Okay.
So will that stop it?
No.
Um...
Oh, great.
The part that looks like a beak is where the pilot seat is.
In an emergency, it will open up.
But I could...
I knew how to put it together because I was like, oh, the
Ray Dome is on its left shoulder.
story yeah i get it first i destroy the raid open that will
force him to open up the pilot seat right if you can shoot a
missile into the cockpit you'll destroy the computer control
system you intentionally designed it with a weak point it's
not a weak point more like a weakness a weakness people and
weapons just aren't very appealing without a weakness of
some kind so true oticon i guess so i owe you one oticon i
mean you can't make something entirely like perfect right
something perfect.
I need bet takers on how many tries it'll take her to beat
the Zans of our shuffle.
Stop!
Okay, let's see.
Oh my god.
The music is so awesome, but it is also so loud.
Alright, Stinger Missile.
Oh, uh, turn around and look at him.
Oh, wait.
Also, I think here I can use the chaff grenade.
hits yeah you don't know where i am now dummy so lock on to
that and boom and
boom shaft away and
uh stinger i
didn't have my rations on i didn't have
everything was so right except except oh my god okay it's
fine
oh oh oh my god uh oh
i need to throw the chaff as soon as i can oh my goodness
crunch got crunched for real oh i don't think that hit
Even like...
Oh!
Chah!
That's not coming for me, right?
Yeah, you don't know where I am.
You can't see me, dummy!
After Zanzibar, take two!
Hey, hey, hey!
It is my fault that I forgot the, uh...
It is my fault I forgot the...
The rations, yeah.
This is my fault.
I should have noticed.
Here he comes.
Damn!
Oh, he's so cute!
Nice try, Snake!
Oh!
Snake, stop standing there!
oh my god great fox oh oh hurry get away this is so riding
her name from long ago it sounds better than deep throat so
it is you you look terrible snake you haven't aged well this
is kind of a clone and i age fast
Deep Throat was...
Was Gray Fox?
He was... He was Deep Throat the whole time!
Gray Fox was deep throating me!
Sorry, calling me as Deep Throat!
Nice.
Fox, why?
What do you want from me?
I'm a prisoner of death.
ninja Fox stay out of this what about Naomi she's hell-bent
on taking revenge for you my chat just broke Naomi you are
the only one who can stop her no I can't why because I'm the
one who killed her parents oh I was young then and couldn't
bring myself to kill her too I think you Dude, it's broken.
Uh-oh.
I felt so bad that I decided to take her with me.
I raised her like she was my own blood.
Sorry, I'll have no chat for a minute.
To soothe my guilty conscience.
To read.
Even now, she thinks of me as her brother.
Oh, what?
Outwardly, we may have seemed like contented brother and
sister.
But you.
But every time I looked into her eyes, I trembled with fear.
We're back.
Tell her for me.
Tell her that I was the one who did it.
There you are!
No!
Oh!
We're just about out of time.
Here's a final present from Deep Throat.
I'll stop it from moving.
What kind of present is it?
Oh my god, so awesome.
Oh yeah, you dodge those missiles.
Yeah!
Okay, this isn't gonna stop it from shooting.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh my god, Fox!
He doesn't look so good.
Oh no, he doesn't look so good.
oh my god oh my god in the middle east we don't hunt foxes
we hunt jackals oh it looks so brutal i mean it is brutal
but oh my god royal harriers fox how strong is that
exoskeleton of yours snake are you just going to sit by and
watch him die
He's so awesome.
Yeah!
He had that the whole time and just never used it.
It's our turn.
Oh god.
Wait a second.
Wait.
He destroyed the Raido.
Impressive!
You are indeed worthy of the code name Fox, but now you're
finished!
Now, fire the Stinger!
Fox!
Can you really shoot?
You'll kill him too!
I can't do it.
No, I can't do it.
Now, in front of you, I can finally die!
After Zanzibar...
Zanzibar Land?!
I was taken from the battle.
Neither truly alive, nor truly dead.
It's no good.
I can't do it.
After Zanzibar Land.
They changed it.
They changed to Zanzibar Land.
Oh no.
Oh I don't think I can watch this.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Fox!
Oh my god.
Snake!
We're not tools of the government or anyone else.
Fighting was the only thing.
The only thing I was good at.
But at least, I always fought for what I believed in.
Snake!
farewell
oh god oh
god oh my god death is entreated he just like oh my god he
just the battle is decided good lord
you see you can't protect anyone not even yourself we change
the teleprompter just chuck it at him maybe you'll get lucky
nice why why are you running at him okay everybody uh wait i
cannot i cannot see where you are i do want to see if I can
find some more um oh my god oh wait did I get hit oh I think
I got okay good there's a ration right here I do want to
find some that was sneaky it unequipped my it unequipped my
my rations it unequipped them that's oh wait uh
oh can I sting or him from here.
Here.
There.
Run,
stick!
What are you doing?
Oh my gosh.
Where?
There, there, there, there.
Why are you just yelling?
Ah!
That should be me.
Oh, wait, right there.
Right, right there, please.
Oh my god.
Did that hit?
I don't know, actually.
Ah!
I don't think it did.
I don't think it hit.
That's okay, though.
It's kind of...
Next one!
Can I get him again?
Sweet.
Oh, shoot.
Run, Snake, run!
I'll crush you into dust!
To end, dusted.
It is truly that this game is easier.
It is just truly that this game is easier than...
Oh.
It is, it's just the fact that this game is easier, but...
Yeah, it's less janky.
I knew it, that was nothing for you.
It really looks easy.
It's so much easier.
It's so...
Oh, there he is.
It's so much easier.
late as usual a snake what do you mean as usual do you know
me you're still alive I will die has nine lives as long as
okay now I think this is the real fight it looks like your
revolution was a failure this is the more difficult part you
destroyed metal gear doesn't mean he keeps people waiting
what are you really after heard of big chongus the
restoration of the era when warriors Yeah, Merrill is dead
in this one.
It was his dying wish.
When he was young during the Cold War, the world needed men
like us.
We were valued then.
We were desired.
You don't have to just be a weapon though, man.
You can just live your life.
But things are different.
Get a hobby.
With all the lies and hypocrites running the world, war
isn't what it used to be.
We're losing our place in a world that no longer needs us.
A world that now...
Yeah, I wanted to get the ending with Otakon, so...
You should know that as well as I do.
There's one specific part that is so funny.
After I launch this weapon and get our billion dollars,
we'll be able to bring chaos and honor back to this world
gone soft.
Conflict shall breed conflict.
New hatreds will arise, and our own biosphere shall steadily
expand.
The super baby man.
But as long as there are people, there will always be war.
But the problem is balance.
Father knew what type of a balance was best.
Is that the only reason?
Isn't that reason enough for warriors such as us?
I don't want that kind of world.
Ha!
You lie.
Is it because I...
So why are you here then?
Is it because I enjoy all the killing?
Why do you continue to follow your...
orders while your superiors betray you why did you come here
well I'll tell you then no oh here I love this part you
enjoy all the killing that's why what are you denying it
haven't you already killed most of my comrades the mocap
actor is so great the hand flare i watched your face as you
delivered the coup de grace no you didn't oh it reflected
such vitality yes you're wrong why did you strip me why did
you strip me liquid you don't have to deny it why did you
take off my shirt to be that way created
children that's what the project was called they're on fun
telly in the 1970s their plan was to artificially create the
most powerful soldier possible the person that they chose as
the model was a man no then is the greatest living soldier
in the world so weird big boss but father was wounded in
combat and already in the coma when they brought him in
what's they created us from his cells with the combination
of 20th century analog cloning and the super baby method
super baby method they fertilized an egg with one of
father's cells and then let it divide into eight clone
babies I ate the other babies the clones to someone's uterus
and later intentionally aborted strong fetal growth I don't
that's you and I were originally octoplets octoplets we
could have had more the other six of our brothers was
sacrificed to make us we could have had gassy snake oh gassy
a snake oh my god so it was you and I two fertilized eggs
with exactly the same DNA but they weren't finished yet.
They used me as a guinea pig to create a phenotype in which
all of the dominant genes were expressed to create you.
You.
I got all the recessive genes.
You're too obsessed with your genes.
You took everything from me before I was even born.
You're too obsessed with the genes.
But you and I aren't his only children.
Oh no.
What?
The genome soldiers.
They too carrying on his genetic legacy but unlike us they
carry it digitally with the completion of the human genome
project in the last century the mysteries of humanity were
made bad thanks to father's DNA they were able to identify
more than 60 soldier genes responsible for everything from
strategic thinking to Those soldier genes were transplanted,
using gene therapy, into the members of the next
generation's special forces.
That's how they became the Genome Soldiers.
Play Metal Gear Acid 1 and 2.
I know a little bit about the story of Acid 1 and 2.
That's right.
The Genome Soldiers that you've been killing right and left
are our brothers with the same genes as ours.
The Genome Soldiers.
The Genome Soldiers?
They are misshapen creatures.
When he grins or shows teeth, he reminds me of Willem DeVoe.
They are our blood brothers.
And they were born of many an ultimate sacrifice.
Good thing Solid Snake doesn't smile.
Human experiments.
Ooh, I see, looking at me like that.
1991, the Gulf War.
The military secretly injected soldiers with the soldier
genes.
Real footage.
The Gulf War syndrome that hundreds of thousands of
returning soldiers complained about.
Real people!
There's a side effect of it.
Ha!
Flash!
Flash being!
Was caused by exposure to pesticides.
And radiation from depleted uranium rounds.
Ha!
Idiot.
That was just a cover story.
Issued by the Pentagon.
First they tried to say it was post-traumatic stress
disorder.
than chemical or biological weapons.
The poison gas detection units and the anti-Seren
injections.
They were all just to cover up the secret genetic
experiments.
They were just crazy.
They were just getting the genes.
The so-called Gulf War babies that have been reported by
Gulf War veterans are.
You are.
Yes.
They too are our brothers and sisters.
The battlefield.
Absolutely.
So the genome soldiers mean that the experiments were a
success success don't be a fool they're a complete failure
we're on the verge of extinction what have you ever heard of
the asymmetry theory nature tends to favor asymmetry those
species which have gone extinct all show signs of symmetry
isn't the genome soldiers suffer from the same problem real
signs of symmetry so do i oh as do you this is not real
that's right we are all on the verge of death at the genetic
level oh my god we don't know when or what type of disease
will occur that's why this is out there genetic information
you want big bosses dna so you can save your family say your
family what in nature you are the same family members don't
mate with each other and yet they help each other to survive
do you know why why because it increases the chances that
shared genes will be transmitted to future generations
altruism among blood relatives is a response to natural
selection that we will help our blood relatives is inscribed
in our very genes our genes you're telling me that your
genes are ordering me to save the genome soldiers thanks
rancid rancid your genes it's fate all living things are
born for the sole purpose of passing on their parents genes
oh my god that's whoa whoa what my genes tell me and then
i'm going to go beyond in order to break the curse of my
heritation it doesn't happen much cake a snake does to do
that first I will kill you you had every opportunity you
have had every look behind you oh Merl Merl wow Merl
she looks oh there's a bomb is she alive hmm yeah I'm not
sure she was alive a few hours ago poor girl kept calling
your name Merrill Merrill stupid woman falling in love with
a man who doesn't even have a name I have a name yeah we
have no past no future if we did our fate is nothing but
what is determined in the genes we inherited from our
father.
Let Meryl go.
As soon as we finished our business, we're almost out of
time.
You're talking about Fox Die.
It seems now that the Pentagon knows that Metal Gear is
destroyed.
They've arrived at a decision.
They won't even need a BDA.
If you want the details, why don't you ask your precious
Colonel Campbell?
Science fiction and historical fiction.
Which is always fun.
Uh oh.
Colonel, can you hear me?
Uh, Colonel, you have some spawning to do.
What is the Pentagon trying to do?
Colonel, answer me.
The Secretary of Defense has taken over active control of
this operation.
He's on his way there by AWACS.
What for?
To bomb the place.
Yeah, shut it, Eli.
Not only that.
B-2 bombers just lifted off from going to Air Force Base.
Uh oh.
They're carrying B-61-13 surface piercing tactical nuclear
bombs.
What?
Ooh.
Metal Gear is destroyed.
Tell the Secretary of Defense.
Uh-oh.
The Secretary of Defense heard that Naomi double-crossed us
and he's worried about Fox's die.
Now that there's no more danger of a nuclear strike from
Metal Gear, he's going to do whatever's necessary to cover
up the truth of what really happened here.
He's going to drop a nuclear bomb to vaporize all the
evidence, along with anyone who knows anything.
Ah!
I'll stop the nuclear strike.
I don't know anything, I promise.
I may be only a figurehead here but I'm still officially in
command of this mission for now order to delay the strike
it'll confuse the chain of command and for now colonel it'll
give you a chance to escape yeah colonel if you do that it's
okay snake the truth is Foxhound was already the subject of
an undercover investigation Merrill was transferred to this
base just before the terrorist attack as a way of
manipulating me those bastards Those bastards.
I'm sorry.
They forced me to cooperate in exchange for her life.
You better get out of there, Snake.
Are you sure?
It'll be bad for you.
Don't worry.
It's the least I can do for you after all the lies.
Colonel.
I'm ordering them to cancel the bombing run.
After that, there's no turning back.
Huh?
What are you doing?
Ah!
Uh-oh.
Snake!
Me Ling!
What happened to the Colonel?
I don't believe it!
What happened?
What's happening?
The colonel!
Sit, speak!
Roy Campbell has been relieved of duty.
I always forget about this guy.
This is the Secretary of Defense, Jim Eisen.
Jim Hausman, yes.
Put the colonel back on.
He's been placed under arrest.
Boo!
For leaking top secret information and for the crime of high
treason.
Boo, Jim, boo!
This isn't what you promised me, Jim!
This is not what you promised me!
You can't see, but I'm like pretending I'm whacking him with
my cane.
There won't be a speck of evidence left.
I'm sure the president would want the same thing The
president ordered this the president is a busy man.
I have complete authority here Second favorite character
after blisking Don't worry We've prepared a convincing cover
story We'll simply say that the terrorists exploded a
nuclear device Oh my god.
Damn it.
You'll be murdering everyone here.
The scientists.
The genome army.
Everyone.
Donald, the DARPA chief is already dead.
So you didn't mean to kill the DARPA chief after all.
He was my friend.
And you could care less about what happens to everybody
else, huh?
Well, if you give me the optic disc, the other guy, I might
consider saving them.
What are you talking about?
test data Donald was supposed to bring it had a accidentally
got killed by us a lot I see oh well that's okay Baker you
two are an embarrassment from the 1970s our country's dirty
little secret you can't be allowed to live you're just the
lingering ghosts of a system that is no more well do try to
get along in the time you have left before the bomb oh
there's no way out for us let's finish this before the
airstrike oh you stole everything from me got my naruto
gloves on i shall not even have my naruto headband and your
jeans and i will take them all sexy no jutsu
she'll make a beautiful sacrifice i'm already sexy do you
see this this will be the time limit for our final battle
when death comes for this girl this nuclear module shall
vanish from this world as well if you win you might still be
Are you gonna talk over the timer again?
Like before?
You could enjoy one brief moment of love.
Of love.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Whoa.
Here we go, everybody.
And if you cross this line, you'll fall.
At this height, it'll kill even you.
What about you then, huh?
Oh my god, not him fixing his hair.
Down.
Have at you, Snake.
Yeah!
Um.
Oh.
Oh, he doesn't talk during...
Oh, stop running away.
Oh, my god.
Shoot.
Stop!
God, you are so...
Annoying!
Oh my god.
Uh...
I still have the dog tags.
Um...
Stop running!
What's wrong, Snake?
Better hurry!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right.
You come here.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, shoot.
It's going to blow.
What's wrong, Snake?
Come here.
Better hurry.
Oh, my God.
I don't think I've got a...
make this i don't think i'm gonna make this at all what's
wrong snake stop riding yeah that's right that's right i'm
gonna crush your little hand oh they were right i got his
dog tags oh my
god he hits so much harder than me
oh my god oh my god oh oh don't come at me
Oh, this is not good.
Ah, this is not good.
What's wrong, Snake?
Um, wait.
Oh, the recessive dreams.
It's the recessive dreams.
Better hurry.
It's going to blow.
Ouch.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, shoot.
I'll go to dot.
We're so done.
This is so over.
It's so over.
Not him laughing at me.
It's going to blow.
Hey, you didn't get me either, so, uh, you know.
What's wrong, Snake?
Ah!
That's right.
Did I get his dog tags again still, or?
Gotta be, like, a little bit more.
A little bit more aggressive.
Oh, ah, shoot.
Yeah.
What's wrong, snike?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh!
A counter-kicked.
Oh!
I don't know if I still got his dog tags or not though.
The camera change is so confusing.
Is that all you've got?
Oh my god.
That was totally on purpose.
Eww!
Stop!
Don't be in such a...
Oh my god.
Oh, oh.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, stop!
Better hurry, it's going to blow!
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god, stop!
Out!
We're like running into each other.
Oh, nice.
Ow!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No,
no, you get off my butt.
Oh, shoot.
I don't know why I tried to...
It was like, oh, no, no, no.
Ah!
You're out of time.
Ah.
Dang.
That was so close.
Yeah, a little jerk.
Oopsie.
I hope I still get his...
I hope I still got his dog tag, though.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
I still ended up kicking him.
Oh, no!
Not the counter.
Oh, my God.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Stop being so slippery!
Oh my god, why was I doing so well last time?
This time I can't get a single hit in.
I'm just gonna redo it.
Oh wait, can he not get me?
Look at him go.
Holy shoot.
He stepped on me.
He's spam charging.
Yeah, it's not fair.
It's not fair.
Oh my gosh, that was so funny.
Okay, but you need to stop running all around, you know?
I gotta kind of like fake him, you know, like that.
There we go.
Kind of gotta fake him, and then...
Oh, fake.
Fake, fake out.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Sure.
Yeah, then.
Yeah.
I'm gonna step on your hands!
Oh, never mind.
Okay, I think I do have the dog tags then, because I didn't
show up.
Oh, shoot.
Fake.
Okay.
Get up here!
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, at least I got the kick in.
I think if you get him into this corner oh you can like kind
of cheese it a little bit but I'm not good enough with the
timing obviously oh nice shoo shoo shoo don't charge at me
nice
ouch can't get the kick in.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, I know he can get me with that move too.
He'll like get up and kick me.
Yeah.
Oh, dang it.
I knew he was gonna.
Oh my god.
You are so annoying.
You're so annoying.
Oh my god, I'm gonna...
I'm actually...
Please.
Someone!
So close!
Come on!
No, please.
Don't charge.
Don't charge, I mean?
Fuck.
Oh my god.
So close.
I'm sweating so bad.
Oh!
We trade a Jank X fight for an extra Jank.
No, this fight was also really...
I remember this fight was hard in the first one too.
Because it's so tight.
Oh, contacts.
I need to put in some eyedrops.
Ow!
Okay, we still have one last little bit.
One last little bit.
We're done, guys.
We got this.
Just like MGS4.
I know.
This is so MGS4!
Oh my god!
This part is so MGS4!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Yeah!
If you just came in, we're at the very end of Metal Gear
Solid, so if you don't want spoilers, Spoilers?
Well, Metal Gear Solid, the Twin Snakes, but if you don't
want spoilers, maybe head on out.
Murphy, thanks for the five-gifted!
Thank you.
Snark!
Merle.
Brayden Mack, thanks for the five-gifted.
Thank you.
Damn, she looks really buffier.
I mean, I know she is, but like...
That angle.
Merle.
Meryl Silverberg's ghost Oh that was guttural Oh my gosh God
well thank you for the five gifted Star Creator Thank you
for the five gifted
Meryl They turned this into a yakuza game No yakuza turned
Itself into a Metal Gear game
Packed up through the 10 gifted oh Merrill forgive me oh
Merrill J things are the part gifted thank you oh my gosh
you guys stop here I gave into my pain trying to watch the
scene I sold your life to save my own I'm a loser I'll I'm
not the hero you thought I was.
Tech, tech.
Oh my gosh, she looks really dead.
It's okay, Snake.
It was me.
I did it.
Not you.
Don't take the...
Oh, I don't like what I... I don't like seeing him like
putting this on himself when it was me.
Merrill.
I'm sorry.
Talk strength.
Thanks for the tech, I'm dead.
Forgive me.
Thank you.
Merrill can't forgive anyone anymore.
Okay, you don't gotta say it like that, Otacon.
Come on.
She's gone, Snake.
Because of me.
No, because of me.
I guess blaming yourself makes it easier, huh?
Focusing on that will keep you from thinking about her
death.
What the hell do you know?
Meryl's dead.
I lost.
So, are you gonna stay here and die?
Along with her?
Snake, people die.
But death is not defeat.
He grew up so fast.
That's what Hemingway said.
I lost Wolf too.
But that wasn't defeat.
She and I will be together forever.
People die when they are killed.
Together forever.
It's true that Wolf is dead.
But our love didn't die with her.
Life isn't just a game of win or lose Don't you think yeah,
you can start new love.
Let's live snake together There's a parking lot right next
door.
We can get to the surface from the way he like dropped down
so fast I released all the security locks It'll be okay We
can escape You have my word on it.
He's gonna Otakon is protecting him you've changed you have
through regretting the past you have to protect the ones
that you love you've changed she looks really bad I mean
she's dead so of course but like oh my god it started Otacon
falling over those guys seem like they only hurry when
they're destroying things he grew up let him destroy it but
they can't destroy the human spirit um you should like leave
okay let's go
Merrill I hope you're still watching me oh you'll see if I'm
the legendary man or not okay I the only reason I don't like
this I think is because it's so sad for snake
so sad for him I love Snake so much I love him come on
hustle so much Snake it's cold outside you'll freeze like
that give me my clothes
not because Merrill died I like Merrill too but watching
Snake's reaction to it makes me the most sad my sneaking
suit Evie!
You better hurry!
You just stepped on it.
Wait a second.
The abs are fake?
The abs are drawn onto the suit?
Looking good!
Missed out!
Yeah!
Now you look like yourself again.
Why are you standing there like that?
woman where's my sneaking suit oh my god it's falling apart
for real happy you're here please never stop streaming as
long as you're having fun of course fish spine thank you so
much oh thank you so much and that is he oh uh we got one
ration wait where's all my stuff I'll take the wheel.
Oh.
Why didn't you turn off the cameras?
When you turned off everything else.
Wait.
Uh.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
Uh, hold on.
Hold on.
Oh, I'm trying to get in.
I'm trying!
How do I use this?
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Can I lower it?
Wait, can you please?
How do I lower it?
Uh, wait, how do, wait, no, seriously, how do I lower it?
Why isn't it?
Uh, uh, uh, uh?
How do I lower it?
Omnicod!
I don't know!
First person!
Oh, okay.
Oh my gosh.
What a mess.
I'm just gonna shoot ahead.
It's unlimited ammo anyway.
Why did it do that?
I'm trying!
I got him.
Oh.
I'm in a real, like, adventure.
Oh, gosh.
I can't see anything.
Otakon.
Wait.
How do I...
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Why do you do that every time?
Otakon.
It's not very helpful.
Snake, I mean, Otakon, I've tried.
This thing is...
God, I have, like, no life left.
Otakon, I'm going to die.
Otakon, I'm going to bleed out.
One HP and a tree.
Oh god, I'm gonna bleed out!
Snake, it's not over yet!
It's not over yet!
Yeah!
I
won't let you, I won't let you take my one life left.
I won't let you take it!
Oh, dang it!
You took it!
Hey, I'm shooting this.
Oh my gosh.
How am I not hitting?
There we go.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, ouch.
Come on.
Yeah!
I'm shooting.
I am shooting your butt.
You cannot.
Yeah, that's right.
Put on a shirt.
Please.
if i die here that would be insane
the music is awesome
oh are you are you okay are you okay hodakon i need you to
drive the car hodakon hodakon i need you to drive the car
his glasses oh my god shoot snake shoot
oh my god He's gun dancing.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Oh!
So close.
Are you okay?
Are you okay, little baby?
Is this CQC?
How many Matrix scenes are there?
You have to understand.
I think the Matrix was like...
Can you move?
It was so popular.
around this time oh my god he's he's all bent backwards oh
it's no use pulls him out anyway there you go i'm surprised
he can stand don't get his toes this guy in his nine lives
snake Snake.
There's less tension here because in the original, they're
trapped under the car.
But here he's just standing in front of...
Do something, Snake!
You can stop him!
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh!
Oh, MBS!
Fox.
Fox?
Die!
Oh,
that was it.
Oh, never mind, it wasn't...
Oh, he's away!
He's...
Give it up.
Oh, oh, he's standing back up?
Excuse me?
um
are you am i otakon being like am i third wheeling
oh my god
you guys they're brothers stop oh my gosh if he's dead that
means no snake don't say it don't think about it snake don't
Don't say it, don't spray it.
Snake, don't...
What happened to the air raid?
No stealth bombers in sight.
The Colonel.
Chat is so down bad.
Colonel!
Are you okay?
Colonel, what happened?
The Secretary of Defense has been arrested.
Early retirement.
I was able to get into contact with the President.
Metal Gear.
The training exercise, all of it.
It was all the Secretary of Defense acting alone.
Of course it was.
What happened to the air raid and the nuclear strike?
The orders were rescinded.
The F-117s and the B-2 bombers have returned to the base.
Once again, I have complete authority over this operation.
I see.
Your Oshie's graduation is not to me.
I wonder about that.
The danger's over.
Thanks, Snake.
Colonel, about Meryl.
I already know.
Oh, I'm sorry, Colonel.
Here's where we learned.
My daughter.
What?
I didn't find out until recently.
I got a letter from her mother, my dead brother's wife.
You should have told her.
I was going to tell her after this operation was over.
No, you can't wait.
Colonel, I...
it's okay snake thanks anyway what snake i'm sorry i kept a
lot of things from you it's okay colonel bro i'm stuck i'm
not a colonel oh that's right i've got a present for you
there's a snowmobile close to you maling sought on the
satellite photos this time of year the glaciers are pretty
calm you should be able to ride right out of there
say never expected you to come home alive me neither i'd
better not show my face around there no danger of that you
two officially died after your jeep sank into the ocean oh
it's not too far from the truth there's also a helicopter
waiting for you at the fox islands okay roy are you going
don't worry i've got an insurance policy a hard copy of all
of mayling's data as long as I've got that you me and Mei
Ling will be oh yeah the battery on these nano machines will
run out soon they won't be able to follow us I guess we
won't meet again don't worry I'll pay you a visit sometime
gonna give that I'm gonna give the Fox die to you Roy just
tell me one thing what about Fox die you guys say it's save
scummy but no it's it's preserving the evidence Naomi said
she wants to talk to you face to face about that.
Duh.
How is she?
Don't worry.
Mealing's with her right now.
I'm switching over to Naomi.
Snake.
Oh, God.
Sorry.
I heard about my brother.
Ah.
Fox.
No.
Frank wanted to tell you something.
He told me to tell you to forget about him and to go on with
your own life.
Snake is such a good guy.
Frankie said that?
Yeah.
He's such a... He also said he'll always love you.
Snake is such a... God, that moment was so ruined by Naomi.
Your brother just saved you, me, and the whole world.
Snake is such a good guy.
He fought on sheer willpower until the very end.
No.
Maybe.
Maybe now he's finally found some peace.
Spread false information on the internet?
My brother was already dying.
Oh.
Ever since he fought with you and Zanzib, of our land he's
been like a ghost a ghost looking for a place to die
Naomi liquid died from fox died too what about me oh boy
when am I can't wait to get some real answers here okay yeah
to you what do you mean what do you mean Yeah, we have a
vibe.
It's up to you how you use the time left to you.
You gave me this virus.
Live snake.
That's all I can say.
Naomi, you gave me a virus!
How long do I have left to live?
Each person is born with their fate written into their own
genetic code, inscribed into their genes.
Naomi!
But that's not all there is to life.
I finally realized that.
I told you before.
I killed everybody around me.
in DNA.
Everybody around me is dead because of this virus!
Where I came from!
How long do I have?
I thought that if I analyzed my DNA, I could find out who I
was.
Nobody cares who you are!
And I thought that if I knew that...
Oh, God.
Then I'd know what path I should take in life.
I secretly wish Snake would Princess Carrie Otacon here.
It's not a secret.
I just wish it.
I didn't learn anything.
Yeah, you didn't learn anything.
Exactly.
soldiers.
You can input all the genetic information.
Okay, here it comes.
But that doesn't make them into the strongest soldiers.
Oh, Atacan, I love this part so much.
The most we can say about DNA is that its genetic
information houses a person's strengths or destiny.
And, oh, you mustn't allow yourself to be trained to fate.
To be ruled by your genes.
Humans can choose the type of life they want to live.
Well, you, you, it's... Oh, snake.
Oh, here he goes!
Oh, no!
programmed or not isn't important.
The important thing is that you choose life.
Just carry him.
And then...
Oh no, here he goes!
Don't you think, Snake?
I'm gonna choose life too.
Until today, I've always looked for a reason to live.
I'm going to just live.
She just doesn't die.
Jeans exist to pass down our hopes and dreams for the future
for our children.
Living is a link to what will come.
All life is tethered to the future.
That's exactly why I got this egg egg.
Because that part is so funny.
Then the world can change.
He just keeps going.
He just keeps sliding.
The true meaning of life.
I can't even listen to Naomi.
Oh gosh.
Okay, she's finally done.
This is what Meryl died for.
Until today, I've only lived for myself.
Survival has been the only thing I cared about in my life.
That's not just you.
That's how everyone is.
I only felt truly alive when I was staring death in the
face.
I don't know.
Maybe it's written into my genes.
Your genes.
what about now I want to enjoy life I really do yeah how
about you lot of con me I feel like a new man like how that
implied that no one was listening to me no science and
technology are fine but the music is so whimsical are my
interest now sounds good the whole reason i got into science
in the first place was because i was no good with people i
was scared of them i was scared of life i thought that i
could never understand them because they're so illogical but
i've finally learned how to like people there's no reason
for me to be afraid anymore you and i are more alike than i
thought No!
I'm no wolf.
But I'm not gonna just stand on the sidelines anymore.
You're so isomotical.
I'm gonna stand on my own two feet.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna hide anymore.
You're giving up your stealth camo.
Huh?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I've seen this scene quite a few times.
You can have it.
Oh god, I'm tears streaming to my face.
Oh god, I'm crying.
I'm laughing so hard.
This is where we say goodbye to my loves as well.
Oh, I'm in.
Our new loves, though.
I mean.
That's why Snake doesn't say anything.
Want me to drive?
No thanks.
I'd rather do it myself.
No problem.
Yeah, your driving was kind of, you know.
Where to, Snake?
my real name is David Otacon I'm Hal Dave oh that's right
Hal Hal and Dave that's a good one maybe we should take a
trip to Jupiter oh god I think it's time for me to look for
a new path at life a new path a new purpose Will you find
it?
I'll find it.
I've already found it.
I know I'll find it.
Sorry, I'm freaking out over my own delusions.
I don't think I'm okay in the head.
God, I'm crying.
The 1980s.
There were more than 60,000 nuclear warheads in the world at
all times.
The total destructive power amounted to one million times
that of the Hiroshima A-bomb.
In January 1993, START II was assigned, oh, it was signed,
and the United States and Russia agreed to reduce the number
of deployed strategic nuclear warheads to 3,000 to 3,500 in
each nation by the end of the year 2007.
However, as of 2003, there still exists more than 20,000
nuclear warheads in the world.
Time to reveal my favorite theory.
The Twin Snakes is actually your retelling of the events of
MGS.
Always a real treat to see in playing these games and
sharing your passion.
This song brings back so many memories.
Yippee!
It was definitely not as dramatic as maybe the first time I
played MGS1.
But I still had so much fun with this.
Congrats on finishing Twin Snakes!
Pyrobug thinks we're the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
It's an absolute riot experiencing it with you.
I'm so glad we got to see you streaming.
Yeah!
I'm so glad that I streamed it.
I can't hit the high notes right now.
My throat's still.
No!
Oh!
Almost no tension in the boss battles, unfortunately.
It's so funny.
The one that I struggled with the most was the tank.
The tank of all things.
But yeah, in this it makes the boss battle so easy.
But, I think it's also worth just playing because of the
redone cutscenes and everything too.
Even though some of them I don't like as much.
But thank you for finishing Twin Snakes, boss.
This is good, isn't it?
Don't make me cry before!
gonna choose life too yeah sure thing Naomi see you in MGS4
so true gosh Naomi you oh so cute oh little me's little wolf
oh sniper wolf little bears some say Otacon is still falling
to this day
This song is so awesome.
So cute.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Sorry if I said your name wrong.
I don't know
the words.
It's not...
What's the language again?
I'm not sure.
Wow, thank you for the aquasupa!
No.
Just found the director.
Godzilla Final War made all the cutscenes for this game.
No wonder why Snake kept doing the Matrix only.
Yeah, exactly.
Thanks for having had another wild ride.
Congratulations, I made it to the game.
Thank you, Fikni!
Thank you for that, Kusubo!
Down!
Thank you for the 20k.
Thank you so much.
Gaelic!
Gaelic, yeah.
Or Celtic.
Which is it?
Celtic?
Glad you have joined MGS Matrix Edition.
Welcome back from Outer Heaven.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Oh, man.
Shirokuma!
Thank you, brother.
Thank you for that.
Thank you.
Of course, we have to wait for the ending.
Oh, it's one of the enders!
Thank you.
It's fun seeing you experience something that was both
familiar and different, right?
Can't wait to see what other Metal Gear shenanigans you
might have in the future.
Replays, Delta Acid, Monkeys, Smash, a lot of possibilities.
Yeah.
I gotta...
I gotta hold my titles.
The Metal Gear VTuber.
Or maybe reclaim it.
Yanwei, thank you.
You've seen Mitchell Hammond's Metal Gear MSX animations.
As of 2023, there are 12,512 nuclear warheads.
Okay.
That could be less.
They wanted 3,000, but, um...
You know.
Congrats on finishing the...
Thank you, Maya!
Yeah.
The VTuber to surpass Metal Gear.
So glad I could return to MGS1.
One twin snakes.
Oh, but...
Twin snakes...
You mustn't allow yourself to be a gene to fate.
To be ruled by your genes.
Humans can choose the type of life they want to live.
She always has to have the last line.
She thinks she's the main character when Ocelot is the main
character.
The important thing is...
And then Meryl died.
Meryl walks in to grab a coffee, side eyes on a corner.
Thank you for the pig.
Just live.
Yes, sir.
unit was wiped out yes yes sir yes sir yes sir those two are
still alive yes sir vector yes sir yes I should become
activated soon right on schedule yes sir yes sir I recovered
all of Rex's dummy warhead data
They've all been deleted from the base's computer.
No, sir.
Yes.
Oh, no, sir.
My cover is intact.
Nobody knows who I really am.
Yes, sir.
Yes, the dapper chief knew my identity.
What he's been disposed of.
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Liquid is dead.
The inferior one was the winner after all.
We were the inferior one?
Until Leverian.
and Liquid thought he was the inferior one.
Of course, the other one thinks so too.
Yes, sir.
I agree completely.
It takes a well-balanced individual such as yourself to rule
the world.
No, sir.
Yes.
No, yes, sir.
No, sir.
No, sir, dang it, I missed this.
Someone knows that you were the third one.
Solidus.
Solidus?
What should I do about the woman?
Wait, what?
Yes sir.
The surveillance will continue.
Yes.
Yes sir.
Thank you.
Mr. President.
Bye Mr. President.
Sentin.
Why?
Yippee.
By the way, Vinnie Vinesas knows that you know about...
Wait, what do you mean he knows that I know about the
Daimler Chief?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, there's a whole link and everything!
Yes, sir.
Clear code.
My code is hyena.
What's hyena mean?
I got stealth!
Save.
Yeah, we'll save.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
He reacted to a chat message about it.
Oh, wait, what?
No way!
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Oh, that was so fun!
That was so fun.
I was still at doing a Mega Tri-Depression.
Oh, impersonation, yeah.
I always go on about it, but Game Boy Metal Gear is
essentially Metal Gear 3.
Acid 1 is the game that is the closet closet close oh
closest to MGS 1 sequel vibes wise I don't know about a
sequel it's really weird code hyena means you're pretty good
oh my gosh wrong for rabbit you can sing you can sing holy
cow I was watching your videos You think so well Ha-Yan is
an anagram of Henya.
It was meant to be Yagi Kenya!
Thank you!
Oh, there we go.
Okay, I don't want to wear out my the CDs so much, but thank
you.
Metal Gear Solid Twin Snakes?
It was an honor.
What's under?
Wait, let's see the special real quick.
Oh!
I never got a camera.
How do I get the camera?
Hmm.
Boss survival.
Oh, cool.
Previous operations.
What?
Emo theater.
Auto-Con chapter.
Wait.
Wait, does it have the MSX games on here?
I had no idea.
They're definitely weird.
But the juice is worth the squeeze.
Oh my gosh, so many that we never got.
Okay, I have to press manually.
Go, go, go, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, uh, normal?
There we go.
Oh, oh, there, there, there, there, there!
Hmm.
There's only 28.
The viewer is literally nothing.
Maybe because we don't have their date of birth or anything.
It's kind of lame.
Okay, never mind.
That's all it is.
Okay, I'm gonna test this real quick.
Oh!
We got baited so hard.
It's just a summary.
Wait.
Oh my god, look at it!
Look at young snake in the back!
Look at him, he's so baby!
Jabayden.
Jabayden, jabayden.
This baby!
Cool.
Welp.
Okay, I'm gonna turn off my GameCube now.
Actually, hold on, give me a second.
We're gonna move over to...
What the heck?
Oh, never mind.
Give me a second.
Here we go.
There we go.
Oh, and you can't hear anymore.
And off!
Here we go.
Turn it off.
Let me put on some...
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
Oh, wait.
Did I mess it up?
It's mostly fine.
Sometimes if I put it on the wrong way, it sticks to my
bangs instead and it becomes weird.
The...
Oh, wait.
Stop it!
Do...
There was a Japanese collector's console bundle for this,
which comes with NES Metal Gear on a separate disc.
Oh, that's so awesome.
Let me get some music real quick, you guys.
Give me a second.
Beep.
Oh, bing.
Ah.
Wow, I feel so...
So good.
I feel so good.
That was so much fun.
Even if the bosses aren't like super difficult, still a lot
of fun.
It also makes you feel good when you're just like, yeah, I
can beat it easily.
Any chance of the Zone of the Enders playthrough at some
point boss?
It's a series near and dear to my heart for being my
introduction to Kojima-san.
too so um it's not like a it's a it's a it's an eventually
so yes but i don't know when just uh and eventually the
oselite fight fight was so much easier every fight was so
much easier it was so funny and i couldn't get the cheese
for quite a few of them but we kind of cheesed uh raven
Vulcan Raven Oh But yeah So much fun
What did you guys think?
Did you guys like it?
Try Ghost Babel I Um Want to I do I do Why Hello?
Why do I keep breathing?
Uh oh Uh oh Everything okay Might need to Might need to Let
my computer rest a little bit today I'm just now becoming a
fan hi kyle congratulations for getting this ending between
the original mgs and this game yeah i'd really choose the
former on your time look up metal gear stereo tv see you
then thanks kyle thank you for the pink just b-e-c-r look at
the membership thank you um oh my gosh why do i keep
freezing what's going on
Can you see me?
Uh, uh, I'm frozen.
Uh, I'm, I'm, oh,
I'm frozen.
Hold on, give me a second.
I'm gonna disappear.
I think maybe my webcam is overheating.
Okay.
It might be overheating.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'm here.
I'm a ghost.
I can just poof in and out of existence, you know?
I can poof in and out of existence.
I actually got really lucky with this because I was like,
you know, I was like, I'm going to come back.
but in the past i used my giant ipad and i was like i don't
really have room for my ipad on my desk i don't know what to
do and then my friend was just like well actually i have a i
have an iphone that i can sell to you thank you for the pipe
gift and thank you um and it's it's an older it's an older
iphone They bought it because they thought that, um, well,
not they thought it.
Well, yes, they, they thought that they had lost their
phone.
And so they bought it.
And then they ended up not needing it.
So, super duper lucky.
Yeah.
So, I was like, otherwise I would have had to probably buy,
like, a whole new phone.
How old is old?
This is a 10X.
I think it's the first phone that introduced like the the
the better stuff for V-tubing yeah it's the first one with
tracking yeah yeah yeah so it ended up working out really
well
yeah that's the iPhone X X 2017 isn't retro It's still new,
right?
Yeah, still new Thank you for this interesting Oh, sorry, in
testing No, I'm just kidding Experience with MGS And
teaching me love can bloom In the battlefield Mia Chan,
thank you Mm-hmm 100% can bloom We're a sting glitch phase
Thanks for the five Thank you Can you use an Android or
iPhone only?
I think I don't know if maybe now more recent.
I don't know.
If more recent
Android phones can be used.
I'm not sure, to be honest.
This is all still new to me.
Paperbacks, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Hey, boss.
I'm here to remind you to talk to your Kamiyoshi.
I have!
In fact, now.
I'm not gonna say.
But I saw, like, a clip where she was like, if Mint wants to
collab with me, she has to suffer.
What does that mean?
Oh, I saw that one.
Yes, sir.
What is that game?
And here's an S.
No, sir.
What's the first game?
What's it called?
Is it on Steam?
Well, I'm looking for it.
What's it called?
Sisyphus?
Oh, the game of Sisyphus?
Roll the boulder to the top.
Oh, this looks like...
Like, real kusage.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, no.
Um...
If I have to play it...
But, um...
To collab with her!
She's superficial.
Her words are very difficult.
It's very difficult.
Yeah.
She's selfish.
Maybe she meant to say, Why are we still here?
Just to suffer.
You can do a mint, I believe in you.
Do it for her.
Why?
I guess I have to suffer for my kamiyoshi.
But it's okay if my kamiyoshi wants me to suffer, then I
don't mind it so much.
Make Kenya play Atlantis no Nazo.
We gotta play Atlantis no Nazo, you guys!
Well do we?
Do we actually?
I say that but now I'm like, wait a minute.
Do I actually have to play that?
Hmm.
Do you want to?
Yeah, I do want to play it, actually.
I think it's fun to also play games like that.
It's a challenge.
I'll increase my gamer, my gamer skills.
Thank you!
Space ghost, coast to coast.
Congrats on beating the game!
I really love how over the top all the animations were in
this one.
I was dying over Snake dodging the bullets while in the car
chase.
I know it's so, there's so much going on.
Yes, Minto.
No Minto.
Of course, Madame Ghost.
I am Dragon.
Thank you for the 10 gift!
Blue Echo Echo the Mambo Show.
Seymour, thank you.
Marilyn, thank you.
I really like the OG better, but this is a really fun
alternative take.
Yeah, of course.
I agree.
I like the OG better.
But this one is also so silly, goofy, fun.
I think I just love every Metal Gear.
I think I just...
I can't...
Just say that I like one more than the other.
that but you know what i mean like i just can't say like
this is the bad one
they're all really good play snap i want to play snatcher
i'm gonna play police nots i want to play snatcher um i own
police nots still looking for snatcher unfortunately
unfortunately prove it by a second pachinko machine have
them stare at each other.
Oh my god.
It's Isola.
We really thank you.
But.
Hmm.
There's so many games I want to play.
So.
But we have time.
We have time.
No worries.
I don't want to.
I don't want to rush through everything.
So fast.
You know.
And then be like.
burnt out a little bit or something.
I don't know.
Revolver isolate.
Parentheses.
Make them kiss.
Play what you enjoy.
Yeah.
So far I am.
So far.
I mean.
It's what like whatever.
You know.
I'm just like.
It's like, whatever, like...
It's not like I'm having a blast or anything.
It's not like I'm having the time of my afterlife or
anything.
It's just like, you know.
Revolver patch is on.
My time of my afterlife.
Wink.
Wink, kawaii, wink!
Just...
Chir- Chir- Chir- Wink, chir- Wink, chir- Chir- Chir- Chir-
Chir- Would you consider heart, gold, soul, silver?
Maybe.
It's...
I don't think I ever actually played...
Oh, sorry.
I don't think I actually played Heart Gold or Soul Silver.
Say that.
Oh, I've never played...
I've played Original Golden Silver, but I've never played
the Remix.
I don't...
I actually don't...
So I don't own them either.
Pokemon games sell...
They're so expensive.
Even secondhand.
Like, let's see.
Hold on.
If I go to eBay...
eBay .com.
Heart gold.
What's it for?
Oh, it's a DS game.
So I can play it on my 3DS.
Oh, wait.
This isn't so bad.
It's 40.
It's 40 without the case.
I don't need the case.
Let's see.
Soul silver.
I always get Soul silver.
Or I played silver before.
because I like Lugia.
Mmm.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
A thousand and one.
What?
Pokemon Soul Silver, Walmart exclusive.
Big box rare.
See notes.
USA seller.
A thousand and one dollars with 22 bids.
Wait.
What's the notes?
What?
Why is it so expensive?
It comes with a Lugia figure and a Lugia figure.
poke walker jacket it doesn't even come with the poke walker
oh wait is it it does it does come with the poke walker just
kidding wow that's a lot of money and it comes with like all
the sleeves and everything that comes inside sheesh i didn't
know there was a walker i had a digi Wait, I did have a
Pikachu one When I was a kid And I had a Digimon one Um For
some reason I never had a Tamagotchi Oh my gosh, this ends
in 22 minutes Wait, I kind of want to see how high does it
get Okay, it's still at a thousand and one When's the last
bid?
Oh, I don't have an eBay account Or I do, but I don't
remember the login Debi Orange Hey boss, exciting news I got
you guys myself a crush but the problem is she's cold and
she's cruel but she knows what she's doing she pushed me in
the pool at her last school reunion she thank you deadbeat
orange no surprise I saw someone on eBay sale final fantasy
7 OG for 20k what I had a Tamagotchi I never had one but I
had the Pikachu one and the Digimon one.
It's not that I didn't want one.
I think my mom just...
It was always my mom that I would ask.
Wait, there's another one.
This one, the heart gold one is even more expensive.
Ends in 14 minutes with only 17 bits.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
If you ever wanted to cover The Best is Yet to Come, Donna
Burke did do English lyrics cover.
Yes, I've seen that before.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Since you own Ace Combat 3, which Ace Combat 3 do you have
meant?
Is it from the global version or the JP version?
I will check.
I got it a long while ago, so I don't remember.
I will check though.
Tamagotchi, Natsukashi.
Natsukashi, you know?
I just wanted to.
Tamagotchi is so great.
Tamagotchi's now are so different.
They're so crazy.
They're like...
They have like the LED screens and everything.
Panda!
Welcome to Membushop.
Thank you!
Snatchu on a GameCube and he enters another big game made by
studio that co-developed Twin Snakes Eternal Darkness.
I... If you guys have any...
Since like I said, I never had a GameCube growing up, if you
guys have any GameCube recommendations, please let me know.
No, I will definitely see if I can find it and I will play
it.
If I'm interested, of course, obviously.
But, you know, I'm open to anything, you know.
I'm in boot camp.
I'm so tired.
Please give me out.
Pawn!
Ganbari!
Gotcha force.
Get out of here, mod.
Mario Sunshine.
Mario Sunshine!
I've still been playing Korone, the wow, wow, wow, Korone
box.
Leave them in the comments though.
Like, uh, OG Resident Evil 4 is for the GameCube.
Oh, really?
But, um, yeah, leave it in the comments because if you put
it here, I'll forget.
So once the VOD is up.
Comment, like, for engagement.
That way I can go back through and see.
I realize I have not had dinner.
And it's almost 11 p.m.
And as much as I want to keep talking with you guys.
I'm starting to feel my head get foggy.
All I had was some twin snake Haribo gummies.
Which I was going to make this into my thumbnail.
I was going to print out a picture.
And take a picture of.
I was going to print out like a fan art.
And.
And cut it out.
And paste it onto the.
Twin snakes.
Packaging.
And take a picture.
And use that as my thumbnail.
But then.
I saw the.
The thumbnail art.
And I was like.
This is just so beautiful.
I have to.
I have to use this.
Spank.
thank you dinner in bio yeah I have to go I'm probably gonna
go make some eggs and tomatoes because I gotta finish up my
eggs or if anyone is having a delicious meal please let me
know one so that I can bless it with my moi moi kum powers
and two so I can possess you and eat it myself
oh I think the stream labs are a little backed up but I
could still read them on my end yeah i made eggs and
tomatoes too today it's so yummy i'm having a burger right
now rogu i'm coming over um hey don't finish it right after
this i'm possessing your body give leave me like the last
bite for me okay she's quesadilla a while ago that doesn't
help me i need it now
Stop.
You guys are...
Yummy.
Having a bacon omelet.
No, I need my nutrition.
You're still gonna get it.
I just get the taste.
You know?
Mm-mm.
Oh.
Okay.
Tomorrow I have a pretty long day.
Oh.
If you are close to...
Wait, where is this at again?
I'm doing an event tomorrow called Kusa Land, which is an
anime DJ event.
I will be singing.
I will be performing.
Not doing...
Not doing, you know...
The DJing.
But if you are in...
Hold on.
What?
Uh, any party.
Uh, go to at any, wait.
Account suspended.
Uh oh.
Wait, I don't think that's the right one.
Thank you.
Wait, uh, wait, I retweeted it.
Where is it?
Oh, oh, at any song party.
sorry my bad at any song party on twitter it's in if you're
close to virginia virginia america then i will be there
singing it's it's pretty short it's just a couple songs but
spring yes springfield virginia i don't know where that is
but uh if you like things like doing calls and mixes.
You know?
You're like, Taiga, Faya, Saiba.
If you want to experience that, listen to anime music and
meet people that like anime music, you should go.
Part of the DC metropolitan area.
It's part of the DC metropolitan area.
That's only five hours away.
About 20 to 30 minutes south of DC.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
If not, maybe off Kai, maybe somewhere else.
We'll have to see.
And if anyone, if anywhere else, once, once, or you can
recommend me as a guest to your favorite anime convention in
your area.
And then maybe they'll accept me as a guest.
And then maybe I can see you there.
Yeah.
When is it?
Tomorrow.
It's tomorrow night!
I'll retweet it again on my Twitter, but go...
You can go to at any song party on Twitter as well to see
the information.
It's tomorrow!
Tomorrow!
Ina intensifiers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, guys, I'm gonna go...
i'm gonna go eat and i'll see you guys not tomorrow well
maybe tomorrow if i see you there um if not i'm going to see
you on sunday yeah
i checked for anime myc and the guests have to apply
themselves as much as i'd like to i'm unable to request you
well we'll see we shall see became a member today so this
was my stream no way really i have to go now but i had a
great time look forward to the next one thank you so much
tick tock tiger thank you have a good night have a good
night thanks for sticking around for so long too really
appreciate it um thanks for the stream thank you guys thank
you thank you uh sunday i'm still figuring out what i want
to do well we'll figure i'll figure it out
Please go to AMYC.
It's not up to me, but I'll do my best, I guess.
Will the Kusalan performances be streamed at all?
Yes!
It will be streamed on Twitch.
They have a Twitch.
I'm pretty sure it's...
Wait, hold on.
Any song party.
I'm pretty sure they're on Twitch at the same name.
At least they told me it would be streamed.
Yes, on Twitch, Annie Song Party.
So it will be, it should be.
It should be also on there too.
Thanks for another fun MGS stream again!
Thank you!
Customer Johnson!
Hal and Dave, or is it Dave and Hal?
I think I actually like Hal and Dave better.
No, Dave and Hal.
Nah.
if you ever end up in salt lake or denver i'll be sure to
get a ticket hope you have a great time tomorrow man thank
you thank you guys thank you thank you okay take care of
yourself have a great weekend um since i might not see you
on saturday but uh get lots of rest if you're working do
your best um do you know when you show up i think it's like
six some six around 6 30 p.m or so if everything goes right
i think series i is on hiatus and i don't have contacts at
anime revolution anymore but i'll try thanks corinn already
i'm gonna go eat everybody thank you so much thank you thank
you thank you um and thanks for letting me finish the twins
next yeah thank you guys i really appreciate you all so much
bye bye thank you guys bye bye see you later bye bye
Oh, uh, uh, uh, double, bobo, bobo, bobo, bobo.
This is awkward.
Um.
Ah.
Uh.
Wait.
Why?
Oh, I was gonna say something I forgot.
You know what?
Uh.